AND HUMAN SERVICES I'M ALL
WELCOME EVERYONE HERE -- THIS
HEARING -- WE WILL HAVE TWO
PARTS -- SO PART A IS THE
HEARING WILL FALL THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
AND PART B. WILL BE COVERING
COVERED CALIFORNIA US THAT
OFFICE THE WHITE HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND PART OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
AND BASICALLY WE ARE TAKING UP
ITEMS THAT ARE PART OF THE MAY
REVISE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WE DO HAVE ONE
VOTE ONLY ITEM -- AS PART OF
PART A SO BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
THAT SIX THREE CAN YOU PLEASE --
CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
SENATOR PAN.
ENTER DATA -- STONE.
OKAY SO AGAIN WE JUST HAVE ONE
ITEM. FOR VOTE ONLY -- IT'S FIVE
ONE NATO DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES -- ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW AND DATA ANALYSIS IS
THERE A MOTION ON THIS ITEM.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR TADO
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAN AYE THE TITLE
[inaudible]
THURSTONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT THREE ZERO
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO NEXT ITEM WE HAVE THEIR
ISSUES FOR DISCUSSION SO IT
MIGHT BRING UP -- THE PARM
SOCIAL SERVICES WILL BE COVERING
I HSS.
YOU CAN ASK EVERYONE TO COME UP
TO THE TABLE AND THEN LETTERMAN
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES THE RECORD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR SURE MEMBERS
PITCHER MAKE A CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU HELLO.
JACKIE BRAZIL ELIA.
JANIE BELL LU.
LANCE SAID NAY TAMAKO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SO WHEN WE GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH --
ISSUE NUMBER ONE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY ADMINISTRATION FUNDING --
THANK YOU -- SO THIS FIRST ISSUE
IS SOMEWHAT TECHNICAL WHEN WE
ARE RELEASED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN IN JANUARY THERE WAS A
PROPOSED NEW -- MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT STRUCTURE AND A NEW MAN
ADMIN METHODOLOGY FOR BUDGETING
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR HSS
THERE WAS.
ONE OUTSTANDING ITEM AT THE TIME
WHICH WAS AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES ABOUT THE VOLUME OF
BACKGROUND.
CHECKS THAT THEY HAVE TO PROCESS
INTO A PARTICULAR YEAR WE'VE HAD
THAT CONVERSATION THIS SPRING
WITH THEM WE REVIEWED THE DATA --
ANIME REVISION INCLUDES A LITTLE
MORE THAN THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN COMBINED TOTAL FUNDS
FOR PUBLIC AUTHORITIES SAID TO
PROPERLY BUDGET AND BASED ON THE
ACTUAL EXPERIENCE.
OKAY THANK YOU LA -- ANY
COMMENTS FINANCE COMMENTS
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE RESET LIBBY SANCHEZ ON THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ONE EXPRESS
ENORMOUS APPRECIATION. TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH FAST TO COME UP
WITH A METHODOLOGY THAT WAS MORE
OUT ACCURATELY REFLECTIVE OF THE
NUMBER OF BACKGROUND CHECKS WE
UNDERTAKE AND WE VERY APPRECIATE
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
IN THE MAY REVISED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS FUNDING AND ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK WITH
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES ON WORKING ON
THIS THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE START SEE NO ONE
ELSE AT THE MICROPHONE -- WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
THIS MOVE ON THE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO RESTORATION OF THE 7% ACROSS
THE BOARD REDUCTION.
BY CONTINUING THE GOVERNOR'S A
JANUARY PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THE
THE 7% -- THERE'S ADDITIONAL
MONEY REQUIRED AS A PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO GROW THE THE CHANGE
IN THE VALUE OF THAT 7% REQUIRES
A SLIGHTLY MORE MONEY TO TO BUY
IT OUT.
AND AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO SUSPEND
THE REDUCTION FROM ACTUALLY
OCCURRING IN BUDGET YEAR --
REMAINS UNCHANGED.
YOU L. L..
AS WAS NOTED IN THE AGENDA -- IN
JANUARY THE GOVERNOR DID PROPOSE
IN ADDITION TO RESTORING IT IN
THE BUDGET YEAR -- TO RESTORE
THE SERVICE HOURS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS HOWEVER IN MAY WHILE ON
THE RESTORATION IS STILL TRUE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR THE POLICY
POSITION IS THAT IT WOULD BE
TEMPORARY AND SUNSET -- JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO IT
WOULD BE THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
RAISE GENERAL COMMENTS AROUND
THIS APPROACH THAT WOULD APPLY
TO ISSUES THAT YOU'LL HEAR LATER
ON TODAY ABOUT THESE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY ONGOING COSTA
NATURE'S PROGRAMMATIC
COMMITMENTS -- AND GENERAL
ISSUES WITH REGARDS TO THE
BUDGET HERE MAY NOT REFLECT --
ONGOING ACTUAL COSTS MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAYOR VISION
PROPOSAL AS TO SUNSET THE
RESTORATION DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS DUE TO LOWER THAN
EXPECTED REVENUE.
OVER THE FORECAST PERIOD AN
ONGOING EFFORTS TO CONTAIN
PROGRAM COSTS AS I AGE ASSESSES
ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
HE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YES CENTER STONE.
YEAH [inaudible]
HE I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SUNSET DATE TODAY.
THERE'S A QUESTION WE HAVE A A
GROWING NEED FOR HSS -- I'M A
PART OF THE SILVER SONORA RIGHT
NOW I DON'T FORESEE MYSELF I
MEAN TO USE AYE HSS BUT THERE'S
A GROWING POPULATION THAT NEEDS
NEEDS THAT -- I THINK THAT THIS
SUNSET -- SENDS A A LOT OF FEAR
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT.
DO AN INCREDIBLE JOB OF KEEPING
OUR SENIOR CITIZENS OUT OF
COSTLY HOMES [inaudible]
AND YES THAT THE REVENUE STREAMS
MAY NOT BE SUFFICIENT -- TO COME
IN.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN
CERTAINLY -- LOOK AT IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR BUT TO PUT THIS IN
HERE I THINK IS SENDING A
SHOCKWAVE.
TO THE THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
BASICALLY GET PAID THE MINIMUM
WAGE.
YOU KNOW.
AND YOU KNOW.
WHAT KIND OF A MESSAGE DOES THE
GOVERNOR WANT TO SOUND TOO I. H.
S. WORKERS WHEN WE HAVE A TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
SURPLUS THIS YEAR?
WE SHOULD EVALUATE THE PROGRAM
EVERY YEAR BASED ON IS MERITS
BASED ON REVENUE COMING IN BASED
ON THE DEMAND FOR SERVICES IN
THIS POTENTIAL SAVINGS OF THE
STATE TO INVEST IN I HSS.
WHY ARE WE PUTTING THIS IN HERE
AND BASICALLY CHECKING THE
FOUNDATION FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE STRUGGLING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK TO LIVE AND WHY ARE WE
JUST GONNA DRESSES NEXT YEAR IN
IN THE IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
I THINK WHITES GOVERNOR SETTING
SUCH A SHOCKING MESSAGE TO A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
GETTING AT THE LIGHTS TAKE CARE
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE -- IN
DESPERATE NEED OF THESE SERVICES.
APOLOGIES I WOULD SAY DEAR
QUESTIONS REALLY THIS IS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S INTENT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE BUILDING A STRUCTURE
AND BUDGET.
AND I WOULD KNOW AND THIS BUDGET
YEAR WE ARE PROPOSING TO
CONTINUE RESTORING THE 7% TO THE
TUNE OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND.
AND AS THIS IS AN OUT GOING OUT
YEAR PROPOSAL THERE IS
OPPORTUNITY.
FARK ONGOING CONVERSATIONS.
NO AND I UNDERSTAND AND THAT'S
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF HAVING A
BUDGET YEAR AFTER YEAR -- TO TO
VALUE WAIT THE THE THE NEEDS OF
A PROGRAM THE REVENUE COMING
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHY IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH -- WE CUT.
THE PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE THE MOST
NEEDED SERVICES INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIAN I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S NOT A VERY BOLD
AMBITIOUS PLAN.
HE WANTS TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
THROUGH THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX IN
IN THIS BUDGET AND HE'S MADE IT
VERY CLEAR IN THE STATE OF THE
STATE THAT YOU WANT TO DO THE
SAME THING FOR ALL AGES.
IT IS -- HIS PHILANTHROPY.
ARE WE NOT DOING IT ON THE BACKS
OF PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
MOST HILL -- CONSTITUENTS.
THE BUDGET IS NOTHING MORE THAN
A PRIORITY.
OF OUR NEEDS IN THE STATE AND IT
REPRESENTS OUR VALUES HOW DOES
THE GOVERNOR VALUE PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN FIRM AT HOME AND NEED
CARE.
AGAIN I WOULD REITERATE THIS IS
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US WE ARE
PROPOSING A BUDGET YEAR. TO
RESTORE THE 7% AND THIS IS THE
SITE PROPOSED ON SIZE PART OF
SEVERAL DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN
THIS IS NICELY BUT AYE AYSHA
SAYS IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING PROGRAMS AND SAID THIS
IS A WAY FOR US TO LOOK AT COSTS
AND TO MAKE SURE.
WE ARE HAVING A STRUCTURALLY
SOUND BUDGET AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT IF YOU'RE BALANCING
WHAT APPEARS TO BE THE FUTURE
BUDGETS ON THE BACKS OF THOSE
THAT CANNOT CHAMPION THESE
ISSUES FOR THEMSELVES.
IN THIS WILL BE THE LAST TIME
I'M GONNA BE QUIZZING YOU TODAY
ABOUT A CENSUS BECAUSE OUR
SUNSETS ON MANY PROGRAMS.
THAT I CAN TELL YOU IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY PEOPLE ARE VERY
ANGRY ABOUT IT.
AND WE NEED TO LOOK FOR THE
GOVERNOR KNOW THAT.
IT'S ABOUT TAKING CARE OF THOSE
A CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
AND WE SHOULD BE PUTTING THESE
ARBITRARY -- SUNSETS AND
PROGRAMS AT IN FIGHTING FOR
RESTORATION FOR MANY MANY YEARS
TO COME.
I'M NOT TRYING TO KILL THE
MESSENGER ARTIST -- PROCEDURE
SENDING MY MESSAGE TO THE
GOVERNOR THAT I THINK IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
IS THERE STONE -- I TO SHARE
CENTER SENS CONCERN IN LA IS
CONCERNED -- IS REALLY
APPRECIATE I RECOGNIZE THAT
WHILE THE BUDGET ITSELF IS A ONE
YOUR DOCUMENT -- BUT I CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO LOOK OUT
AT OUT YEARS.
BUT I WOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT --
ON THE 7% CUT CAME ABOUT BECAUSE
OF THE GREAT RECESSION.
ALRIGHT SO.
THIS IS THE RESTORATION OF THE
7% IT'S NOT AND SO REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS WERE
SAYING THAT WILL BE MADE THE CUT.
WHEN I BRING IT BACK BUT THEN
WE'RE GONNA CUT YOU AGAIN?
ABOUT THE FUTURE TWO YEARS FROM
NOW WHATEVER THE CIRCUMSTANCE
OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR WILL WHEN THAT TIME
COMES.
I STILL HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT BUT I'M NOT SURE YEAH I
I DON'T AGREE WITH BUILDING IT
IN.
INTO THE MECHANISM CLEARLY YOU
KNOW IN OUR DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE BUDGET OF COURSE KNOWING TO
LOOK AT THIS YOU WANNA SEE OUT
YOUR IMPACTS -- BUT I THINK AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE ONLY THE
AGING POPULATION WE HAVE A
GROWING NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WHO
ARE LIVING -- WITH.
DISABILITIES WHO NEED TO SUPPORT
SO THEY CAN LEAD -- PRODUCTIVE
AND LIVES WERE THERE -- THAT.
THE IDEA THAT. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
WORKING IN THE FIELD AND ALSO
PEOPLE MIGHT CONSIDER WORKING IN
THE FIELD RIGHT.
NO THAT WE BUILT IN A 7% CUT.
AND HAVING THE ISLANDS THAT
UNCERTAINTY WHAT WILL REALLY
HAPPEN I MEAN I THINK THEY HAVE
BUT IT ALWAYS THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO ASSUME OF THE BILL THE
SEND THAT THAT'S WHAT WILL
HAPPEN.
RIGHT I MEAN WE MAY NOT ACTUALLY
DO IT WHEN THE TIME COMES THE
PENDING WHAT'S ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE.
END OF THE ECONOMIC SERVES AS A
POOR ME MAY EVEN DECIDE
HOPEFULLY NOT -- YOU'LL HAVE TO
DECIDE WHAT WHAT WE PRIORITIES
WHAT ELSE WE YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE
WE COTTON THE OTHER BIGGER CUTS
THAT WE LOOK AT IN DIFFERENT
PLACES -- BUT I AM YOU KNOW I I
SHARE WITH LA IS CONCERNED AT
THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT'S AN ONGOING
PROGRAM IT'S IT'S NOT A ONE TIME
SO THAT KIND OF TREATING THIS IS
A ONE TIME.
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY SENDS THE
WRONG SIGNAL AND AND ACTUALLY
UNDERMINES OUR EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES BECAUSE WE'RE
TELLING THE PEOPLE WHO.
MAY BE GOING INTO THIS PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY THE
NEED FOR THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
CHANGE AND YES IT IS ONE THE
FASTEST GROWING PROGRAMS.
I WOULD POINT OUT THOUGH THE
ALTERNATIVES.
THE ALTERNATIVE THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT THAT THE PEOPLE
DISAPPEAR.
NOTHING DID NEED DISAPPEARS IT
GETS PUSHED AND OTHER PLACES IN
FACT.
I BELIEVE LA YOU LOOKED AT THIS
RATE I MEAN THE ALTERNATIVE IS
WE INSTITUTIONALIZE PEOPLE.
AND THEN WHO PAYS FOR MOST OF
THAT WELL ACTUALLY INTERESTING
NO THOUGHT TO US AGAIN RATE
NURSING HOME CARE AT THE DELTA
KERR DAT UNDR MEDICARE AL.
AND SO ACTUALLY [inaudible]
IT.
THE WHO'S US ACTUALLY TO FIGURE
HOW WE SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM SO
WE CAN NOT OF SO ACTUALLY IS A
BUDGET EVEN DUMBER BUDGET
COMMITTEE CELL I MEAN THERE'S A
POLICY ISSUE EVEN FROM A
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT.
I REALLY DO WONDER -- INURED
LONG TERM ANALYSIS DID YOU
FACTOR IN THE FACT THATOKAY WE
DO A 7% CUT WHAT WHAT HAPPENED
THEN TO THE SERVICES.
AND THEN HOW MUCH OF A SHIFT WE
NOW HAVE FROM HSS TO OTHER
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE ALSO TO
PAY FOR AND HOW COST EFFECTIVE
THOSE ARE -- SO I I CERTAINLY --
IN A WOULD APPRECIATE -- BEFORE
I WOULD CERTAINLY EVEN ENTERTAIN
LOOKING AT THIS -- AGREEING TO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS I'D LIKE TO
SEE AN ANALYSIS.
THAT SHOWS THAT EVEN FROM A
PURELY FINANCIAL PLAIN VIEW
ALTHOUGH AGAIN THE SHE'S NOT
JUST FINANCIAL AND WE'LL TALK
ABOUT PEOPLE'S LIVES.
EVEN FINANCIAL VIEW CAN YOU
ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT THIS
ACTUALLY WOULD WORK THIS
ACTUALLY REDUCES OUR OUTGOING
SPENDING MY GUESS IS IT MIGHT
ACTUALLY NOT LET YOU PRETEND
LIKE THIS.
NEEDS TO STOP.
YOU KNOW DISAPPEAR MAN I THINK
THAT'S AN UNWARRANTED ASSUMPTION.
SO -- HOPEFULLY -- THE A JOB FOR
BY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR AND ALSO THE OVERALL
IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING TO PUT
SUNSET ON ON GOING SERVICES I
MEAN WITH A SEVEN OZ
CONVERSATION WE WANT THE
SERVICES OR NOT.
YES WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE OF YOUR COSTS WOULD BE SO.
OKAY.
IS IT IS IT ANY OF BY WAYS ANY
IN AND SUCH ANALYSIS BEEN DONE
AND AND FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
AS I SUGGESTED. ONE THE ANALYSIS
WAS THE MAYOR REVISION FORECAST
WHICH IS NOT PROTECTING A
RECESSION BUT IN MY MIND
RECESSION COVERS ALL AND REVENUE
DECLINES OF NATURE BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE SHIFT TO THEN THE
COST SHIFT THAT COULD HAPPEN AS
A RESULT OF THIS.
THEY'RE LIKE INSIST.
THIS WAS PACIFIC PLAY FOR THAT I
AND JUST LAST COST AND THOSE OUT
YEARS OKAY SO SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THESE IN SILOS.
WE'RE NOT RECOGNIZING THE PEOPLE
HAVE NEEDS.
YOU KNOW WE COULD MAKE A POLICY
CHOICE NOT TO MEET THEM.
RECOGNIZE RIGHT LET'S LET'S E
HONEST WITH PEOPLE THAN OKAY WE
COULD SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
HE CAN AFFORD IT WE'RE NOT TO
PROVIDE IT.
OR SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT ARE A
POLICY PROPOSALS AND COME OUT
AND SAY THAT OTHERWISE THEN MY
AND SAY WELL WE CAN MEET THE
NEEDS BUT WHEN I GO FIGHT THIS
WAY.
THEN WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE IT AND
THE COULD TURN OUT THE
ALTERNATIVE IS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE AND SO I HOPE WE'RE
NOT JUST LOOKING AT THINGS IN
SILOS.
AND WE'RE BEING HONEST ABOUT.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY PROPOSING?
INCIDENT IN THESE PROPOSALS I
RECOGNIZE THOSE CONCERNS OKAY
THANK YOU.
YES SAYS THERE'S NOTHING I'M
GOING TO FALL APART I'M NOT SURE
YOU UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS THAT -- DO WE
ARBITRARILY.
CUT BACK ON THE 7% UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
SOME PEOPLE. TWO SIX SERVICES
AND MORE INSTITUTIONALIZED
SETTINGS SO INSTEAD OF SPENDING
TWELVE BUCKS AN HOUR.
ON HAVING A FAMILY MEMBER OR
FRIEND OR YOU DEDICATED HEALTH
CARE.
PROVIDER -- PROVIDE THE SERVICES
WERE LOOKING AT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IS GOING TO
BE SPENT -- WHICH IS A MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE -- AVENUE -- I HSS IS
A ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM IS A NOT.
IT'S AN ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
WHICH MEANS WERE MANDATED BY LAW
TO GIVE IT.
CERTAINLY IF WE DON'T FIND IT
APPROPRIATELY.
WE CAN RATION IT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE NEED TO EARN A
LIVING WAGE I DON'T SUGGEST THAT
THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO PAY PEOPLE
EIGHT DOLLARS AN HOUR SO THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE TO DESPERATELY NEED THEM.
BUT I THINK THE QUESTION WAS HAS
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DONE A ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS TO
KNOW THAT IF WE CAN EMBARK ON
BUT NOT RESTORING THE FEE
PERMANENTLY.
AND THAT RESULTS IN A LOSS OF
SERVICE.
TO THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL WITH
THE ALTERNATIVE COST.
INSTITUTIONALIZING THOSE BE --
HAS JUST AS DEPARTMENT FINANCE
DENNIS STUDY IN IF YOU HAVEN'T
HAS A PHILLY -- DONE THAT STUDY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BUDGETS ON A MULTI YEAR AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT AND OUR ANALYSIS TO ENSURE
THAT IN THESE OUT YEARS WE ARE
PRODUCING A STRUCTURALLY SOUND
BUDGET.
I WOULD DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE LA OKAY **** BUT BUT YOUR
ANALYSIS IS FLAWED BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED YOU LOOK AT HOW YOUR
BUDGETS AS DECLINING.
BUT YOU DON'T LOOK AT YOUR OUT
YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE
MAINTAINED SO YOU HAVE A FLAWED
ANALYSIS IN MY VIEW DEPARTMENT
OF LA -- CAN YOU RESPOND.
GINNY GIVE ME GINNY FELLOW WITH
THE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS DOCTOR
PAN INDICATED WE DID LOOK AT
THIS YEARS AGO ACTUALLY AND IF
THE CONTEXT WAS QUITE DIFFERENT.
THE PROGRAM WAS QUITE DIFFERENT
AT THE TIME.
BUT THE READ THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION WAS NEARLY A COMPLETE
ELIMINATION THE PROGRAM ABOUT IT
WAS LIKE NEARLY 87% REDUCTION.
SO WE WERE REALLY LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING THE
PROGRAM AND NOT AND DID FIND
THAT.
IT WAS COST EFFECTIVE TO THE
STATE TO HAVE THE PROGRAM.
AND THAT WAS LARGELY BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES ALSO HAVE A SHARE AND
IT'S NOT JUST.
AS YOU SAID IT'S TWELVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR BUT THE STATURE OF THAT
IS ACTUALLY MUCH SMALLER THAN
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT KICKING IN AND THE
COUNTIES.
SO WE DID LOOK AT THAT WE HAVE
NOT LOOKED AT SORT OF THIS
MARGINAL THE 7% DECREASE IN I
THINK OF THAT IT'S A BIT.
OF A TRICK YOUR ANALYSIS TO DO
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN ALL OR
NOTHING SO ASSUMING SOMEONE HAS
TO GO INTO INSTITUTIONALIZED
CARE TODAY -- NUMBER ONE WHAT IS
THE PERCENTAGE OF COST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WITH
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE FEDERAL
CONTRIBUTION WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
IT I'M NOT HOLDING TO A FIGURE
IS THE AVERAGE COST PER DAY THAT
WE WOULD HAVE TO SPELL PER DAY
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT PER DAY.
I THINK THAT AND I'M NOT ARE
MEDI CAL PERSON BUT I NOTICED
THE FEDS PAY ROUGHLY ABOUT 50%
pAND I THINK A NURSING HOME COST
AS UPWARDS OF SIXTY TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TOTAL
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE CLIENT
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT I AGES
US IS THAT IS A BIGGER BANG FOR
THE BUCK IT'S LESS MONEY THERE'S
OTHER EVEN SOMEONE'S IN IN.
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THEY
MAY BE RECEIVING OTHER OTHER
SERVICES AS WELL WHICH IS ALSO
WHAT SORT OF LAYERS ON TOP OF
THE TRICK UNITS OF THIS ANALYSIS
IS THAT IT'S NOT JUST THE I JUST
HAVE COSTS BUT THEN THEY ARE
GETTING OTHER SERVICES BUT BUT I
THINK.
THAT'S A THAT'S A FAIR COMMENT
THAT ON AVERAGE A PERSON IN I
JUST US VERSES IN A NURSING HOME
IS CHEAPER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- PUBLIC
COMMENT.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS TO ANYONE
WITH THE CSU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
PROPOSAL -- THIS TO YOUR SON
SAID IS DEFINITELY A STEP BACK
FROM THE JANUARY PROPOSAL AND I
THINK IT CONTINUES TO LEAD
DIETERS AS PROGRAM AS A WHOLE
KNOW THAT THE NEEDS OF BOTH THE
PROVIDERS AND THE CLIENTS ARE
JUST.
NOT IMPORTANT -- TO THE STATE WE
CONTINUE TO COME BACK HERE YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND WE WOULD MAINTAIN
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
PERMANENT RESTORATION TO THE 7%
AND WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU HIGHLY
CONSIDER -- EXCEPT AND TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO PERMANENTLY
RESTORE THE 7% REDUCTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MARTY EMOTO CALIFORNIA
DISPLACING YOUR COMMUNICATION
NETWORK ALSO FAMILY MEMBER MY
FAMILY HAD TO DEAL WITH ALL
THESE KINDS OF CUTS BACK IN
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS WHEN MY
SISTER WAS STILL ALIVE.
FIRST OF ALL ADVOCATES IN THE
PUBLIC CONFERENCE CALL WITH THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
IN JANUARY WE'RE TOLD.
THAT THE 7% RATE RESTORATION
WOULD BE ONGOING AND THEN TOLL
IN DANCING IN MAY REVISED STATEN
FACT IT ISN'T AN INSULT
INADVERTENTLY PEOPLE WERE MISLED
AND THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT A GOOD
WAY TO TO MOVE FORWARD ON ON ON
POLICY MAKING NUMBER.
TWO THERE'S A RAINY DAY FUND.
AND WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF A
RAINY DAY FUND IF NOT TO PROVIDE
A CUSHION IF TEMPORARY. FOR
SAFETY NET SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
HAS THE TIME TO MAKE MORE
CAREFUL POLICY DECISIONS ON ON
THE IMPACT OF CUTS OR REDUCTIONS
THAT MAY BE NECESSARY. TO YOUR
OR THREE YEARS NOW.
LASTLY NUMBER THREE WE SHOULD
MAKE REDUCTIONS VERY DIFFICULT
TO DO.
AND IT SHOULD BE DELIVERED OF
THERE SHOULD BE A PROCESS WHERE
ADVOCATES THE STATE AND
LEGISLATURE CAN LOOK AT THE CUTS.
PROPOSED IN REAL TIME WE SHOULD
MAKE IT IS DIFFICULT TO DO CUTS
AS IT IS DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW TO
DO INCREASES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN AND SENATOR STONE --
ONE ALIGN MYSELF WITH THOSE
COMMENTS -- CHRISTINE ABOUT HIM
ALTON WITH YOU W. REPRESENTING I
JUST AS WORKERS -- EVERYTHING
THAT IT HAS BEEN SAID 1100%
CORRECT I AM URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO STAND STRONG ON%
THIS DOCTOR PAN WE HEARD THIS
ISSUE LAST MONTH -- THE I IT'S
BEING HELD OPEN BUT WE ARE.
ON BEHALF OF YOU W. PLEASE.
VOTE FOR THE PERMANENT
RESTORATION OF THE 7% I WOULD
KNOW TWO THINGS.
THIS IS.
ATTEMPTING TO BY PASS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IF A
REDUCTION IS NECESSARY DUE TO AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN IN TWO YEARS
WE SHOULD DELIBERATE THAT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND THEN WE CAN HAVE A VOTE AND
DO ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
NORMALLY DO FOR CUTS.
AND NUMBER TWO IN RESPONSE TO
THE OBSERVATION THAT I JUST AS
IS THE FASTEST GROWING PROGRAM
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S TRUE THAT IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND IN FACT I WOULD URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO ALSO ADOPT THE
REQUEST FOR THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ACTUARIAL
ANALYSIS SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN
THE WORK OF CREATING A WAY.
TO INTERVENE WITH MIDDLE CLASS
PEOPLE.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO SPEND DOWN
AND BECOME HSS RECIPIENTS SO
LET'S THINK HOLISTICALLY HERE
THAT IF WE ARE TRYING TO CONTROL
I JUST AS BECAUSE THERE MIGHT BE
ANOTHER WAY TO DO IT THAN JUST
THE REDUCING.
THE ACCESS TO SERVICES SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WELCOME -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE WERE VERY -- DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE THE RETREAT IN THE MAY
REVISE HOW AND THIS ISSUE I
THINK FOR ALL OF THE REASONS
BOTH -- YOU AND SENATOR STONE AT
HAVE POINTED OUT -- AND I I I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT --
MY COLLEAGUES ARE MAKING AS THIS
CREATES A PRESUMPTION THAT THIS
IS WHERE REDUCTIONS WILL HAPPEN.
IN TWO YEARS I GET IT THAT IT'LL
BE SUBJECT TO DISCUSSIONS BUT AT
THE STARTING POINT OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WOULD BE FROM THE
PRESUMPTION.
THAT THIS -- THAT THE INCREASE --
ROLL BACK WOULD BE THE STARTING
POINT FOR THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND
THEN ONE LAST POINT ON THIS THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT -- RETREAT FROM
WHAT IS THE STATE'S ONSTAD --
OBLIGATION AND SO THAT SHOULD
ALWAYS BE KEPT IN MIND THAT --
THAT WE HAVE A BROAD OBLIGATION
TO ENSURE THAT IN EVERY PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE THAT -- THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE LIVING WITHIN
THEIR AT LEAST RESTRICTIVE --
ENVIRONMENT AND AND IN THEIR
HOMES AND IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU.
WELCOME LIBBY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WANT TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH.
THE REQUEST ON BEHALF OF SEIU
AND YOU D. W. TO MAKE THE 7% CUT
REPEAL PERMANENT AND REALLY WANT
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION TO BOTH
DOCTOR PAN AND SENATOR STONE FOR
RAISING THE LINE OF QUESTIONING.
REGARDING THE COSTS THE REAL
COSTS THAT ARE BORN BY CONSUMERS
AND PROVIDERS IF THIS CAUGHT
ISN'T FULLY WORKED STORED IT'S
NOT JUST THE DE HUMANIZING
CHOICES THAT ALL CONSUMERS HAVE
TO MAKE BECAUSE THE ALLOCATION
OF OURS IS BASED ON A NEAT.
SO WHERE TO THOSE 77% OF OURS
COME FROM BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION COSTS WHICH
AS THE LA -- APPROPRIATELY
POINTED OUT OF BETWEEN SIXTY AND
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR BUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HIGH OUR CONSUMERS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOSPITAL IS A AND
THOSE COSTS CAN BE LIMITLESS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE REQUEST
TO THE COMMITTEE TO PERMANENTLY
RESTORE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
NANCY CHANCE CHOICES PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES -- I HAPPEN TO
WORK IN ONE OF THE OTHER SILOS --
IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES PIECE OF THINGS AND I
JUST WANTED TO ECHO WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE IS SAD BUT ALSO
TO SAY I I CAN ASSURE YOU
THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SCHOLARSHIP BECAUSE THE MINUTE
SOMEBODY LOSES.
HOURS AND I HSS AND THEY'RE IN
SUPPORTED LIVING THAT.
SUPPORTED LIVING BUDGET NEEDS TO
BE INCREASED IS TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT.
AND IT I THINK IT IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN NOT BY A LOT BUT
IT IS MORE EXPENSIVE SO GATHER
WILL BE CAUTIOUS NOT JUST
INSTITUTIONALIZATION BUT ALL
KINDS OF SCHOLARSHIPS -- SO I
OPPOSE THE SUNSET ON THE 7%
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEING NO ONE ELSE -- AT I
JUST.
STRATA COULD FIRST OF ALL I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
BUDGET IN THE MONEY. FOR THIS
YEAR -- SO I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
THANKS FOR THAT -- THAT'S AND
ALSO AGREEMENT WITH THAT.
THE ISSUE IS.
VIEWING THIS IS AN ONGOING.
PROGRAM AND AN ONGOING
COMMITMENT AND I THINK YOU HEARD
FROM TESTIMONY AT EIGHT THIS IS
ACTUALLY OF ROLL BACK FROM.
JANUARY.
AND THAT'S VERY CONCERNING --
AND THINK YEAH WE AND WE'VE --
HAD CONVERSATIONS IN THIS VERY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT THINK
ABOUT HOW WE PLAN FOR THE FUTURE
RIGHT WE HAVE AN AGING
POPULATION WE ALSO HAVE.
A LARGER NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO --
FORTUNATELY -- ARE ABLE TO THE
OTHERS WHO HAVE DISABILITIES OR
A WHO WHO WITH THANKS TO THIS
PROGRAM OTHER PROGRAMS -- ARE
ABLE TO LIVE.
IN AND LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT AND IN INDIA FOR
CONTRIBUTING AND BE ABLE TO WORK
ON JOBS DOING LOTS OF OTHER
THINGS AS WELL.
AND THIS.
PROPOSAL TO SENSUALLY SAY IN TWO
YEARS WE'RE GOING TO BE REMAIN
THE CUT UNLESS OTHERWISE.
I THINK SENDS A VERY NEGATIVE
MESSAGE AND ALSO.
DOESN'T REALLY REFLECT I THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S VISION FOR
EXAMPLE HE HAS AGING TASK FORCE
RIGHT AND THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF OUR SAFETY
NET FOR FOR AN AGING POPULATION --
AND SO FORTH SO IT JUST SEEMS SO
INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT ELSE THE
GOVERNOR'S DOING SO CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW WILL.
WELL -- I I HOPE THAT TO AN
ANIMAL ONE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION THE BUDGET
GOVERNOR BUDGING FOR THIS YEAR.
SIDES NO ONE RECOGNIZE THAT.
BUT I I HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WE TRY TO
INCLUDE IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
AND CLEARLY I CAN TELL WEEK WE
WE DISAGREE WITH THIS PROPOSAL
WILL -- THERE'S SOME
CONSIDERATION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT.
HOW THIS REALLY SEEMS TO
CONFLICT WITH -- THE VISION
EXPRESSED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
HI SO WILL NOT HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING.
FEATURING A WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AGAIN.
AS A RESULT A FEDERAL STATUTE
THAT THERE WAS PASSED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO NOW WE WE'VE HAD A
LONG ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE IN THE AYE%
EXERCISE PROGRAM TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WE COMPLY.
WITH IT WITHOUT REQUIREMENT --
AFTER A LOT OF ENGAGEMENT WITH
THEM A LOT OF DISCUSSION WITH
THEM -- WE WE'VE ADOPTED A
COMPLIANCE MECHANISM THROUGH OUR
EXISTING -- ELECTRONIC SERVICES
PORTAL -- AND ALSO A TELEPHONIC --
WELL TO THAT. FOR FOLKS THAT
THAT DON'T HAVE INTERNET ACCESS.
THAT WOULD LEAD TO COMPLIANCE ON
THE THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
PROTOTYPE THEY'VE BEEN TESTED --
WE ARE NOW HEADED TO A JULY ONE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FIRST STEP
THAT WILL BE -- NOTHING NOTHING
DONE IN A LARGE PROGRAM IS DONE
BIG BANG SO WE'RE STARTING WITH --
ONE SMALL PART OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THEM TO OF ALL THE TO BE
VOLUNTEERING TO GO FIRST -- TO
DO THE IMPLEMENTATION THEY'LL BE
A PILOT PERIOD -- FOR THE COUPLE
OF MONSTER TO WORK OUT BUGS.
LOOKAT LOOK AT ENROLLMENT
STRATEGIES THAT WORK AND DON'T
WORK FOR PEOPLE WERE STARTING
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
USING ELECTRONICS SERVICES
PORTAL -- BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT'S EASIEST BUT THEN THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
YET USING NOT FUNCTIONALITY THAT
WILL NEED TO BE REACHED.
POINT BEING IN LA COUNTY IS
STARTING FIRST WE THINK BY
JANUARY WE SHOULD BE THROUGH
MOST OF LA COUNTY.
AND THEN A NUMBER OF OTHER
COUNTIES BEYOND BECAUSE WE MADE
THE DECISION WITH WITH COUNTIES --
THAT LA WOULD GO FIRST -- WHO WE
ARE BRINGING SOME OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN MONEY THAT
WE HAD PLANNED FOR BUDGET YEAR
PLUS ONE INTO THE BUDGET YEAR
BECAUSE WE WILL LA ALONE IS 40%
OF THE CASELOAD?
SO.
I WILL BRING SOME OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION MONEY FROM THE
OUT HERE INTO THE BUDGET YEAR TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
MONEY TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU MILLION.
BUTTONS FINANCE.
MANY MEMBERS.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MAKE WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
ADMINISTER THE AYE TO SAYS
PROGRAM ON YOUR BEHALF.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT MONEY IN
THE MAY REVISION WE WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE FUNDING IN THE MAY
REVISION FOR COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION.
IS ONLY FOR EXISTING CLIENTS AND
PROVIDERS THERE'S NO ONGOING
MONEY FOR NEW -- CLIENTS A NEW
PROVIDERS IN A PROGRAM WITH
GROWTH AND TURNOVER -- THIS IS A
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED A
DIFFICULT PROCESS FOR CLIENTS IN
PROVIDERS TO NAVIGATE.
AND YET THERE'S NO RESOURCES FOR
COUNTIES TO HELP EXPLAIN THE
MORE COMPLICATED REQUIREMENTS OR
TO HELP PEOPLE MANY OF WHOM HAVE.
BEEN SIGNIFICANT COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS SO WE WOULD ASK.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ESTIMATED -- A
NEED FOR A POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH PEOPLE
AND PROVIDERS WHO ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ON THE PROGRAM.
LIBBY SANTOS ON BEHALF OF COPPER
FOR HSS AS WELL AS AT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA WANT -- TO ALIGN
MYSELF.
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MISTER MAC -- THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY A 30% PER YEAR
TURNOVER RATE IN A TRUST US AND
SO WE APPRECIATE THE THE FISCAL
YEAR -- ALLOCATION FOR ON
BOARDING -- PROVIDERS AND
CONSUMERS INTO THE EEVEE PROGRAM
BUT REALLY WE REALLY THINK IT'S
NECESSARY TO HAVE THE EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR OUT YEARS -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME GOOD MORNING
MY THE GRAY REPRESENTING LESS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND ALSO APPRECIATE
THE COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIP IN
ESTABLISHING THE EBV PROGRAM AND
WANTED TO ALSO ASK FOR THE
ONGOING FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME PER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
AND WE JUST WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE ALL THE
EFFORTS HAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH.
IN BEING RESPECTFUL THROUGH
THEIR PRINCIPLES THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A U. V. V.
N. AS WE SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OTHER STATES -- WE CERTAINLY SEE
THAT WERE ON A MUCH BETTER PATH
THAN THOSE OTHER STATES ARE ON
IMPLEMENTATION SO WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL IN THE END TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THERE ARE THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
COUNTIES THAT WE'RE BRINGING
THIS HOME IN THE WAY THAT I
THINK WE WERE ALL INTENDING FROM
THE BEGINNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MCCARTY MOTOS HE CAN'T
FAMILY MEMBER FIRST OF ALL PRE
SHAPE THE WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OVER THE PAST A YEAR AND A HALF
ON EVEY VIS I THINK THE STAFF
FROM THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
SENSITIVE.
ON THIS CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE --
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND ARE ACTUALLY THE PROPOSAL OR
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY FRANK
MECCA.
AND LASTLY THE ISSUE OF VVV AND
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD IS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL SUPPORT THE IDEA
OF THE LA PILOT.
BUT THE RESTORATION ISSUE
REGARDING THE 7%.
IT LIKE A LOT OF THINGS
UNDERMINES THE CREDIBILITY THE
TRUST.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS TRIED TO
BUILD UP WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
URGING THEM TO BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE IS NOT GONNA MOVE FOR WITH
A POLICY THAT'S GOING TO BE
INVASIVE AND TAKE AWAY PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS IN IMPLEMENTING THE V.
THE BUT THEN.
THE STATE GOES BACK ON ITS WORD
ON THE 7% SO IT MAKES IT REALLY
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO TRUST.
AND THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF POLICY
MAKING IS NOT JUST MAKING
POLICIES GOOD OR BAD IS BUILDING
THAT TRUST WITH THE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS -- SO
MAY MAYBE CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT WAS RAISED -- REGARDING AN
ONBOARDING SO PRECIADO THE THE
WORK HERE PEACHES THE
PARTNERSHIP ON DVD I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A CONTENTIOUS ISSUE AND I
THINK -- THAT REALLY APPRECIATE
THE MINISTRATION WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND SOUNDING LIKE
WERE YOU KNOW.
LANDING ON A GOOD PLACE THERE
BUT IN TERMS OF THIS PARTICULAR
pABOUT ON BOARDING AN ANTI WHAT
CAN YOU PLEASE.
THE OF A DRESS THAT YES
CERTAINLY I I'M NOT PERSONALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE CALCULATION
AROUND THE EIGHT POINT SIX
MILLION THAT THAT YOU JUST HEARD --
WHAT I WOULD TELL YOU IS THAT
WE'RE VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
BEING A SUCCESSFUL EFFORT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT PEOPLE
HAVING THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED TO HAVE?
I I WOULD SAY IT'S A LITTLE BIT
SIMILAR TO A COUPLE OTHER AREAS
IN THE BUDGET INCLUDING THE AND
A CAL FRESH EXPANSION TO THE SSI
POPULATION.
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE REAL ACTUAL
DATA ON IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
ACTUAL LEVEL OF EFFORT THAT IT
TAKES?
ON AND WE HAVE OUR COMMITMENT
YOU KNOW HERE AT THE AT THE
TABLE THE IT'S AN ANNUAL BUDGET%
PROCESS AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET IT RIGHT.
WHETHER THAT MONEY IS NEEDED IN
THE BUDGET YEAR OR BUDGET YEAR
PLUS ONE I I'D LIKE TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT --
BUT YOU KNOW CASA CASA WE WANT
THIS TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND WE'RE
OPEN TO REEVALUATING THE NEED
FOR RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE INDEED FACTS SUCCESSFUL
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
OKAY OKAY ANY ANY FOR THE COMING
FROM FINANCE ON THAT.
I JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE MADE ESPECIALLY AROUND
THE FACT THAT AS WE ROLL OUT EBV
WILL HOPEFULLY BE QUE A LOT MORE
DATA AND INFORMATION AND THAT
WAY WE CAN HAVE A INFORMED
PICTURE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL.
I THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE THAT
IF WE NEED TO MAKE MANY
ADJUSTMENTS OR SOMETHING.
YEAH SUPPORT OKAY FOR YOU HAVE A
COMMITMENT WE CAN AT THE END OF
THE HEARING HAVE BEGIN THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND AND CERTAINLY RECOGNIZING
THIS IS A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT
AND SELL WITH.
OKAY THANK YOU ALRIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
MINUTES OF EFFORT INCREASED
COSTS.
OKAY ARE THEY THIS IS MERELY AN
UPDATE TO THE MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT A PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- WE'RE
ADJUSTING AT THIS TIME FOR A
CHANGES IN BOTH CASELOAD AND
AVAILABLE REALIGNMENT REVENUES
AND IN PARAGRAPH A TWO OF THE
BACKGROUND SECTION IT CALLS OUT
WE'RE ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTY FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND.
IN THE MAYOR REVISION -- TO
CONTINUE -- THE THAT THAT
METHODOLOGY.
I THINK YOU ALEJO.
AS WAS MENTIONED THIS MAINTAINS
THE SAME JANUARY PROPOSAL IT'S
JUST GOING TO COST US MORE TO
IMPLEMENT THAT BASED OFF OF
UPDATED I JUST AS COST ESTIMATE
SO NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
RIGHT.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING BATTLE IN COOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF MARIN
CONTRA COSTA AND SEEN YOU GO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS FUNDING THANK
YOU.
TESTING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- JUST
WANT TO REITERATE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE COMMITMENT
FROM THE GOVERNOR TO REVISE THE
COUNTY ACCESS MOE.
AND APPRECIATE INCREASE STATE
GENERAL FUND PROPOSED THE MAYOR
VISION TO MAKE THAT POSSIBLE
THANK YOU.
OKAY AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW PUTTING IN THE RESOURCES TO
HELP -- WITH THE GREEN OF THE
COUNTY SO.
WE CAN JUST.
NOT TRADE OF THE EXPIRED CUTS
WE'D ALL BE HAPPY ARE EIGHT OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN.
ALL RIGHT -- OKAY.
SO.
NEXT UP IS -- BACK WE WE DON'T
COUNT WORKS SO -- DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES CAO WORKS.
WE GOT SOME.
AS YOU'VE HEARD ME TO OBSERVE
THAT AREA OR MANY PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE HERE NO THANK YOU.
OKAY WELL MAYBE WE'LL DO THE
COOK NEW INTRODUCTION FOR THE
PEOPLE THE TABLE ALEJO.
GOOD MORNING TO AS ALAMO DEALIO.
OKAY FINANCE HER WORDS OF
FINANCE ALL RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD
BEGIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- AS YOU FOR ME
TESTIFYING PRIOR HEARINGS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON REVISED ADMIN
BUDGETING METHODOLOGIES FOR A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS -- IN CAL
WORKS WE IN IN AMERICA'S AND
IMPLEMENTED A DAY THE
METHODOLOGY ARE AROUND THAT AND
ALSO -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH --
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION C. SACK IN AND
COUNTIES ON A METHODOLOGY FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
COMPONENT OF THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION.
THERE'S TWO PIECES HERE THERE'S
THE COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER TIME TO
ENGAGE WITH CLIENTS THAT AS WELL
AS THEN THE FUNDING FOR DIRECT
SERVICES THINGS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER THINGS
THAT ENABLE PEOPLE TO GO TO WORK.
THE MAY REVISION REFLECTS --
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT ON THE
TOP OF PGE SIX IN YOUR AGENDA
CALLS OUT AND WE'RE ASKING FOR A
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO TO IMPLEMENT THAT METHODOLOGY --
AND THAT'S BASICALLY THE
PROPOSAL HERE.
THANK.
YOU COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FROM.
IN REVIEWING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS TO CONTINUE UPDATING
COMPONENTS OF THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION AND IN THIS CASE
PARTICULAR TO THE THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES COMPONENT.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED.
TO PROVIDE -- BUDGETING FOR CASE
WORKER LEVELS BASED ON THE BILL
THE LEVEL OF NEED ESTIMATED --
THAT THE THE CAL WORKS
PARTICIPANT NEEDS -- AND SO IN
THIS SENSE IT'S A IT'S A MORE
CUSTOMIZABLE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY AND AND FOR THAT
REASON -- WE THINK IT'S A
PROMISING STEP TOWARD ACCOUNTING
FOR DIFFERENT NEEDS THAT THE
DIFFERENT POWERS CLIENTS MAY
HAVE -- ONE KEY OUTSTANDING
QUESTION THAT THAT WE REYES HAS
TO DO WITH IMPLEMENTATION -- THE
CURRENT METHODOLOGY IS
CALCULATED BASED ON THESE
DIFFERENT NEED LEVELS.
AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL -- SO
THAT THE STATEWIDE DATA IS
ASSESSED AND THE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY IS IS.
DERIVED FROM THOSE NUMBERS AND
THEN AS AS HIS HISTORICALLY THE
CASE THAT APARTMENT INCOME CAN
COLLABORATION WITH THE COUNTIES
DETERMINES HOW TO ALLOCATE THAT
STATEWIDE.
BLOCK WILL CALL IT OUT TO THE
COUNTIES I'M IT'S NOT CLEAR AT
THIS POINT IF.
THAT ALLOCATION WILL BE MADE TO
THE COUNTIES SIMILARLY BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CASES THAT CUSTOMIZABLE LEVEL AT
THE COUNTY. FOR FEDERAL BE
ALLOCATED -- SORT OF BASED ON
PRIOR YEAR LEVELS WITH SOME MORE
MINOR ADJUSTMENTS -- SO WE THINK.
AGAIN PROMISING STEP BUT BUT A
QUESTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
HOW CUSTOMIZABLE TO COUNTY LEVEL
TO TO MAKE THE ALLOCATION.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE.
TALENTS OKAY YES SAYS ANDERSON I
THINK IT WAS SURE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT -- REMAINING
CASE WORK IS THE MOST DIFFICULT
OF ALL THE CASES IN THE COUNTIES --
MAKING THE ARGUMENT THAT IT WAS
GONNA CAR ABOUT TEN HOURS OF
TIME VERSUS FIVE HOURS A TIME
CAN YOU ARTICULATE.
WHAT DATA YOU'RE RELYING ON
THERE SEEMS TO BE QUITE A?
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
ENTITIES ONE TO MAKE SURE THEY
ABLE.
TO SPEND THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WITH THESE -- WHAT THESE PEOPLE?
I I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHERE WE WERE JUST
TALKING THAT WE DON'T LACKING
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT WE DID SURVEY
COUNTIES WE TOOK THEIR DATA WE
PROPOSED WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS A
LOGICAL YOU KNOW.
THE HARDER CASES TAKE MORE TIME
CASES TAKE CLASS I THINK IT'S A
STARTING POINT FOR THAT
CONVERSATION -- I UNDERSTAND
THAT COUNTIES FEEL PRETTY
STRONGLY THAT THE MOST INTENSIVE
CASES TAKE TEN HOURS A MONTH --
I DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION
THAT WOULD TELL ME THAT'S NOT
TRUE OR THAT THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT EITHER -- AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION
EITHER IN THE BUDGET PROCESS OR
THROUGH THE LEARNING OF ACTUAL
EXPERIENCE GOING FORWARD.
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AND THE BUT STILL ALSO A FOLLOW
UP ON SOME QUESTIONS THE LA --
HAD BUT I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE I
GUESS IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU
DEFINE INTENSIVE CASES RIGHT SO
BECAUSE YOU'RE PROBABLY LOOKING.
CLOSELY.
SO IS A DIRECTORY OF A BELL
SHAPED CURVE RATES OF INTENSE
CASES OF PEOPLE AT THE END THE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU CUT OFF HE
CURVE AND THEN -- IS THAT THE
AVERAGE OF THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALWAYS BEAT OUT LIARS AND THEN
OF COURSE SMALLER COUNTIES WILL
HAVE FEWER PEOPLE AVERAGE OUT SO
YOU HAVE MORE VARIATION.
SO I THINK CERTAINLY GETTING
MORE DATA AND GETTING ACCURATE
DATA.
WOULD BE HELPFUL I DO APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED WORK OF THE
DEPARTMENT ALONG WITH THE
COUNTIES AND AND IN DOING THIS --
TO STAY WILL REMIND PEOPLE
BEFORE -- THE THE THE THE
DEPARTMENT THE COUNTIES EMBARKED
ON THIS WE WOULD JUST WORKING ON
A LINEAR MECHANISM WHICH
ACTUALLY UNDERMINE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
DURING GOOD YEARS AND THEN WHEN.
DAD YEARS CAME YOU KNOW WE
ALWAYS PLAY CATCH UP SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS INVESTMENT AND
AND THEN ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZING THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE PUT IN SOME MORE MONEY
DURING THE GOOD YEARS -- TO
MAINTAIN AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WILL THEN BE READY -- IF THE
CASE LET'S GO UP WHEN --
ECONOMIC HARD TIMES A STRIKING
PEOPLE NEED THE HELP SO I REALLY
THINK -- THE PARCHMENT IN THE
HARD WORK ON DOING THIS I THINK
THIS -- METHODOLOGY CERTAINLY
HAS PROMISED BY IF MAYBE YOU CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THE AREAS
QUESTIONS ABOUT SO WE CREATED
FOUR CATEGORIES AND WILL HERE I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM --
THAN PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
COUNTIES ABOUT THIS BUT EXACTLY
AND ARE WE GOING TO EAT. FOR
EACH COUNTY DO WE SAY WELL HOW
MANY PEOPLE YOU HAVE IN EACH
CATEGORY AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ALLOCATION IS TO TAKE STATE WIDE.
DISTRIBUTION AND SAY WELL WE
JUST DIVVY UP BY THE NUMBER OF
CASES YOU HAVE SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT WHAT'S AND COUNTY SO
WHAT WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE
CURRENT DISCUSSION IN TERMS OF
HOW YOU PLAN TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS.
FIRST LET ME START BY CLARIFYING
OR MARKET I MADE EARLIER I
MENTIONED THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES HAS TWO COMPONENTS THE
CASE MANAGEMENT AND DIRECT
SERVICES WE HAVEN'T DONE A
METHODOLOGY ON THE DIRECT
SERVICES PARTS I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WE'RE NOT FINISHED EVEN
THOUGH I SAID WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
THE METHODOLOGY.
SO YOU KNOW THAT THAT SAID -- I
I WOULD DâN THEN GO TO
ANSWERING THE QUESTION MY
ALLOCATION I THINK IT'S
PREMATURE TO TO REALLY HAVE HAVE
PUT ANY THOUGHT INTO THAT --
HISTORICALLY -- LEFT THE FUNDING
HAS BEEN DRIVEN BY CASELOAD FOR
ACTUATION SINCE SO ESSENTIALLY
WE'VE BEEN MARGINALLY BUDGETING
AND BASED ON CASELOAD MOVEMENT
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH COUNTIES
ABOUT WHAT'S APPROPRIATE AND WHO
WEAR THAT CASELOAD IS
GEOGRAPHICALLY MOVING WE'VE
WE'VE ADJUSTED THOSE ALLOCATIONS.
I THINK CONCEPTUALLY THAT'S A
VERY LOGICAL THING HERE THE
POINT IS NOT TO OVER BUDGET SOME
PEOPLE IN UNDER BUDGET OTHERS WE
WANT TO BUDGET WHERE THE
CASELOAD FALLS -- THINGS LIKE AS
AS YOU WERE JUST ALLUDING TO THE
DEFINITION OF WHO FALLS IN WHICH
MARKET IS STILL NOT SETTLED
EITHER.
SO I THINK THERE'S SOME
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN FIRST -- CLICK.
I AM NOT INTERESTED IN BEING
UNFAIR TO ANYBODY AND EVEN IF WE
BUDGET ACCURATELY BASED ON WHERE
WE THINK THAT WORKLOAD IS GOING
TO BE.
THAT COULD BE A BIG OR A SMALL
CHANGE FOR AN INDIVIDUAL COUNTY
AND SO WE THINK ABOUT.
RAMPS FOR THEM AND I OTHER
THINGS THAT PLAY INTO AN
ALLOCATION SO I I WOULD SAY
THERE'S A LOT THAT STILL IN PLAY
BEFORE I COULD TELL YOU HOW
EXACTLY THIS IS GONNA BE
ALLOCATED AND MANY MORE
CONVERSATIONS WOULD NEED TO
HAPPEN BASED ON THE FINAL BUDGET.
AND JUST TO TO CLARIFY A BIT I
THINK WE WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT WOULD BE PREMATURE AT THIS
POINT IF THE ADMINISTRATION HAD.
FULLY WORKED THROUGH -- THOSE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS WE RAISE THE
QUESTION MORE OF A LONG TERM
LACK -- AS WE EXTEND THIS NEW
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES METHODOLOGY
AND BRING IN THE DIRECT SERVICES
COMPONENTS SO IT'S THE FULL
METHODOLOGY SOMETHING TO KEEP IN
MIND AS WE REEVALUATE JUST HOW
FAR THE LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED
IN GOING IN PURSUING THIS MORE
CUSTOMIZABLE APPROACH -- IT'S IN
NO WAY CRITICISM OF DSS WITH THE
COUNTIES AT THIS POINT TO
SOMETHING WE ONE FIVE AND I
REALIZE THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
AND I ACTUALLY JUST WANTING
KNOWLEDGE APPRECIATE THE FACT
WE'RE TAKING ON THIS WORK
BECAUSE AT LEAST AND WE'LL HEAR
VERY SHORTLY -- PLACE I THINK
THIS IS A I MEAN THIS IS AN
IMPROVEMENT.
TYPE THAT DON WHAT WE HAD BEFORE
SO WE'RE OBVIOUSLY WE CAN ALWAYS
IMPROVE THINGS EVEN MORE AND BUT
I I HOPE THAT.
WILL BE SURE WE KEEP THE PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD I REALLY
APPRECIATED MINISTRATION IN THE
COUNTIES IN THE STAKEHOLDERS
WORKING TOGETHER TO DO THIS FOR
SO AT LEAST.
MAY NOT BE PERFECT BUT WILL HAVE
A BETTER SYSTEM THAN WE HAD
BEFORE.
I THINK THAT'S THE GOAL AND I
REALIZED ARE STILL ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS THE FIGURE OUT HOW
TO REFINE AND HOW TO IMPLEMENT
IT'LL PROBABLY BE A MULTI YEAR
DISCUSSION I MEAN ABOUT TO READ
IN A MULTI YEAR DISCUSSION IT'S
ALREADY BEEN.
BUT IT'S BIG IT'S COMPLICATED
STUFF IT'S IMPORTANT RIGHT A LOT
OF MOVING PIECES AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN NOT TO KEEP MAKING
ANALOGIES TO THE CONFERENCE
EXPANSION BUT WE'VE COMMITTED TO
COUNTIES THAT ONCE WE HAVE SOME
DATA ON THAT.
WILL LOOK AT OVERALL HOW WE
BUDGET TO CALPERS PROGRAM I
THINK WHEN YOU IMPLEMENT A NEW
METHODOLOGY IT'S KIND OF A BLACK
A TORRID AND MAKE SURE IT'S
WORKING THE WAY IT WAS INTENDED
AND AND TO CONTINUE TO BE OPEN
TO ADJUSTMENTS GOING FORWARD.
OKAY SO -- I'M SURE WERE.
EAGER TO TELL US HOUSING GOING
FOR YOUR AND OKAY WELCOME.
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FRANK MAY CAUSE YOU TO BE
DAY AND I NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE CHEERS LEADERSHIP ON THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION ISSUE AND
SENATOR STONE SUPPORT -- OUR
PROGRESS AND PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE DEPARMENT OF FINANCE
HAS BEEN REALLY GREAT.
ON THE SINGLE ALLOCATION AND
WE'RE WE'RE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL.
FOR THE PROGRESS IN THE GOOD
FAITH AND SO -- WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
THE COUNTIES ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. TO TO SENATOR
STONE'S POINT THERE'S ONE SORT
OF PRETTY SIGNIFICANT AREA OF
DIFFERENCE AND IT'S HOW
INTENSIVE CARE OF THE CASE OR DO
YOU NEED FOR THE INTENSIVE CASES
AND I SHOULD SAY WE AGREE ON WHO
THEY ARE.
THE METHOD OF STRATIFY AND THERE
IS AGREEMENT IF IT'S AT SOMEONE
THAT SUFFERING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR HOUSING AND SECURITY FOR
EXAMPLE SO THERE'S NO WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE DISAGREEMENT THERE.
IT'S HOW MUCH TIME DOES IT TAKE
A WORKER AND WHAT WE DID WAS WE
ACTUALLY PULLED WE ASK COUNTIES
TO PULL CASES.
TAKE SORT OF IF THERE IS SUCH A
THING OF THE TYPICAL INTENSIVE
CASE.
AND SHOW US WHAT YOU DID BASED
ON OUR PRACTICE ENHANCEMENT
PROJECT THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ON AND IT WAS CONSISTENT FROM
PLASTER LOS ANGELES THOSE CASES
WERE TAKING AT LEAST TEN HOURS.
SO WE'D LIKE THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER
IS INTENT LANGUAGE THAT SAYS NOT
IN BUDGET YEAR BUT I'M BUDGET
YEAR PLUS ONE WE WILL MOVE. TO
I'D ATTEND OUR STANDARD FOR
THOSE INTENSIVE CASES AND
CONTINUE TO REFINE THE OVERALL
ESTIMATE IN THE PROCESS THE
SENSE OF URGENCY FOR US IS THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
IMPLEMENT THE CARROTS OUTCOMES
AN ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW.
SO WE ARE ABOUT TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HOW WE'RE DOING
WITH THIS CASES AND SO.
WE FEEL AN URGENT NEED TO AT
LEAST PUT A MARKER DOWN AND GET
SOME AGREEMENT ON WHERE WE'RE
HEADED -- AS WE EMBARK ON BEING
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE RESULTS.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
SB SANTOS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA ONE ALIGN MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS OF MISTER MAC OF
BOTH THE EXPRESSION OF
APPRECIATION BUT ALSO THE REAL
CONCERN ABOUT THE TEN HOUR
VERSUS FIVE HOUR DIFFERENTIAL --
MY WORKERS KNOW HOW LONG IT
TAKES AND THEY PUT THAT MUCH
TIME IN AND SO WITHOUT THE
BUDGET LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT
IT WILL GO UP TO TEN HOURS THE
CONCERN IS.
IS THAT YOU KNOW THE RESPONSE
WILL BE -- WORKERS ARE GETTING
IT DONE WE DON'T NEED TED FUND
IT MORE LATER ON IT'S REALLY
IMPERATIVE BECAUSE IT REALLY
DOES TAKE THAT MUCH TIME FOR THE
INTENSIVE CASES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
ARE THE REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
ECHO THE STATEMENTS FROM C. WDAM
AND THE PRIOR WITNESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
DOESN'T GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES --
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT HERE AND ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT WENT INTO IT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
UP SO JUST TO CLARIFY ON THE
HOURS BECAUSE IT'S A THAT STILL
WORK IN PROGRESS AND YOU STILL
COLLECTING DATA DAY ABOUT DATA
THEY WISHED OFFERED USER USER IN
THE CURRENT.
BUDGET LANGUAGE A CAP ON THE
INTENSIVE CASES DO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE AN HOUR SET OR NOT.
TIGER WOODS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCING WE JUST NOTE THAT.
BASICALLY WHAT THE WORK WE'VE
DONE SO FAR IS THAT WE'VE SET UP
THIS STRUCTURE AND ANSWER MAC I
WAS TALKING ABOUT STRIVE FINING
FOR DIFFERENT LEVELS OF CASE
INTENSITY AND WHAT.
NEEDS ARE -- WE BELIEVE THAT
THROUGH THAT CAL OR PROCESS
WE'RE GOING TO GET MORE DATA AND
SOME BETTER INSIGHT INTO WHAT
THAT TRUE NEED IT'S A FOR THOSE
ALRIGHT BUT JUST TO CLARIFY BUT
WE PUTTING ANYTHING IS THERE
PROPOSAL TO PUT INTO.
BUDGET LANGUAGE -- INTO THE
ACTUAL BUDGET A STATE LIKE YOU
CAN'T BE HIRED AN EX NUMBER OF
HOURS SO IT SO THERE'S THERE'S
ELECTABILITY FOR YOU IF YOU SAY
IT'S TEN HOURS NEW GREETS AND
OURS WILL BE TEN HOURS.
WE WE ESTIMATED CASELOAD TIMES
NUMBER OF HOURS TO GET TO A
DOLLAR FIGURE TO PUT IN THE
BUDGET BUT THERE'S NO LIMITATION
THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T SPEND MORE
THAN FIVE HOURS ON AN INTENSIVE
CASE IN.
ANY OKAY.
SO I GUESS THEY IS A BUDGET
ASSUMPTION NADA POLICY
LIMITATION OKAY THAT'S WHEN I
CLARIFIED BECAUSE I'D SAY JUST
TO THE WILL OF THE GIVE BE SURE
THERE'S THE FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
ARE NOT BUILDING IN SOMETHING
AND DOESN'T GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT CONVERSATION.
SUIT TO AFTER YOU KNOW GOING
BACK AND FORTH AND RECOGNIZING
YOU MAY HAVE TO IF YOU HAVE TO
MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT YOU KNOW COME
BACK -- BUT THAT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING INTO THE LAW IT INTO THE
BUDGET A SPECIFIC NUMBER OF
HOURS BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SAID
DISEASE POINT OUT YOU STILL
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
YOU'RE STILL COLLECTING DATA AND
SO FORTH IT'S TOO EARLY TO
CODIFY OKAY.
DON'T KNOW THAT I AGREE.
SO I WILL BE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S A GOOD
THAT'S HELPFUL SO I AM I KNOW
YOU AREN'T WELL WHO'S HEALTHY --
TO ONE OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND OKAY.
RIGHT THEY ALSO HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN THEN -- WHAT'S MOVE ON
ISSUE NUMBER TWO CAL WORKS OUT
COMES IN THE COUNTY REVIEW
COUNTY ADMINISTRATION AND I
THINK WE'VE HEARD SOME REFERENCE
TO THIS REVIEW YOU DEAD I I
GUESS I'LL TAKE THE UNUSUAL STEP
OF REFERRING TO MISTER MAC AS
REMARKS A MINUTE AGO THIS IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OUTCOMES.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY -- STRUCTURE
THAT WE SET UP -- WITH THIS IS
COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE COST AND
DATA REPORTING -- COST --
BUDGETING FOR THE THOSE ITEMS.
ON A COMBINATION OF STATE
GENERAL FUND AND AND FEDERAL
TENNIS DOLLARS.
OKAY THANK YOU LA YOU COMMENCE.
FINANCE.
THE MEMBERS OKAY PUBLIC ON IT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
WE SUPPORT THE MAYOR VISION.
OKAY I HAVE A SAID OKAY
FANTASTIC.
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS LIKE THAT SONG
WILL HOLD SIDE OF OPEN AND THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE VICE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITATIONS OPTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I I
THINK WE IN OUR FULLY TITLED
THIS ONE I WANT TO BE CLEAR WE
ARE NOT CHANGING ANY ASSUMPTIONS
HERE WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING
IS ADDING MONEY TO THE BUDGET TO
MAKE TO MEET THE CURRENT
STATUTORY WILL -- PROVISIONS SO
THIS IS ASSEMBLY -- BUDGET
ADJUSTMENT TO TO DO WHAT CURRENT
LAW CURRENTLY REQUIRES OKAY ELIA.
WE'VE REVIEWED THE THE
ADJUSTMENT AND WE CONCUR WITH
THE MINISTER SITUATIONS --
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE CHANGE
OKAY FINANCE.
RIGHT.
MEMBERS PUBLIC COMMENT.
JIM LEHRER IS REPRESENTING
CHILDREN NOW I'M IN SUPPORT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING PROGRAM AND
WHAT NOT THAT WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
TO ASK FOR A LITTLE BIT MORE
MONEY AND SOME -- SEPARATE AND
NO COST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WE THINK WILL HELP AND
ENSURE CLARIFICATION AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
I'M AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU.
MIGHT THE CARRERA'S IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
OKAY THANK YOU.
PRICING NOTES OF MICROPHONE WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FOUR CAL WORKS
STAGE ONE TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY.
BUT YOU YOU PROBABLY ARE
FAMILIAR THAN IN MOST OF OUR
STATE SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY NOW FOR FOR VARIOUS
REASONS THAT WE DON'T NEED TO
GET INTO STAGE ONE THOUSAND AND
PART OF THAT AND WE THINK IT'S
TIME TO IMPLEMENT THAT POLICY IN
STAGE ONE AS WELL.
FAMILIES WHO ENTER STAGE ONE AND
NEED STAGE ONE CHILD CARE ARE
WHERE THEY ARE MOST VULNERABLE
AND THIS IS CERTAINLY THE PLACE
PERHAPS WORSE THAT STABILITY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED FIRST.
THANK YOU AVAIL.
WORD STILL REVIEWING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL -- BUT AT AT FOR SORT
OF FIRST GLANCE IT'S ONE OF THE
MORE MAJOR -- BUDGET PROPOSALS
IN THE COW WORKS WORLD FOR THE
MAY REVISION -- IT WILL MAKE
STAGE ONE CHILD CARE MORE LIKE
STAGE TWO AND THREE IN THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM -- THE THE TO
PURSUE THAT THE LARGEST THROUGH
POLICY COMPONENT FROM
PROGRAMMATIC STANDPOINT IN OUR
VIEW IS -- A CHANGE.
TO THE LENGTH OF DURATION --
THAT A FAMILY RECEIVES CARE IN
STAGE ONE CHILD CARE UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD GO TO TWELVE MONTHS --
UNDER CURRENT PRACTICE COUNTIES
ARE THEMSELVES TO FIND WHEN A
FAMILY IS STABLE AND AT THAT
POINT THE FAMILY WOULD
TRANSITION INTO STAGE TWO OF
THEM A REVISION PROPOSAL THAT
PERIOD CANNOT BE.
SHORTER THAN TWELVE MONTHS SO
WILL BE STANDARDISING THAT THAT
TIME THE FAMILIES IN THE STAGE
ONE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
OKAY COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MCCOURT CWD A WE SUPPORT THE
TWELVE MONTHS CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY IMPACT OUR WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL IN THE ADVOCATES ON
REFINING THE PROPOSAL FOR OVER A
YEAR NOW AND SO -- WE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTED IT
WILL SIMPLIFY.
THE RECEIPT OF CHILD CARE -- WE
ARE ACTUALLY ASKING FOR A CHANGE
AN ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED. TO SEPARATE CHILD CARE
OUT OF THE REST OF THE CAL WORK
SINGLE ALLOCATION SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF CAL WORKS THE
COMPONENTS OF OF THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION HAPPENED FUNGIBLE.
AND THE PROPOSAL WOULD SAY CHILD
CARE IS NO LONGER PART OF THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION ENOUGH
FUNGIBLE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THAT POLICY.
BUT TO IMPOSE IT WITH A MONTH
AND A HALF LEFT BEFORE THE
FISCAL YEAR STARTS FOR COUNTIES.
IS AN UNDUE BURDEN ON US WE'VE
ADOPTED OUR BUDGETS BASED ON THE
TWENTY YEAR PRESIDENT THE FISCAL
YEAR STARTS JULY ONE THAT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT OUR ABILITY
TO HIRE ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AND
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES WORKERS.
SO WE'RE ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO GIVE US A YEAR TO
PHASE THAT IN A TIME CERTAIN.
IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE BUT TO
GIVE US A YEAR TO MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENTS NECESSARY.
YOU FOR THIS REALLY SIGNIFICANT --
RULE OF THE GAME IN TERMS OF HOW
WE FOUND THE OVERALL CAL WORKS
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
ARE THE GRILL REPRESENTED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE'RE ALSO VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND SUPPORT THE POLICY
CHANGE FOR THE TWELVE MONTHS
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY.
HOWEVER WE ARE OPPOSE THE
SEPARATION OF STAGE ONE CHILD
CARE FROM THE SINGLE LOCATION.
THANK YOU WELCOME CAN LOS TOTAL
NOW IN SUPPORT OF THAT
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
TESTING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE
INVESTMENT HERE AND WHAT ALSO
SUPPORT THE REQUEST FOR A ONE
YEAR DELAY TO HELP COUNTIES --
BETTER PREPARE FOR THE CHANGE IN
SINGLE LOCATION THANKS.
THANK YOU WELCOME LEVY SANTOS ON
BEHALF OF US YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
APPRECIATION FOR THE INCREASED
FUNDING.
WANT -- TO UNDERSCORE THE
COMMENTS BY MR MICA REGARDING
THE REQUEST FOR THE ONE YEAR
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION THANK
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ARE ANY OF THE COMMONS
ALRIGHT SO WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN Q..
R. IS MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE KALAN CASE MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS CHANGE.
COLOR IS THE COMPONENT OF THE
COLORS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO PREGNANT AND
PARENTING TEENS -- INVOLVES AN
EDUCATION COMPONENT AS WELL BT
PART OF THE CASE MANAGEMENT
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT WE
ABIDE BY A CASE MANAGEMENT
METHODOLOGY THAT'S ESTABLISHED
BY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FOR FOR OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL.
IT'S A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT SHIFT --
THEY RECENTLY CHANGED THE MODEL
THAT THERE AND HEARING TO IT
KIND OF ALMOST DOUBLES THAT THE
CASE ULTIMATE CASE MANAGEMENT
COMPONENTS SO WE'RE PROPOSING TO
ADD FUNDING. TO FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE SO WE'RE
PROPOSING THAT WE COMPLY WITH
THAT STATUTE ALTHOUGH WE HAVEN'T
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL ON THIS
ISSUE.
THAT THEIR FOOD WE WE KIND OF
PHASE AND AND RAM ALLOW COUNTIES
TO RAMP UP TO GET TO THAT
STANDARD OVER A MULTI YEAR
PERIOD -- AND AND SO THE THIS
FUNDING REFLECTS NOT THE FULL
COST OF DOING SO BUT JUST THE
FIRST YEAR OF MEETING THAT NEW
STANDARD.
THANK YOU EL AL.
FINANCE.
COMMITTEE IN THE NUMBER PUBLIC
COMMENT OKAY.
ARTS WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN I
JUST WANTED AND DIFFICULT TO%
MAKE HIS OWN ON TERMS OF THE
PREVIOUS ISSUE -- TO DO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR SUPPORT
FOR TWELVE MONTHS ELIGIBILITY
CELL I MEAN THE FOR STAGE ONE
SELLING REALIZE OR SOME DETAILS
PEOPLE WORKING OUT -- BUT IT'S
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD.
THIS MENTIONS A BIG CHANGE BUT I
THINK A VERY NEEDEDONE CELL DO
APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER SIX DECREASED TEN OF
FUNNY FOR CAL GRANTS -- I'M NOT
REALLY SURE HOW TO EXPLAIN THIS
ONE WE GIVE A LOT OF MONEY TO
THIS TO NAY COMMISSION EVERY
YEAR TO FIND CAL GRANTS IT'S
SOMETHING OF THAT WHAT WE CALL
THE TENNIS BALANCER IN OUR
BUDGET WE MAKE ALL THE CASELOAD
ADJUSTMENTS IN POLICY
ADJUSTMENTS AND WE LOOK.
AT HOW MUCH TEN IF WE HAVE LEFT
OVER.
AND THEN -- WE ALLOW THIS TO
KIND OF FLUCTUATE -- THERE THERE
IS AN UPPER BOUND SOMEWHERE ON
THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
WITHIN THAT THAT THIS -- FUND IS
TO NAY THAT THEY CAN FIND -- BUT
IN THIS CASE -- WE FIND
OURSELVES PULLING BACK ALMOST
SIX MILLION IN TOWN OFTEN IN A
REVISION.
THANK YOU LA -- FINANCE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
MEMBERS NOW OKAY WE'LL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN -- ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
BUDGET.
THE BILL.
CAL WORKS HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU -- THIS AGAIN IS IS
TECHNICAL -- YOU'RE FAMILIAR OUR
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM OR HSP
IS BEEN GROWING OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS AS IS NATURAL IN ANY
PROGRAM RAMPING UP NOT EVERY
SINGLE DOLLAR HAS BEEN SPENT
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND WE'RE
SIMPLY ASKING THAT LAST YEAR'S
MONEY BE ABLE TO BE ROLLED OVER
INTO THE BUDGET.
YEAR.
THANK YOU L. L..
REVIEW THIS IS A TECHNICAL
CHANGE WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST NO
COMMENTS I THANK YOU FINANCE ALL
RIGHT.
COMMITTEE ANY.
MEMBERS OF A PUBLIC COMMENT
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN.
AND THEN WILL ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
A CHILL BILL LANGUAGE SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX TERMINOLOGY CHANGING
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION.
A LOT LAST YEAR WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THEN THE
SPONSOR OF THIS OF THIS
LEGISLATION THIS IS THIS
LEGISLATION THAT A COUPLE THINGS
THAT RAISE THE OVERPAYMENT
COLLECTION THRESHOLD FROM THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS -- SMALL DOLLARS
ARE NOT COST EFFECTIVE FOR FOR
GOVERNMENT TO GO BACK AND
COLLECT -- SO THAT WAS ONE THING
IT ALSO -- AUTHORIZE THE
EXPUNGEMENT OF OLD DAD IN THE
COW WORKS PROGRAM IF YOU'VE BEEN.
OFFERED FOR A WHILE WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE COLLECTIONS IN A
COUNTY COME BACK IN AND PUT YOU
BACK IN -- AND SO THAT THAT
PROVISION -- ALSO WAS THERE.
IN THE DRAFTING OF THE BILL IT
CAME TO OUR ATTENTION -- THIS IS
THE THE TERM EXPUNGE IS ACTUALLY
COMMONLY USED WHEN WE DELETE OLD
EXPIRED -- ELECTRONIC BENEFIT
TRANSFER BENEFITS OF THINGS THAT
ARE LEFT ON USE ON CARDS FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR ARE EXPUNGED.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING TO CHANGE THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE FOR THE
OVERPAYMENTS ISSUE TO THE WORD
DISCHARGED FROM EXPANSION IS A
FEW INSTANCES WHERE THAT CHANGES.
THE THE OTHER THING THAT -- THAT
WE DISCOVERED -- AND PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE REALIZED AT THE TIME
WAS THAT -- THE WAY THAT WE
WROTE THIS THE CALYX PROGRAM IS
OF COURSE STATE WIDE CLIENTS
MOVE AROUND THEY MAY BE SIR BY
MULTIPLE OF THE SAUCE CONSORTIA
DURING THEIR TIME ON AID.
AND WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
STATEWIDE LOOK YET AT ALL THE
DEBT THAT SOMEBODY HOUSE WITHOUT
AN EXHAUSTED MANUAL EFFORT SO
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
IS TO DELAY -- THAT EXPUNGEMENT
PROCESS THE I'M SORRY THE
DISCHARGE PROCESS.
STILL LEARNING. TO THE TIME THAT
WE HAVE THE CAL SAW SYSTEM IN
PLACE THAT CAN PROVIDE THAT
SINGLE STATEWIDE VIEW FOR PEOPLE
IN A MUCH MORE ECONOMICAL
FASHION.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THE OVERPAYMENT
COLLECTION THRESHOLD REMAINS AT
TWO FIFTY WE'RE NOT PROPOSING TO
DELAY THE ENTIRE BILL JUST THE
PIECES OF IT THAT MAKE IT AND
FEASIBLE TO OPERATE SOONER THAN
NOT.
OKAY THANK YOU HELLO
[inaudible]
THE FINANCE.
MEMBERS.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO I GUESS THIS IS -- WE TO WIN
MENTIONED YESTERDAY THIS IS.
INTEGRATION WITH THE COMPUTER
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW SALAS ERIC SO.
ONE OF THOSE OKAY SO WE ARE
HOLDING THIS ITEM OPEN.
ALL RIGHT I THINK THAT CONCLUDES
PART OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE SUPPORT OF SO MANY
ITEMS THIS YEAR AND IN THE
COMMITTEES.
RELATIONSHIP THAT THANKS BYE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO NEXT UP
IS DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
FIRST EVERYONE COME UP -- WILL.
EVERYONE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
AND WE'LL START WITH THE ISSUE
ONE WHICH IS MAY REVISION
ADJUSTMENTS SO FIRST HAVE
[inaudible] ONE INTRODUCTIONS
AROUND THE TABLE AGAIN. FOR THE
RECORD.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING NANCY
PARCHMENT DIRECTOR DDS.
JOHN WELL DDS.
JIM NIGHT DDS HELLO A NEW
MEDICAL IPO.
MARK NEWTON ALEJO AND IT'S EVEN
PUBLIC FOREIGN FINANCE OKAY
THAT'S WAIT THAT WE GET TO KNOW
YOU ALL YOUR NAMES HE KEEP
HEARING OVER AND OVER AGAIN ALL
RIGHT WONDERFUL.
LET'S START OFF WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE MAY REVISION
ADJUSTMENTS.
YES THANK YOU AGAIN NANCY BARS
AND DIRECTOR DDS -- I'LL JUST GO
AHEAD AND BRIEFLY I'M REFERENCE
YOU TO THE AGENDA WHICH
CORRECTLY STATES -- THE PROPOSED
ADJUSTMENTS SO FOR ME REVISED
INCLUDING -- AN UPDATED NUMBER
OF EIGHT POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL FUNDS.
AND THEN THAT REFLECTS A NET
INCREASE OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION IN
TOTAL FUNDS OVER -- CURRENT YEAR --
SPECIFICALLY TO COMMUNITY
SERVICES PROGRAM WITH THEIR
REGIONAL CENTRES WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR UPDATED POPULATION
THAT IS NOW PROJECTED TO BE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND AND NINETY FOUR THIS
REFLECTS A SLIGHT DECREASE --
JUST OVER OUR PURPOSE --
PROJECTED NUMBER FROM A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- HOWEVER WE
DO REFLECT A PROPOSED AND A DATE
A NUMBER OF SIX HUNDRED AND
BURSTS. SIXTY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION TOTAL FUN AND PURCHASE A
SERVICE IN THIS IS PRIMARILY TO
UPDATED NUMBERS RELATED TO
PARTICULAR KIND OF SERVICE
CATEGORIES SUPPORT SERVICES
MISCELLANEOUS SERVICES -- IS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING KIND OF THAT --
UPDATED NUMBER -- AS A DRIVER.
FOR BUDGET YEAR PROJECTION WE'RE
PROJECTING A CAT CONSUMER
POPULATION WHICH IS REFLECTED AN
UPDATE FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS FOR A TOTAL OF
300-500-00100.
SIXTY ONE ALSO IN THE MAY REVISE
IS PROPOSING -- FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS A. A PROJECTED INCREASE
OVER GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX POINT. NINE
MILLION -- OF TOTAL FUNDS AND
AGAIN -- THAT IS -- COUPLE
THINGS IS DRIVING THAT ONE IS
THE RELATED TO THE CASE LOAD --
VARIANTS THAT IS PROJECTED AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE SERVICE
CATEGORIES IN WHICH WE HAVE
UPDATED NUMBERS FOR EXPENDITURES
ALSO REFLECTS THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENT --
SUSPENSION A UNIFORM HOLIDAY --
AS SOME OF THE PRIMARY DRIVERS --
FOR THE PROJECTED UPDATES STATE
OPERATED -- ON THE AGENDA IS
CORRECTLY REFLECTS THE PROJECTED --
RESIDENTS THAT WILL BE -- FOR
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET YEAR AND
THEN ALSO CORRECTLY REFLECTS THE
PROPOSAL -- FOR THE TOTAL --
SPEND THAT IS UPDATED FOR MAY
REVISE OF THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION TOTAL
FUND FOR THE STATE OPERATING
COMMUNITY FACILITIES WHICH IS
REFLECTING.
A NET INCREASE OF FOURTEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION TOTAL FUN.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED -- TO THE
PROJECTED -- POPULATION AND AND
EXPENDITURES ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
EL AL COMMENTS FINANCE.
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO THE ENDING DODGING
THAT WE HAVE A WE ARE INVESTING
ADDITIONAL NUMBERS RECOGNIZE WE
ALSO CASELOADS AND SO FORTH
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION -- OVERALL.
OVER THE PREVIOUS BUDGET.
I CAN AFTER READING ALL CENTERS
YES.
YES REGAL CENTERS OKAY I SHOULD
NUMBER TWO PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENT.
SO FOR THE PROVIDER -- RATE
ADJUSTMENT I AM THERE'S A COUPLE
QUESTIONS TO THAT ARE PROJECTED
IN HERE FOR ME -- TO RESPOND TO
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AS WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY TALKED ABOUT THERE'S
A PROJECTION -- FOR BUDGET YEAR --
AND AND AS FAR AS AN ANNUALIZED
NUMBER THE PROJECTION FOR THE
PROPOSED SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
ADJUSTMENT IS TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND
WHICH IS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE MILLION THAT'S ANNUALIZED.
BUT FOR NINETEEN TWENTY THE
AGENDA CORRECTLY -- REFLECTS
WHAT IS PROPOSED.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY SO REGARDING
IT SO IT'S A HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
MILLION TOTAL FUND AND THE
NINETY EIGHT MILLION -- WOULD BE
FOR RELATED TO DDS I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE A PORTION
OF THE TOTAL TWO HUNDRED JUST TO
UPDATE THAT IS ALSO REFLECTS THE
D. O. R. PORTION -- THAT YOU
WOULD BE HEARING AND IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE AS WELL.
SO WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT JUST
TO REMIND YOU WITH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENT
IT'S FOCUSED ON TARGETED AREAS --
THAT WE HAD DISCUSSED -- BUT
AGAIN JUST TO REMIND YOU LOOKING
AT COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES ON
THE SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS IN THE
VARIOUS CATEGORIES SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTED LIVING.
AND SO THE QUESTION THAT WAS --
THAT WAS ASKED TO ADDRESS WAS
TALKING ABOUT KIND OF THE THE
GAPS YOU KNOW AND HOW DOES THAT
RELATE TO THE RIGHT STUDY AS WE
HAD DISCUSSED THAT WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE METHODOLOGIES AND
LOOKING AT THE PROJECTION FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENT.
THAT IT WAS RELATED AND INFORMED
BY THE RATE STUDY SO WHEN WE
WERE ARE LOOKING AT THE OVERALL --
RATE ADJUSTMENTS IT IS
APPROXIMATELY 18% FOR THOSE
TARGETED SERVICES.
SO WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
TARGETED SERVICES AS IT COMPARES
TO IF THE RIGHT MODELS WILL WERE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED -- FULLY
IMPLEMENTED COMPARED TO WHAT OUR
CURRENT RATES ARE FOR THOSE
TARGETED AREAS WE WERE ACTUALLY
LET ME BACK UP.
OUR OUR TOTAL -- GREAT STUDY AS
COMPARED TO OUR CURRENT RATES
SHOWS A DIFFERENCE OF ABOUT 40%
ON AN AVERAGE SO THAT'S A
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW WITHIN THE
DIFFERENT SERVICE CATEGORIES AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS BUT ON AVERAGE
40%.
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL AND WE INCLUDE THAT IN
OUR TOTAL YOU KNOW VIEW OF OUR
TOTAL RATE AS WE COMPARED TO THE
RATE STUDY?
THAT 40% IS THEN CHANGED TO A
DIFFERENCE OF 23%.
SO AGAIN IT IT IS FOR ALL OF OUR
SERVICES BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT FOR
YOU IS THAT WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THE TARGETED SERVICES WITH
COMMUNICATOR FACILITIES.
WITH SOME OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT SERVICES THOSE ARE THAT
THE SERVICES THAT DO YOU HAVE IN
COMPARISON WITH THE RATE MODELS
THE GREATEST KIND OF DELTA.
IF YOU WILL BETWEEN CURRENT
RATES AND THEN THE PROPOSED --
SUPPLEMENTAL RTES SO IT'S IT'S
EVERYWHERE FROM ABOUT. 80% AND
THEN LIKE FOR TRANSPORTATION
ASSISTANT YOU KNOW IF THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN THE RIGHT MODELS
IT WOULD BE LIKE AN ADJUSTMENT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND 5%.
SO YOU DO SEE AND IN SOME OF
THESE CATEGORIES IS THE GREATEST
ELEMENT.
I DO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THOUGH
THAT IT'S NOT THE ONLY FACTOR
WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT OUR
TARGETED PROJECTIONS WE'RE NOT
JUST LOOKING AT KIND OF THE
GREATEST GAP AS COMPARED TO THE
RATE STUDY.
WERE ALSO TAKING A LOOK AT FOR
COMMUNICATOR FACILITIES THAT
THAT IS THE AREA THAT WE ARE
SEEN.
THE REDUCTION OF ACTUAL
PROVIDERS -- NOT ONLY RELATIVE
TO THE CONSUMER POPULATION BUT
JUST IN GENERAL WERE SEEN THAT
REDUCTION AND IN THE ARM LEVEL
PROVIDERS.
WE ALSO ARE ARE LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT MODELS THAT ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE H. CBS.
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT WE WE CAPTURE AND
REIMBURSEMENTS.
AND SO CERTAINLY WITHIN THOSE WE
HAD TALKED ABOUT THAT THEY ARE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH EIGHT CBS --
IT'S ALSO WITH OUR EMPLOYMENT
FIRST POLICY WITH A SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT.
THE OTHER PART THAT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANTTHAT THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE POINT
OUT.
IS REALLY MOVING THAT NEEDLE
BETWEEN THE IN EQUITY BETWEEN
THE DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
EXISTING RATES CERTAINLY PRESENT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING
THAT THE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENTS.
IS GOING TO FULLY SHRINK THAT
GAP BUT IT IS DEFINITELY TAKING
A LOOK AT HOW TO MOVE HAT
NEEDLE FORWARD.
SO -- AS FAR AS TAKING A LOOK AT
THE QUESTION THAT YOU HAVE IN
YOUR AGENDA ASKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW LOOKING AT THE
ADVOCATES PROPOSAL OF THE 8% I
CERTAINLY CAN'T SPEAK TO KIND OF
THE THEIR INTENT BEHIND THAT 8%
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY.
IS THAT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE DIFFERENT OPTIONS A
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF OF
CONTINUING TO PERPETUATE THE
CONCERN OF THAT IN EQUITY
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT PROVIDERS
AND THE DIFFERENT SERVICES.
THAT DOING AN ACROSS THE BOARD
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THE DOUBT WOULD WOULD
CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE.
THE CONCERN THAT WE WOULD HAVE
IN KIND OF KEEPING THAT KIND OF
STAGNANT WE WOULD NOT BE KIND OF
FOCUS IN ON SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS.
NOT SUGGESTING BECAUSE ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE IS
THAT HOW DOES THAT COMPARE TO
THE GAPS FOR THOSE SERVICES THAT
ARE NOT INCLUDING THE TARGETED.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT THERE'S
NOT STILL SOME PARTICULAR ISSUES
THAT ARE WITHIN KIND OF OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM BUT AGAIN GETTING
TO THE POINT OF SAYING LOOK WE
DO NEED TO HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION AND AND REALLY OVER.
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS WE ARE
GOING TO BE HAVING THAT WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW A WHAT IS
THE THE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
AS FAR AS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT.
ORDER THE DRIVERS AS FAR AS OUR
EXPENDITURES YEAH WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT THAT YEAR OVER YEAR KIND
OF DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
WITH WITH REGIONAL CENTER --
PURCHASE A SERVICE EXPENDITURES
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
INCREASE THAT WE ARE SEEN IN OUR
EXPENDITURES AND AND THAT HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
ADDRESSED OVER THE MANY YEARS
AND WE DO WANT TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT.
MORE FULLY SO HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF I MISSED
ANYTHING AS FAR AS THE TARGETED
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE AN
AGENDA HAPPY TO DISCUSS THOSE
WITH YOU.
OKAY.
ALEJO.
A SONY PADDOCK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- WE HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
IT DOES USE SOME OF THE FINDINGS
FROM THE RATE STUDY IN A
BENEFICIAL WAY AS THE DIRECTOR
JUST DESCRIBED FOR EXAMPLE
TARGETING USING THE THE GAPS IN
FUNDING IT COMPARED TO THE WHAT.
THE RATE RATES WOULD BE
WONDERFUL IMPLEMENTATION TO
TARGET THE RESOURCES AS WELL AS
TRYING TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
INEQUITIES ACROSS PROVIDERS WHO
PROVIDE THE SAME SERVICE IN THE
SENATE IN A SIMILAR REGION --
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME KEY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
AND WE KNOW THAT IT MISSES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FUNDAMENTALLY
BEGIN A RATE REFORM AND IN THE
UP COMING FISCAL YEAR.
SO I'VE GOT KEEP -- FOR A
PRIMARY CONCERNS.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE FUND THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING PROPOSED IS
RELATIVELY MODEST -- WHEN YOU
COMPARE IT TO THE RATE STUDIES
IDENTIFIED FUNDING GAPS IF YOU
WERE TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE RATE
MODELS IN NINETEEN TWENTY IT
WOULD INCREASE GENERAL FUND
SPENDING BY ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS?
WHERE IS THIS IS A A? TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALIZED COST --
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION IN
NINETEEN TWENTY BECAUSE OF THE
HALF YEAR A PROPOSAL.
SECOND AND YOU JUST DISCUSS THIS
ISSUE -- IN THIS IN THE HSS
ISSUE BUT THE PROPOSED SENSITIVE
RATES RAISES CONCERNS AND I
WON'T.
GO OVER ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU JUST DISCUSSED BUT I WOULD
NOTE THAT THESE ARE SERVICES
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PROVIDED -- SORRY CONTINUE TO BE
NEEDED BY DDS CONSUMERS AND YOU
TWENTY TWO IT'S NOT LIKE A ONE
TIME.
PROJECT THESE ARE REALLY ONGOING --
SERVICES -- SECONDLY ONE OF THE
RATIONALES -- GIVEN FOR THIS
READING CREASES TO STABILIZE
RESIDENTIAL CAPACITY IN TO
STABILIZE WORK FIRST CAPACITY
ACROSS THE OTHER SERVICE
CATEGORIES SO.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU TAKE THOSE AWAY
IT'LL HAVE A DESTABILIZING
AFFECT -- THIRD.
WE NOTE THAT THE PROPOSAL LIMITS
THE SCOPE OF WHO BENEFITS FROM
FISCAL RELIEF PROVIDED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WE ACTUALLY
THINK THE WAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
TARGET THE INCREASES -- IS
PROBABLY A MORE COST EFFICIENT
APPROACH BUT IT DOES SORT OF
LEAVE OUT A LOT OF THE OTHER
PROVIDERS FROM ANY AMOUNT OF
FISCAL RELIEF IN THE COMING
FISCAL YEAR.
AND FINALLY WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE PROPOSAL POSTPONES DOES --
DISCUSSION OF RATE REFORM -- I I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE DIRECTOR
NOTED THAT DISCUSSIONS WOULD
TAKE PLACE OVER THE SUMMER --
BUT IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL THE
UPCOMING BUDGET IN NINETEEN
TWENTY IT DOES NOT FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS OF RATE REFORM AND
AS WE DISCUSSED LAST WEEK OUR
OFFICE HAD PUT FORTH A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT FOR IDEAS.
FOR EITHER DOING A STAGE ROLL
OUT OF RATE MODELS OR AT LEAST
PILOTING SOME OF THE RATE MODELS
IN CERTAIN SERVICE CATEGORIES.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT -- HIMSELF PROVIDE
MAKE DOES THAT WE SPENT BY MORE
THAN TWO HOURS.
DISCUSSING A LOT OF THE ISSUES --
SO.
THE SO ANYWAY I'M NOT SAY THAT
WE CAN'T BRING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES UP AGAIN BUT IT JUST
MIGHT OF MINE PEOPLE WITH. THREE
TED PEARLY SENSE OF THAT I DID
WANT TO ASK ONE CLARIFYING
QUESTION I ASSUME CENTER STONE
HAS SOME -- SOME COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS HE WANTS TO ASK SO I
CAN JUST CLARIFY THAT.
ONE SO THE SO UNDERSTAND IT YOU
DECIDE TO DO TARGETED INCREASES
THE INCREASES THAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING ARE THE BEING PROPOSED
BY ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE WHAT WAS
RECOMMENDED RATE STATE DOESN'T
RAISE IT FOR THESE FOUR ITEMS IS
IT BRING IT ALL THE WAY UP TO
WHAT THE RATE STUDY RECOMMEND
THERE'S ONLY PARTIALLY?
OUT. TWO IT DOES SO SO FOR THE
ONES THAT YOU ACTUALLYARE
PROPOSING INCREASES FOR
RESIDENTIAL SERVICE SUPPORT
SERVICE FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION ASSISTANCE IS THE
AMOUNT THAT'S BEING PROPOSED TO
BRING.
THE CLOSE THE ENTIRE GAP ONLY
PARTIALLY CLOSE THE GAP THIS
PURPOSE MENTION AND REYES
STUDIED WILL.
ON AN AVERAGE SO.
I'LL HAVE MY COLLEAGUES KIND OF
CLARIFY IF IF I'M NOT KIND OF
CAPTURING THAT.
SO AND GENERATE STUDY IT SAID
THIS AND A NEW CENTER PERCENT OF
THE RATE STUDY AND SO THE NOW
RECOGNIZING THAT ALL OF THOSE
SERVICES ARE AT DIFFERENT.
LEVELS WITH IN THAT 100% SO AS I
WAS SAYING THAT WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT CCF IS THAT ABOUT 80%
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE.
YOUR TRIP YOU KNOW OR THEIR AS
TO GET THERE IS LIKE AN 80%
INCREASE TO GET TO SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE PROBABLY AT A MUCH LOWER
PORTION.
THAT'S WHAT ALL OF THOSE
SERVICES TOGETHER WOULD GET YOU
TO ABOUT 60% OF IF IT WAS FULLY
FUNDED IN THE RATE MODELS SO FOR
THE TARGETED SERVICES THAT YOU
IDENTIFIED FOR YOU ARGUED
RECOGNIZE AS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
OTHER SERVICES THAT ARE NOT.
INCLUDED.
IT'S A PARTIAL IT'S A IT WOULD
BE A PARTIAL IF THE RATE MODELS
WERE FULLY IMPLEMENTED FOR EVEN
JUST A SERVICES FOR THOSE
SERVICES AND AND OF NOTE.
THAT WHEN WE MEET.
WITH WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL SO THAT THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE IS THAT -- AS I HAD
MENTIONED THAT -- THE THE RATE
STUDY IF FULLY IMPLEMENTED ON AN
AVERAGE WOULD BE A GIVE OR TAKE
A LITTLE BIT OF ABOUT 40%
INCREASE TOTAL OF ALL IN SCOPE
SERVICES.
SO WITH THE INVESTMENT OF THE SO
THE RATE ADJUSTMENT THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING THAT THAT WOULD THEN
CHANGE THAT TO YOU YOUR YOUR
DELTA WOULD READ WOULD BE
REDUCED.
HOWEVER YOUR THE SOME OF THE THE
TARGETED -- SERVICES THAT I
TALKED ABOUT CCAF TRANSPORTATION
YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE SUPPORT
SERVICES STILL ON TOTALITY WOULD
BE.
THE ONES THAT WOULD HAVE THE THE
GREATEST INCREASE STILL THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED TO GET TO THE
RIGHT STUDY.
OKAY ABOUT IF THAT MAKES SENSE
OF YOU CLOSING THE GAP CLOSING
THAT GAP STILL HAVE A GAP IN THE
GAP.
UTILIZING THE GAFFE THAN IN SOME
WAYS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IT IS IT'S MOVING THE NEEDLE IN
THE SENSE OF TRIED OF IT BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE A A PROPORTION OR A
RELATIVE PERCENTAGE.
AS IT IS BASED ON COMPARED IT TO
THE RIGHT STUDY SO WE STILL SO
WILD THOSE TARGETED AND GRANTED
AND FHA.
YOU KNOW IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
IF IT WAS FULLY AT THE RATE
STUDY WAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED THEY
HAVE A SMALLER PERCENTAGE
INCREASE THAT WOULD OCCUR.
MORE YOUR LARGER ONES WOULD BE
THE CCS AND SOME OF THE SUPPORT
SERVICES AND SO WHAT I'M JUST
SAYING IS THAT.
YOU KNOW WITH THAT WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE STILL AS
COMPARED TO THOSE.
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT WITHIN OUR
PROPOSAL THEY STILL WOULD HAVE A
GREATER DELTA BETWEEN.
THEIR NEW RATE AND OKAY IF THE
RIGHT STUDY WAS IMPLEMENTED
[inaudible]
AT OKAY.
IF I MIGHT ADD -- WHEN WE WHEN
WE SPOKE WITH THE DEPARTMENT A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND THEY
ESTIMATED THAT IT WOULD COST
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION SIX
HUNDRED PLUS?
MILLION ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES.
THIS IS A TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
AUGMENT SO JUST PUT IT IN THE
CAR OKAY.
RIGHT SO WHAT AND THAT'S JUST
FOR THE ONE CATEGORY THAT WE'RE
JUST TAKING THE ONES OF THE
BIGGEST ALT AND MAKING THE DELTA
A LITTLE SMALLER.
IN THAT PARTICULAR EXAMPLE OF
CCF'S THAT IS ACCURATE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT CENTER STONE AND
FRY HAVE MORE COMMENTS LATER
THANK YOU LETTERS SO
[inaudible]
SO.
IF WE'RE TO FULLY FUND THE LAND
FROM AN ENTITLEMENT ACT IN
SPIRIT.
IT WOULD COST US ABOUT ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION.
IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND YOU'RE PROPOSING.
THAT WE USE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION THIS YEAR.
WHICH LEAVES -- SIGNIFICAN DOT
OF ABOUT A BILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS.
YOU CAN ENHANCE THE THESE FOUR
CATEGORIES SO WERE REALLY UPSIDE
DOWN.
BUT WE'VE NEGLECTED.
TO DO RATE INCREASES FOR OTHER
SERVICES THAT.
HAVE AN IMPACT ON OUR ABILITY TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR DD COMMUNITIES --
THE ADVOCATES HAVE -- BEEN
ASKING.
IN LIEU OF YOUR FINAL COMMENTS
ON THE RATE STUDY IN A PERCENT
ACROSS THE BOARD INCREASE.
WHICH I DON'T THINK IT'S
UNREASONABLE.
BECAUSE WE'RE FINDING IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO CONTRACT FOR
SERVICES OUT OF OUR OUR REGIONAL
CENTERS SO.
ASSUMING THAT YOU.
INCREASE THE FOUR CATEGORIES AS
YOU HAVE PROPOSED IF YOU WERE TO
ADD AN 8% INCREASE TO THE OTHER
SERVICES.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT.
KIND OF A BUDGET ENHANCEMENT YOU
WOULD -- NEED I'M I'M HEARING
ABOUT A QUARTER OF A BILLION
DOLLARS AND ABOUT RIGHT TO
FIFTEEN FIFTY MILLION.
OUR POLICY IS WE DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER WITH US RIGHT NOW BUT IF --
THAT'S A QUESTION WE CAN GO
AHEAD AD TAKE A LOOK AT AND
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO YOU
SO WE WE TASK YOU WHAT'S --
DURING A RAID STUDY.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE RATE
STUDY WEST.
TO PROVE THE MAGNITUDE OF THEIR
RATES TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET.
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND
CERTAINLY DESERVE -- SIX SO WHY --
EVEN IN THE FOUR CATEGORIES TO
CHOOSE -- ENHANCED WHY WOULD WE
STILL SEE A DELTA.
WE CAN'T CLAIM THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY COMING INTO
THE TREASURY BECAUSE WE SEE
OURSELVES HAVING TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN WE HAD
BUDGETED.
FOR SO WHY ARE WE FULLY FUNDING
THESE FOUR CATEGORIES AND
AUGMENTING THE OTHERS.
I SEE THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES IN THE BUDGET
FOR ME AND I'VE BEEN.
TUNING THE HORN FOR PROVIDER
RATES TO BE INCREASE FOR THE
PAST. FOUR YEARS AND I'VE BEEN
HERE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF OUR
REQUESTED FALLING ON DEAF EARS --
I WAS HOPING -- THAT TO THEIR
NEW GOVERNOR THAT MAYBE HE WOULD
SHOW MORE OF A SENSITIVITY. TO
THIS VERY FRAGILE POPULATION --
AND KIND OF PUT.
MONEY WHERE HIS MOUTH IS AND
WANTING TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE
THAT.
REALLY DESPERATELY NEED SERVICES
[inaudible]
AND I THINK YOU'LL AGREE THAT.
WE HAVE MORE OF A NEED THAT OUR
ABILITY TO FUND SERVICES I THINK
YOU WOULD PROBABLY AGREE WITH ME
THAT.
WE HAVE FAMILIES THAT ARE
WAITING FOR SERVICES THAT ARE
GETTING THEM.
AND SO I STILL THINK THERE WERE
GROSSLY UNDERFUNDING.
ARE PROVIDERS -- I DO UNDERSTAND
WHY IN THESE GOOD TIMES.
THAT WE DON'T FULLY -- FUNDS
BASED ON THE EXPENSIVE TIME
CONSUMING STUDY THAT WE DID BUT
AT A MINIMUM.
WHY WOULD WE -- ADOPT THE 8% FOR
THE REMAINING ITEMS SO THAT WE
CAN GIVE SOME.
CONFIDENCE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITIES AT ALL OF US SERVE
THAT THE TV COMMUNITY IS GOING --
TO BE TAKEN CARE OF AND THAT
THEY COULD SEE SOME LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL. FOR MANY MANY
YEARS OF CUTBACKS AND AND AND
NON RESTORATION TROODON
RESTORATION EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THAT.
COUPLE OF COMMENTS THAT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE IS WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US WE REALLY DID.
TAKE TIME TO SIT DOWN AND THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE PRIORITIES
AND WHICH WE ARE GOING TO PUT
FORWARD -- AS A PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT I HAD
MENTIONED YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNICATOR FACILITIES REALLY
STABILIZING WE HAD HEARD FROM
THE COMMUNITY THAT THIS IS A
PARTICULAR AREA OF CONCERN SEEN
YEAR OVER YEAR THOSE CHANGES.
AND THEN TAKING A LOOK AT
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES AND
THEN ALSO THOSE THOSE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT ARE SO CRITICAL
WE'RE INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH
PRETTY COMPLEX NEEDS.
NEEDING THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT PERSONAL
ASSISTANE THE SUPPORT SERVICES
AND TO RESIDENTIAL INTO DAY
PROGRAMS AND ALSO INTO THE
FAMILY HOMES.
THOSE AND THEN TRANSPORTATION IS
ALSO ANOTHER ELEMENT THAT WE HAD
HEARD THAT.
YOU THERE'S THERE'S A OF A REAL
CLEAR NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT ARE PRETTY
INDIVIDUALIZED AND SO FOCUSING
ON THAT.
SO WE WE FOCUSED ON THOSE AREAS
THAT ALSO TOUCH KIND OF BROADLY
IN IN MANY OF THE OTHER
CATEGORIES WHILE MEDIAN MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN DIRECT INTO THE
SERVICES.
WITH DAY PROGRAMS SOME OF THE
OTHER SERVICES THESE WERE THE
AREAS THAT WE SAW AS THE
PRIORITY AREAS TO MOVE FORWARD --
AND THAT IS THE PROPOSAL --
WE'VE BEEN I I I I LOOK AT EVEN
THIS ANALYZE -- NUMBER THAT
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE YEAR OVER
YEAR WHICH IS PART OF THE
BENEFIT OF THE A. B. X. TWO ONE
SOME OF THE OTHER WORK AND I'M
NOT SAYING THAT THERE'S NOT.
ISSUES OR PRESSURES AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL SAYING THAT
THERE'S THINGS WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT AND
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW TO ADDRESS
IT.
BUT WE HAVE HAD SUPPORT THROUGH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE IN LOOKING
ANNUALIZED.
YOU KNOW WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM FROM SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
YOUR FOR THE REGIONAL CENTER
PURCHASE A SERVICE I THINK
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE OF ABOUT.
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED
IN FUNDING OUR SERVICES WE HAVE
A COULD WE HAVE A CONTINUED
GROWTH IN CASELOAD WHICH YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE
TO BE ABLE TO ALL WORK TOGETHER
TO SAY HOW DO WE DELIVER THOSE
SERVICES.
YOU KNOW FROM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TO NINETEEN TWENTY LOOKING IN
THAT HE PROJECTED GROWTH AGAIN
OUR CASE LOW GROWTH IS GOING UP
OUR EXPENDITURE GROWTH I
OUTPACING OUR CASE LOW GROWTH.
YOU KNOW AND AGAIN I'M I'M NOT
SAYING THAT THIS ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT ISN'T IMPORTANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT ALL OF OUR SERVICES.
BUT THAT'S WHY WE REALLY WANT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT EVERYTHING IN
TOTALITY.
UNDERSTANDING IT BECAUSE EVEN
FROM 718-192-1920 WE'RE LOOKING
AT ABOUT A SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
ONE MILLION DOLLAR DIFFERENCE.
IN OUR PURCHASES SERVICES SO.
REALLY DRILLING INTO SOME OF
THOSE GROWTH TRENDS AND
UNDERSTANDING ARE REIMBURSEMENTS
AND UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THOSE
PIECES.
THAT SAID YOU KNOW AGAIN AND YOU
GUYS HAVE HEARD ME SAY THIS
BEFORE OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY
EXEMPTION PROCESS.
IS NOT THE FAVORITE OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
BUT IT IS A SAFETY NET.
IT IS SOMETHING IN THOSE
INSTANCES IN OTHER SERVICES IF
THERE'S A NEED FOR US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS ARE GETTING SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS.
THAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT TAKING
AWAY THOSE SAFETY NETS WERE ALSO
SAYING THAT FOR THOSE THAT
WITHIN THE RATE STUDY THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN PROJECTED AS A RATE
REDUCTION.
THAT THOSE ARE NOT THINGS THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTING AT THIS TIME
EITHER SO I I JUST WANT TO ALSO
JUST POINT OUT THAT THERE'S SOME
REALLYIMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WERE.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT TO
STABILIZE WHAT WE'RE TARGETING
ON THE THE SERVICE AREAS THAT
THAT WE'VE TARGET IN OUR
PROPOSAL.
NO AND I APPRECIATE THOSE
TARGETED AREAS A CHIU OF EVEN
HAND SIDE.
AND I'M SURE THAT -- MANY OF THE
FIGHTERS ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
WHAT YOU'VE YOU'VE PROPOSED BUT
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE STILL
LEAVING A LOT ON THE TABLE FOR A
LOT OF OTHER NEEDS THAT ARE NOT
BEING MET.
AND HOW DO I HOW DO I A RESPOND --
TO VENDOR REQUEST WHEN I SAY YOU
KNOW SENATOR WHY -- WHY CAN'T I
SEE MY RATE INCREASE BECAUSE I'M
HAVING TROUBLE THE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THIS PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY?
WHEN THE STATE IS BOASTING THAT
THEY'RE JUST FLOODED WITH CASH
YOU KNOW WHY ARE WE THE PRIORITY?
SO.
IN AND WHY DO WE DO STUDIES THAT
IDENTIFY IN QUANTITATIVE EXACTLY
WHAT IS NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE.
AND YET WE DON'T PROVIDE THAT
LEVEL OF CASH WHEN WE HAVE THE
CASH SO.
IF NOT NINETEEN TWENTY LET ME
ASK YOU.
WHEN DO YOU SEE THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THE LANTERN MEN ACT AS
A FULLY FUNDED ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM HELPING THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
THANK YOU CENTER IT WE RE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE AN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE OUR
PROVIDING SERVICES WE ARE STILL
MEETING.
THEN THE NEED OF OF SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS HER WALKING INTO THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND NEEDING
SERVICES.
NOW AS WE TAKE A LOOK AND
UNDERSTAND KIND OF WHERE THOSE
GAPS ARE YOU KNOW WE STILL NEED
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE SOME OF
THOSE GAPS IN SERVICES.
AND AGAIN THE PROPOSAL THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE YOU IS ADDRESSING
MANY OF THOSE GAPS YOU KNOW ARE
WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
EVERYTHING TO DAY BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE SOME THINGS WE DO
NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
APPRECIATE AND AND AND REALLY
VALUE -- THE INTEREST IN OUR OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
BUT THE PRIORITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING ON FOR SEVERAL YEARS
AND SUPPORTING OUR DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
IS IS BEEN.
RECOGNIZE I THINK THROUGH THE
BUDGETS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD AND APPROVED AND
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR CASE SO
GROWTH IN OUR EXPENDITURE GROWTH
HAS CONTINUED TO BE FUNDED.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THOSE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
HAVING AN IMPACT TO OUR SYSTEM.
THE RATE STUDY IT WAS A VERY
INFORMATIVE PROCESS FOR US IT IT
LET US TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT WOULD BE --
CAPTURED.
ADDITIONAL LIKE SERVICES TAKING
A LOOK AT WAGES AND AND
COMPENSATION LOOKING AT TRAINING
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW HOW MANY
HOURS IN THE COMMUNITY IN A
PARTICULAR INSTANCE FOR DAY
PROGRAM SO THERE'S DIFFERENT.
PROJECTIONS THAT WERE WITHIN TE
RATE STUDY -- THAT WAS
INFORMATIVE AS FAR AS EVEN
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES THAT HELPED
INFORM OUR PROPOSAL.
SO AS OUR PROPOSALS MOVING YOU
KNOW IS IS BEFORE YOU IS THAT WE
DIDN'T.
PUT THAT ON A SHELF TO SAY THAT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE PART OF
IT BUT IT IS YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE
A BIGGER DISCUSSION TO HAVE --
BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION OF
WHEN WE'RE GOING -- TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THOSE ISSUES THAT'S FOR
FOR ALL OF HIS TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS -- BUT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK AND MAKE SURE THAT
ANYBODY WHO WALKS THROUGH THE
DOOR OF A REGIONAL CENTER IS
RECEIVING SERVICES AND TO
FURTHER UNDERSTAND WHERE THOSE
GAPS ARE SO WE CAN HAVE.
KIND OF THAT THAT BROADER
DISCUSSION BUT WAS IN THE
PURPOSE OF THE READ STUDY.
IS TO IDENTIFY THOSE GAPS AND
QUESTION THOSE CAPS AND THEN YOU
LOOK AND FIND OUT THAT THE
REASON WHY YOU HAVE THOSE GAPS
OF BECAUSE CONTRACTORS ARE TAKEN
THE WORK BECAUSE THEY CAN'T WORK
FOR NOTHING.
AND SO IT'S LIKE WE'RE NOT
LEARNING FROM THE STUDIES.
AND WE'RE JUST GIVING LIP
SERVICE SAYS -- TO IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE AT LEAST IN
AND STATEMENT ONLY BUT WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO THE THE THE THE
THE THE TIRE OR TIRES MEETING
THE ROADS.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE ALONG
FUNDED APPROPRIATELY AND SO I I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IN THE IN
THE IN THE GREATEST REVENUE
STREAM THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S
EVER HAD.
WHY DOES THE DEVELOPMENT A
DISABLED GET THE BACKSEAT IN THE
STATE BUDGET WHY ARE WE WORKING
TO FULLY FUND THIS PROGRAM?
AND SO.
I KNOW YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB.
AND I'M I'M SURE THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES HEARING BUT I'M VERY
DISSATISFIED AS A CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING CARE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
THAT WE OVERSEE WHILE WE WERE
ELECTED I DON'T THINK THIS IS
THIS IS A PARTISAN ISSUE THIS IS
A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT NEED THE
HELP THE MOST AREN'T GETTING IT.
AND YOU HAVE THE CONTROL AND THE
HELP IN WORKING WITH THIS
GOVERNOR AND STRESSING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY SHOULD HAVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ATTENTION THEY'RE NOT GETTING WE
SHOULD BE HAVING A PEACEFUL
APPROACH TO PROVIDING THESE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THIS
BUDGET THANK YOU FOR RESPONSES.
OKAY CENTER CHAU.
YOU KNOW I JUST.
WANT TO REITERATE AND EXPRESS MY
CONCERNS AND JUST ECHOING WHAT --
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR STONE JUST
OP EMPHASIZED AS WELL IS THAT I
THINK.
THAT WERE REALLY REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS IN ON THOSE.
POPULATIONS OUT THAT.
NEEDED THE MOST AND WERE.
POTENTIALLY LEAVING OUTRIGHT --
PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN MEETING
WITH CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT --
TODAY AND YESTERDAY AND PHONE
CALLS AND IN PERSON.
AND THERE'S SOME REAL CONCERNS
THERE AND EIGHTY THEY NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY IN
TERMS OF HOW.
YOU KNOW THE PROPOSED RATES ARE
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
PLACE GEOGRAPHICALLY AND I SAID
THIS BEFORE AND JUST REITERATING
AGAIN -- THERE ISN'T CURRENTLY
INFORMATION AVAILABLE WHETHER
THERE WOULD BE REGIONALIZATION
OF THE NEW BASELINE RAY AND
WHETHER.
SUCH OF REGIONALIZATION -- BUT
PROVIDED LOW RATE TO AREAS LIKE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- YOU SENATE
DISTRICT FOURTEEN OR
SENATE-DISTRICT.
TWELVE BY THE HAVE DEEMED LOWER
COST -- SO.
WANTED JUST TO RE EMPHASIZE
MANDATE THAT.
SO IS THAT HE IS A MEDIA WE WE
HAD AN EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION AND
PRAYER HEARING ABOUT THE THE
GENERAL ISSUES THERE ARE FEW
MORE SPECIFIC THINGS I JUST WANT
TO TOUCH ON SO FIRST OF ALL --
HAVE YOU SEE HER DISSATISFACTION
WITH THE LEVEL RATE INCREASE BUT
EVEN THE ONES THAT ARE BEING
OFFERED HAVE A SUNSET DATE AND
STAND CORRECT.
SO I AM NOT SURE WHAT KIND OF
MESSAGE WE'RE SENDING PEOPLE WE
HAD THIS DISCUSSION AGAIN WITH
THE PRIOR ITEM -- WITH THE PRIME
SOCIAL SERVICES -- IF WE'RE
SAYING THAT WE'RE TARGETING AND
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO BRING CLOSE
SOME OF THE APS IN A TELL
PEOPLE WELL IN TWO YEARS THAT'S
GOING TO GO AWAY AGAIN -- I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CONVINCE
PEOPLE TO SAY WELL ACTUALLY NOW
I'M GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
NEW RELATIONSHIP AND YOU
CONTRACT OF MORE HIRES WHATEVER
IS.
IT'S DESIGNED TO GO AWAY AND TWO
YEARS NOW THE REALITY IS IS THAT
YOU KNOW WILL HAVE A DISCUSSION
WILL SEE WATER REVENUES LOOK
LIKE HIM IN THE BUDGET TO WHEN
YOUR DOCUMENT WILL WE BUT WE DO
LOOK OUT MULTIPLE YEARS I THINK.
THAT THAT'S A GOOD THING WE
SHOULD BE DOING -- BUT THE IDEA
THAT WE WOULD BUILD INTO OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT THE THIS
THAT WHAT INCREASE THERE IS.
WILL GO AWAY.
I MEAN THAT MEANS THAT YOU'RE
TELLING EVERYONE WHO GETS THE
INCREASE THAT YOU CAN'T COUNT ON
IT AND SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
DO YOU KNOW I CAN SEE THE
CHANGES IN.
AND BEHAVIOR TO CHANGE OUT THAT
THAT THE STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT
YOU WANT TO SEE FOR ME ENTRIES
BECAUSE PEOPLE THAT THIS IS A
TEMPORARY BOB RIGHT -- SO I I
CERTAINLY HOPE -- THAT -- THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL AGREE I
BELIEVE.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO THAT I MEAN
OTHERWISE THAT'S JUST UNDERMINES
THE WHOLE PIECE SELL.
SELL SIDE FROM HOW BIG YOU KNOW
WE AND WE WENT OVER THIS BEFORE
LET'S LET'S NOT SEND THE SIGNAL
THAT WHAT INCREASE WE DO DECIDE
TO ADOPT -- FIRST REALLY AN
ONGOING SERVICE I MEAN IT'S NOT
THAT THE NEED GOES AWAY I MEAN
IT'S ONE THING IF YOU HAVE A
NEED AND YOU KNOW FOR ONE TIME
INFUSION THAT TAKES CARE OF IT.
YOU KNOW THEN THAT THIS IS NOT
ONE OF THOSE ITEMS SO LET'S
LET'S NOT.
SO I HOPE I HOPE WE CAN AGREE ON
THAT -- THE OTHER ISSUE IS IS IT
I APPRECIATE IN THE LAST HEARING
AND AGAIN NOT WOODLAND REITERATE.
THAT THERE IS A PRETTY -- WITH
THAT THERE'S A PROCESS THIS WAS
I MULTIPLE YEARS IN THIS VERY
SUBCOMMITTEE WE WERE TOLD
THERE'S A RATE STUDIES THERE'S A
RATE STUDY.
THERE'S A RATE STUDY AND WE NEED
TO WAIT FOR THE RATE STUDY THE
RATE STUDY IS HERE.
SO I KNOW THAT NOW THAT YOU HAVE
THE RESULTS THERE'S GONNA BE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH VERY
STAKEHOLDERS AND SO FORTH.
BUT I THINK YOU YOU HEAR YEAR IS
THAT OBVIOUSLY WE ARE -- NOT
JUST VERY INTERESTED -- WE ARE
YOU KNOW WE WILL WE DOES NOT
WANT THIS RATE SAY THIS SIT ON
THE SHELF IT'S BEEN.
MENTIONED SO MANY TIMES OF
COURSE THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO COME NOW THAT IT'S HERE.
AND WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY ON
IT AND IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE GOVERNOR
PRIOR GOVERNOR AGREED.
TO RIGHT THIS IS THE THIS IS
BEST A WAY AND THERE ARE SOME
IMPERFECTIONS WE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT IN TERMS
OF HOW YOU KNOW WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATION BUT THAT.
THIS WAS I THINK.
YEAH THIS IS THE APPROACH THAT
WE WANTED TO TAKE RIGHT I MEAN
THIS DOES THE DEPARTMENT THAT.
WORK WITH THE VENDOR TO FIGURE
THIS OUT IT CETERA.
AND IT'S HERE AND IT'S SAYING
THAT WE HAVEA BIG PROBLEM WE
HAVE A BIG GAP.
AND OBVIOUSLYIT'S UP TO US AS
THE POLICY MAKERS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO CLOSE THAT GAP AND HOW WE
WANT TO PRIORITIZE BUT I THINK
THIS OF COMMITTEES VERY
INTERESTED AND I BELIEVE -- MAC
ADDRESS SPEAK FOR THE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES BUT I THINK THAT
BUDGET COMMITTEE OVERALL.
DOESN'T WANT.
DISTANCE JUST SIT ON THE SHELF
SO -- I'D STATE WAS JUST FOR
THIS WAY THE EXPECTATION WILL BE
IS THAT I UNDERSTAND YOU
MENTIONED PRIOR HEARINGS GOT
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE SUMMER.
AND SO FORTH AND I REALIZE HE'S
DISCUSSIONS ARE JUST GONNA BE
FOR ONE TIMES AND BUT WE WILL
TRY ONE AN IN DEPTH EXAMINATION
OF WHAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
BY THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
CONVERSATIONS STAKEHOLDERS -- A
PRESENTATION ABOUT THIS THAT
PERHAPS EVEN SEPARATE FROM JUST
REGULAR BUDGET PROCESS BECAUSE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT.
SO I HOPE THAT THAT SOMETHING
THAT -- YOU USE THAT -- YOUR
DEPARTMENTS AND DIRECTOR I KNOW
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN VERY OPEN TO
WORKING WITH US AND AND AND AND
AND ARRANGING -- SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE A DETAILED UPDATE ON WHAT
THE PLAN IS.
A WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH THE
RATE STUDY IN THE FINDINGS THAT
CAME OUT FROM THAT AND WHAT THE
THE TENDED.
NOT PROGRESS WERE PLAIN TO MAKE
[inaudible]
YOUR TO TEXTURES BUDGET
OBVIOUSLY CELL.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT.
AS ALWAYS WERE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION SO LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT DISCUSSION WITH YOU YEAH --
BLOW HEALTH WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING WORD TO ADD THAT THERE'S
A FOR BUT THE OBVIOUSLY I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO REACH OUT BUT
THERE IS A L. THE SUBS AND IT'S
NOT JUST CONVERSATION BUT THERE
ARE SOME AT LEAST SOME INITIAL
PLANNING BUT YES.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY LET'S SEE PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW.
DOCTOR PAN A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- RICK ROLLINS --
REPRESENT HARKIS SO SHE SHOULD
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES FOR SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PEOPLE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
YOUR PRIOR SUPPORT AND CURRENT
SUPPORT FOR OUR POPULATION LIKE
TO ALSO ASSOCIATE.
OUR POSITION WITH THE COMMENTS
OF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S AND
EACH OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
SPECIFICALLY -- WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THE THE INPUT OF FUNDING
THIS YEAR BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH
QUITE FRANKLY WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE SYSTEM IS IN CRISIS.
ACROSS THE BOARD AND WE'VE BEEN
A STRONG PROPONENT OF THE 8% TO
STABILIZE IN -- FUNDING FOR OUR
SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD THIS YEAR
ON THE QUESTION OF THE OF THE
SUNSET -- CLEARLY IT'S A
DESTABILIZING IMPACT AND I THINK
THE POINTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE ON THAT IN MY LAST COMMENT
IS IF NOT NOW WHEN -- TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE HAD A SIMILAR STUDY
OF THE CITY GATES STUDY THAT
CAME OUT AT A SIMILAR TYPE TIME
IN OUR ECONOMY WHERE THINGS WERE
LOOKING PRETTY GOOD.
ONLY TO SEE A QUICK DOWNTURN IN
OUR ECONOMY AND THAT PARTICULAR
RATE STUDY SHELVED WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED OF COURSE HOW
SENSITIVE THE SYSTEM IS NOT
HAVING A GUARANTEE OF FUNDING
BUT HAVING AN ENTITLEMENT.
THAT WE TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT WHEN WE HAVE THE MONEY AND
HAVE THE TIME AND HAVE THE DATA
TO SUPPORT WHAT THE SYSTEM IS
GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW THAT WE
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
NANCY CHANCE FAMILY MEMBER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CHOICES
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES -- AND
THE CALIFORNIA.
THE PERSON CENTERED PARTNERSHIP.
AND THE PATH FOR COLLABORATIVE
OKAY.
I JUST WISH I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASE
OF FOR THE SERVICES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED -- WE FEEL THAT AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND RESPITE
SERVICES NEED TO BE INCLUDED
WITH THOSE SERVICES AS THEY BOTH
ARE H. U. B. S. COMPLIANT AND
ALSO HELP PEOPLE TO REMAIN
LIVING IN THEIR OWN HOMES
INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW HAVING TO GO
TO A MORE RESTRICTIVE --
ENVIRONMENT.
I AM ALSO OPPOSED TO THE SUNSET
OF THE RATE INCREASE AND LESS
THAT SUNSET IS ACTUALLY TIED TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OF THE
RATE STUDY.
SO I MEAN IT WAS TIED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION THEN THAT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT BECAUSE YOU'RE
SPENDING MONEY NOW TO GET THERE
BUT THERE IS NO NO MENTION OF
THAT SO THAT'S CONCERNING -- AS
YOU'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT THESE
HEARINGS ARE -- OVER AND OVER
AGAIN MOST PROVIDERS BIGGEST
CHALLENGES HIRING -- PEOPLE AND
PROVIDING A WITH A LIVING WAGE
TO THEIR EMPLOYEES.
AND QUITE FRANKLY I I I'M
ACTUALLY IS.
A SUPPORT LIVING PROVIDER I AM
ALSO AN INDEPENDENT PROVIDER IN
A DAY SERVICE PROVIDER BUT AS OF
SUPPORT LIVING A PROVIDER AYE
I'M NOT GOING TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE GIVING SALARY OR
RAISES.
IF I'M GONNA HAVE TO TAKE HIM
AWAY IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS I'M
REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT THAT SO
THAT'S A PROBLEM IN WITH THE
SUNSET -- I'M AGREE IN AGREEMENT
WITH THAT.
MANY OF WHAT THE LA -- THE
THINGS THAT THE LA -- SAID AND I
THINK WE SHOULD HELP ALL
PROVIDERS IN SOME WAY LIKE
PERHAPS FUNDING FULLY FUNDING
THE MINIMUM WAGE.
TEXTING THAT MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK
THAT FULLY FUNDS THAT AND THE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES THAT WOULD
HELP EVERYBODY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME A THING THANK
YOU MARTY MOTO FAMILY MEMBER AND
PART OF ALL THE GROUPS THAT
NANCY CHANCES MUST MENTION.
FIRST OF ALL JUST WANTED.
SHOW MY APPRECIATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT I MEAN THEY HAVE BEEN
GOOD AND WORKING WITH ALL OF US.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S A BUT THAT
SAID.
IT'S JUST IMPORTANT FRAME THIS
DISCUSSION RESTORATIONS WHEN
THERE ARE MADE WHETHER HERE OR
AND I HSS OR ELSEWHERE.
THERE SUNSET IT AND WONDERING
INCREASES MADE EITHER HERE OR
ELSEWHERE.
THEY'RE ALSO SUNSET IT AND
THAT'S A REALLY A UP A REALLY
TERRIBLE IN BALANCE IN POLICY
MAKING THAT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY.
TO ADDRESS AS WELL AS
ADMINISTRATION.
FIRST WE PREACHER WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASES WITH
IN GIVEN THE FRAMEWORK WOULD
LIKE.
TO INCLUDE OR ASKED TO HAVE --
I'LL LESS INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES AND IN HOME RESPITE
INCLUDED IN SOME OTHER SERVICES
THAT MIGHT BE NEEDED SECOND.
WE BELIEVE TAT THERE NEED TO BE --
BUT THE LEGISLATURE DOT TRAILER
BILL PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE.
ADOPTING OR LOOKING AT MANY OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
PUT THEM IN TRAILER BILL.
IS IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE THIS
DOES -- CONVERSATIONS WHICH WE
WOULD APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT IT'S IMPORTANT
HAVE ACTION STEPS TIED TO THAT
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
SOMETIME IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET YEAR ON
SOME OF THE RATE MODELS THAT CAN
WORK THAT CAN ADDRESS.
PEOPLE IN CRISIS REDUCING
DISPARITIES -- A COMPLIANCE OF A
HOME COMMUNITY SERVICES FINAL
RULE.
AND YOU'D LIKE THE LA ALL
SUGGESTED WE CAN TRY THIS AND IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF STATES AND
PILOTS.
LASTLY I THINK ALSO INTO THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE A NEED TO BE A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
DEVELOPING AN OUTCOME TOOL --
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST IS NOT
JUST IMPORTANT WE MEASURE UNITS
OF TIME OR LENGTH OF OF PEOPLE
IN A SERVICE BUT ALSO WE MEASURE
QUALITY OF SERVICES.
THAT CAN THEN TARGET RESOURCES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IN GROCERY BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION.
WHAT WE DO APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS DONE
WE CAN'T?
HELP BUT FEEL AS THOUGH THEY ARE
PUTTING THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE BY DECIDING.
WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THE RATE
STUDY WOULD BE SPECIFIC TO A
CERTAIN PROGRAMS AND THE LIKE
AND AND WE WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE
ASK FOR A PERCENT ACROSS THE
BOARD?
THAT OBVIOUSLY IMPLEMENTATION
THE RAGE THAT HE WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON WHAT THE RESULT IS FOR
THOSE RATES BUT NOW WHAT.
WE'RE SEEING IS A CHOICE OF
WHICH SERVICE CODE TO THE
QUESTION WAS RAISED.
IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT
DESTABILIZATION THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION THAT THIS
APPROACH WILL DESTABILIZE IF YOU
ARE A PROVIDER WHO IS PROVIDING
SERVICES IN MULTIPLE SERVICE
CODE YOU HAVE EMPLOYEES DOING
THAT WORK.
YOU TO GIVE A RAISE TO ONE
EMPLOYEE IN CAN'T DO ANYTHING
FOR ANOTHER.
AND WHILE THAT MAY SEEN ALL
MICRO PROBLEM IT'S A MACRO
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO
HAVE A DESTABILIZING AFFECT
ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO THAT IS ONE OF OUR MAJOR
OBJECTIONS YOU CANNOT LEAVE OUT
THESE OTHER SERVICE CODES WHILE
THOSE ARE STILL SERVICE CODE WE
WILL FIND OUT THROUGH THE RATE
STUDY WHAT HAPPENS THERE BUT
THIS IS A BAD APPROACH.
AS IT STANDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CENTER
STONE STAFF JORDAN THE WITH THE
RK CALIFORNIA NEW YORK UNITED
THROUGH PULLED THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE.
FIRST JUST WANNA ALIGN OURSELVES
HOLY WITH THE STATEMENTS FROM
THE LA -- AS WELL AS FROM THE
STATEMENTS THAT WE HEARD TODAY
FROM THE SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE -- IT
SPECIFICALLY THE STATEMENTS
REGARDING TO THE RATE STUDY WE
REALLY REQUEST THAT SOME TYPE OF
TBL BE INCLUDED THAT.
MANDATES THAT GREAT CITY IS
IMPLEMENTED IN THAT WE GET THEIR
STARTING NEXT YEAR OF
DISCUSSIONS HAVE TO HAVE TO HAVE
TO HAPPEN OVER THE SUMMER --
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
SERVICES IDENTIFIED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DO NEED
INCREASES IN SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES A HUGE CONCERN HOWEVER
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THEN
SAYS.
BY NOT INCLUDING OTHERS THAT
THOSE AREN'T IN NEED THAT THE
NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO
FOR EXAMPLE OR IN A DAY PROGRAM --
ISN'T IN NEED OF HUGE INCREASES
AS WELL HOWEVER JUST IN
CONVERSATIONS ON FRIDAY WITH --
A LARGE -- SERVICE WRITER
RIVERSIDE ANOTHER ONE YESTERDAY
IN SACRAMENTO WHO -- IT'S
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR SOME THE
MOST MEDICALLY COMPLEX
INDIVIDUALS IN THE AREA -- HAVE
ALREADY CLOSED SOME PROGRAMS AND
IS SAID TO BE THE ONE SACRAMENTO
TO MORE WOULD HAVE TO AS A
RESULT BECAUSE THERE'S SUCH A
HUGE LOSS.
AT THE CURRENT RATES BUT THERE
IS NOTHING IN THIS FOR INCREASED
RATES FOR THOSE SERVICES AS WELL
A PERSON'S LIFE IS BRAIDED WITH
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS IN THIS IS
NOT NECESSARILY RECOGNIZING HOW
THEIR BRAIDED -- FINALLY WE'VE
BEEN TOLD TO WAIT FOR THE RATE
STUDY WAIT FOR THE RIGHT TO BE
FOR THAT RIGHT STUDY RIGHT
CITIES HERE AND ACTUALLY BEEN
TOLD.
AGAIN LET'S WAIT SOME MORE AND
TALK SOME MORE WE CAN'T DO THAT
IN A PERCENT MINIMUM FOR
EVERYBODY IF WE WANT INCREASE
FOR MORE FOR CERTAIN SERVICES
FANTASTIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME THIS CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARL LUNDEN HERE ON
BEHALF THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING
PEOPLE WITH IBD -- I WOULD LIKE
TO RECOMMEND THAT YOU SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER WITH CENTER STONE RACE
TODAY WHICH IS.
AN 8% FOR EVERY PROGRAM OUTSIDE
OF THE ONES INCLUDED IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL THAT SAYS
SUPPORTER OF COURSE BY THE STERN
LETTER -- REQUEST IT'S NOW BEEN
SIGNED BY HALF OF THE STATE
SENATE -- AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE
YOU VIEW JUST SOME SACRAMENTO
ICE OUT LAST NIGHT AS A BOARD
MEMBER -- FOR AN AGENCY IN A
THREE HOUR BOARD MEETING WHERE
WE DISCUSSED VERY SPECIFIC LOWER
BUDGET IT'S THAT TIME OF YEAR
FOR US TO IMPROVE OUR BUDGET.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THE STAFF
PRESENTED TO US THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE STAFF PRESENTED TO
US WAS A CHART.
SHOWING OUR STAFF IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS HOW MANY PEOPLE WE
HAD WORKING IN THE AGENCY FROM
SIX MONTHS AGO TELL TODAY.
GUESS WHAT A DROP FROM FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY DOWN.
TO FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY THE MAIN
REASON IS MONEY WHAT THEY'RE
BEING PAID THE STAFF
SATISFACTION SURVEY WE ASKED
THEM TO TAKE EVERY YEAR WHICH WE
ALSO WERE PROVIDED LAST NIGHT.
SHOW THAT 90% OF THE PEOPLE
REALLY LIKE THEIR JOB THEY LOVE
THE JOB THEY LOVE THE MISSION.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE LEAVING
THE NUMBER ONE REASON THEY'RE
LEAVING IS BECAUSE OF MONEY HOW
DOES THAT TRANSLATE IN OUR
AGENCY HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
IT MEANS WE LOST SEVENTY STAFF
PEOPLE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT
ALREADY HAVE AN I PP IN THE
LOCAL REGIONAL CENTER WHO WERE
RECEIVING SERVICES.
THAT MEANS OUR STAFF FOR NOW
HAVE AND YOU OVER TIME TO COVER
FOR THE LOS STAFF THAT WE CAN'T
COVER ANYMORE THAT IS THE
PICTURE.
OF EVERY AGENCY STATEWIDE AND
THE LAST THING I'D SAY ABOUT
THAT AND STATEWIDE VIEW.
IS THAT WE HAVE WAITING LISTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT IS NOT
MEETING THE DEMANDS OF EVERY
PERSON ON THE COMMUNITY AS A
DIRECTOR SUGGESTED.
IF WE HAVE A WAITING LIST
ANYWHERE WE ARE FAILING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THAT PERSON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
IF ANYONE WITH A SAY YOU
CALIFORNIA -- APPRECIATE THIS AS
A FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT
PICKS AND CHOOSES -- WHICH
SERVICES IN WHICH NEEDS ARE ARE.
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR RESOURCES
WHEN THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THEY'RE ALL IN NEED -- OF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES SO THAT'S
WHY THE 8% ACROSS THE BOARD
WOULD E MORE BENEFICIAL.
AS THE CONVERSATION CONTINUED WE
HOPE THAT THEY DO CONTINUE IN AT
THE RATE STUDY -- IS EVENTUALLY
ACTUALIZE -- IS A WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOU TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
OKAY -- SO WHEN.
CALL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN -- BUT
WHATEVER WE END UP FINALLY
AGREEING TO IN THE BUDGET -- I
THINK THERE'S TREMENDOUS
INTEREST IN AND FOLLOWING WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO -- AS KNOWLEDGE
OF COURSE FOR THIS YEAR WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT -- BUT ALSO IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS AS WELL AND AND
SO HOPEFULLY WE GET RID OF THE A
FOLLOW UP ON THE THE RATE STUDY
ITSELF AND WHAT WE PLAN TO D
WITH IT WHAT THE PLANS ARE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
CONVERSATION COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF EITHER THAT OR WHAT RATE
METHODOLOGY WE WILL BE -- THAT
WE SPENT ALL THIS TIME AND
EFFORT DOING THE STUDY WHAT KIND
OF REFORM TO EVEN TEND TO DO
SELF.
CONSIDER THIS THING AND IS THERE
SOME A FINAL COMMENT AND
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS -- I AGREE WITH YOU I
AGREE WITH THE THE SPEAKERS AT
AGAIN THE THE TWO YEAR SUNSET IS --
ANTI PRODUCTIVE -- MY AT MY
CONSULTANT STAFFERS -- COME UP
IN THE FIGURE THAT IF WE WERE.
TO GIVEN A PERCENT INCREASE TO
THE SERVICES THAT ARE NOT BEING
ENHANCE THE FOR SERVICES THAT
ARE REPORT -- THE COSTS THE
STATE WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
AND I I DON'T THINK THAT'S AN
AND REASONABLE AMOUNT -- TO TO
STICK BACK IN THE BUDGET -- AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME SO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WELL WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN -- NEXT ISSUES
ISSUE NUMBER THREE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REGARDING REGIONAL
CENTER TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YES THANK YOU -- TO WALK YOU
THROUGH AND AND AGAIN AND IN THE
AGENDA IT CORRECTLY OUTLINES THE
CONCEPTS AND I'LL GO AHEAD AND
JUST BRIEFLY WALK YOU THROUGH
EACH OF THOSE CONCEPTS THAT'S
RELATED -- TO THE PROPOSAL TO
HAVE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
RELATED TO TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
SO THE FIRST -- THREE ITEMS
REALLY IS AROUND -- A FOCUS ON
THE AREA AFTER -- TRANSPARENCY
THE FIRST ONE IS PERFORMANCE
CONTRACT REPORTING THIS YEAR WE
CURRENTLY HAVE -- PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS THAT -- REGIONAL
CENTERS PRODUCE AND WORK WITH
THEIR COMMITTEES AND DEVELOPING
ON ANNUAL BASIS AND THEN THEY
RECEIVE DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT --
TO PROVIDE A MEASUREMENT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THOSE MEASURES ON A
ANNUAL BASIS.
THIS IS JUST ADDING TO THE
REQUIREMENT OF PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS AS A WELL WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
ARE WE GOING TO BE CHANGING THE
MEASURES TO BETTER INFORM KIND
OF THIS THE THE SERVICE DELIVERY.
BUT THIS WOULD REQUIRE THE
GOVERNING BOARDS OF EACH
REGIONAL CENTER DIRECTOR TO
ANNUAL REPORT ON THE PERFORMANCE
CONTRACT. TO THE DEPARTMENT --
AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE US A
SUMMARY IS TO KIND OF THOSE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS ARE THE
ACTIONS THAT WOULD BE -- FOCUS
THAT THEY COULD DO TO IMPROVE IN
EACHOF THE AREAS THATTHEY BUT
IDENTIFIED AS A NEED.
THIS WOULD ALSO -- EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WITHIN
THE COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
THE REGIONAL CENTER PROCESS FOR
STANDARDIZATION.
THIS IS A IS LOOKING AT IN THOSE
AREAS THAT -- REALLY ARE KEY AND
NOT GETTING AWAY FROM THE
UNIQUENESS OF EACH OF THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
BUT TAKING A LOOK AT HOW TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM THE COMMUNITY FROM
FAMILIES AND CONSUMERS.
IS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO WALK AND TO EACH
REGIONAL CENTER IF THEY'RE
ACCESSING KIND OF HIM YOU KNOW
INFORMATION ABOUT.
BEING A REGIONAL CENTER I'M
RECIPIENT OF SERVICES YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THOSE SERVICES THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO THEM.
SO THIS WOULD BE -- AN AREA IN
WHICH WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SAY
STATEWIDE HERE'S AN INTAKE
PACKET IF YOU WILL -- THAT WOULD
BE TRANSLATED IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR EARLY START AND
FOR LETTERMAN SERVICES.
ON TO OUTLINE WHAT IS A REGIONAL
CENTER WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WHAT ARE
THE SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AND AGAIN EVERY PERSON
WHO BE JOAQUIN OR ASKING FOR
SERVICE THAT THAT INFORMATION
WOULD HAVE THE SAME ACROSS THE
STATE -- OUR INTENT THEN WOULD
BE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT CAN BE
PERSONALIZED WITH THE NEED TO
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AS LONG AS
THE CORE.
CONTENT WAS CONSISTENT WE WOULD
BE -- WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO GIVE
INFORMATION TO HELP DESIGN WHAT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE TO MAKE
SURE IT WOULD BE A VALUABLE
RESOURCE.
ON THE NEXT ITEM IS REFORM IS
DASHBOARD REQUIREMENTS -- THIS
WOULD JUST EXTEND THE
DEPARTMENT'S DASHBOARD -- THAT
EACH REGIONAL CENTER WOULD BE
POSTING AND HAVE ON THEIR
WEBSITE THEIR RELATIVES THEIR
PARTICULAR REGIONAL CENTERS
DASHBOARD I'M AND A LINK TO THE
DEPARTMENT SO -- THEIR COMMUNITY
WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT THE
ELEMENTS ARE IN MEASURING -- THE
KEY TRANSPARENCY PIECES AT THAT
REGIONAL CENTER AND THEN BE ABLE
TO GO TO THE DEPARTMENTS TO DO A
STATEWIDE COMPARISON.
THEN IN THE IN THE NEXT SECTION
IS ABOUT BOARD GOVERNANCE --
THERE ARE THREE ELEMENTS THAT WE
HAVE THAT WOULD BE RELATED TO
BOARD GOVERNANCE IS REALLY
LOOKING AT THAT KIND OF THE
BROAD MEAN THE RESPONSIBILITY
AND AND GOVERNANCE OF OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS SO.
AT THE BOARD GOVERNING BOARD
MEETINGS -- FOR MEETING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IS THAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE BOARDS TO MEET WITH
THE DEPARTMENT UPON OUR REQUEST --
AND THAT WOULD MEAN THAT IN THE
EVENT THAT THERE IS A NEED IN
THE RARE EVENT THAT TO DO THAT
WITHOUT ANY REGIONAL CENTER.
STAFF THAT THAT WOULD BE MET BY
THE BOARD UPON THE DEPARTMENTS
REQUEST.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE GOVERNING
WORDS -- EXPERTISE LOOKING AT
ENHANCING THE EXPERTISE OF THE
GOVERNING BOARDS RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NOT A REQUIREMENT FOR
KIND OF THE FISCAL OR FINANCIAL
EXPERTISE THIS WOULD BE ADDING
THAT ELEMENT -- BUT ALSO THEN
PROVIDING THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THEY HAVE -- WITHIN STATUTE A
REQUIREMENT FOR MANAGEMENT BUT
IT WOULD GIVE THEM THE OPTION TO
USE MANAGEMENT OR SOMEBODY WHO
HAS -- EXPERIENCE IN -- BOARD
GOVERNANCE.
THE NEXT ITEM IS LEGAL COUNSEL
REGARDING CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IS THAT WHEN THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
THEIR LEGAL COUNSEL ON THAT THAT
COUNCIL IS NOT AN EMPLOYEE OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER SO.
KIND OF EXTENDING SOME CONFLICT
OF INTEREST MAKING SURE THAT
WERE FREE OF CONFLICT AND THAT
THERE IS -- AT REPRESENTATION TO
THE GOVERNING BOARDS THAT IS
DOES NOT HAVE THE CONFLICT TO
BEING AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER.
THE NEXT ITEM IS FOR CONSUMER
SAFETY -- LOOKING TO EXTEND
BACKGROUND CHECKS -- WELL MANY
OF THE LICENSE SETTINGS THEY ALL
HAVE REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
BACKGROUND CHECKS MANY OF THE
NON LICENSE SETTINGS DO NOT.
SO WITH THE RELATION WITH THE
RATE ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE WOULD
BE LOOKING AT EXTENDING
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO THOSE --
SERVICES THAT ARE TARGETED FOR
INCREASES THAT DON'T ALREADY
HAVE A REQUIREMENT FOR
BACKGROUND CHECKS WITHIN THOSE
TARGETED SERVICES -- WE HAVE THE
FAMILY HOME AGENCY AND
COMMUNICATE FACILITIES THAT DO
HAVE -- EITHER STATUTORY OR
REGULATORY -- REQUIREMENTS THAT
SET THOSE BACKGROUND
REQUIREMENTS THIS WOULD EXTENDED
TO SUPPORTED LIVING AND THEN
ALSO TO SOME OF THE SUPPORT
SERVICES.
HEALTH AND SAFETY -- THIS WOULD
ALLOW FOR THE DEPARTMENT THE
DIRECTOR TO BE ABLE TO ISSUE
GUIDANCE TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS
IN THE EVENT THAT THERE IS A
NEED TO ESTABLISH A KIND OF A
STATE WIDE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
PROTECTION -- AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
WOULD BE IF THERE IS AN INSTANCE
IF THERE'S A PROVIDER THAT IS A
MULTIPLE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
FOR SOME REASON THERE'S A NEED
TO GO AHEAD AND SAY WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME -- VISITS TO THE HOMES
TO ASSURE SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT THAT COULD BE DONE FROM A
DIRECTIVE AS AN APARTMENT -- TO
BE ABLE TO DO MORE THAT STATE
WHITENESS AS OPPOSED TO REGIONAL
CENTERS -- CERTAINLY THEY'RE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
THE SAFETY IS THERE BUT THERE
MAY BE TIMES WHEN THERE'S A
ISSUE THAT'S OCCURRING WITH ONE
REGIONAL CENTER IN THE NORTH
THAT THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL CENTERS MAY NOT BE
AWARE OF IT.
THIS -- IS GIVING A BIG PICTURE --
VANTAGE POINT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE AND
ASSURING SAFETY FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN THE COMMUNITY -- THE NEXT OE
IS FOR SERVICE PROVIDER QUALITY
IS THAT IN THE INSTANCE THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE SUBMITTING
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS TO
PROVIDERS FOR AREAS OF
CORRECTION.
THAT WE WOULD BE RECEIVING AS A
DEPARTMENT THOSE COPIES --
WITHIN THEIR RE ORGANIZATION WE
HAVE A NEW RISK MANAGEMENT
QUALITY MANAGEMENT -- OFFICE IF
YOU WILL AND THIS WOULD HELP
INFORM THAT OFFICE AS TO WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE AREAS WHERE WE
CAN ENHANCE WHETHER IT'S
TRAININGS ARE OTHER PROTECTIONS
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WERE AWARE
OF WHAT THE ISSUES ARE STATEWIDE
SO WE CAN MOVE IMPORTANT
POLICIES FORWARD.
THE LAST ITEM IS NATIONAL CORE
INDICATORS WE DO THE ANNUAL WE
HAVE THE NATIONAL CORE INDICATOR
SURVEYS AND DIFFERENT CYCLES AS
FAR AS COHORTS -- IN THIS
PARTICULAR ONE WE WOULD BE --
ASKING THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS --
TO ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS OF
DISCUSSION THAT WOULD BE
PRESENTED AT THEIR BOARD.
MEETINGS AND THEN THEY WOULD --
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OUTCOMES OF THOSE MEETINGS AND
THE PLAN TO ADDRESS ANY AREAS
THAT THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED AS A
REGIONAL CENTER COMMUNITY TO FOR
AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT.
THANK YOU EL AL.
SENATE PETTITTE KALLIO -- THE
THE LANGUAGE -- FOR THIS TRAILER
BILL WAS JUST CAME OUT LAST
NIGHT AND WE JUST SAW THE FACT
SHEET THE OTHER DAY SO -- WE WE
ARE STILL REVIEWING THIS BUT
SOME OF OUR INITIAL COMMENTS I
JUST LIKE TO MAKE FOUR POINTS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU AS WE AS WE ANALYZE
THIS PROPOSAL BUT INITIALLY --
WE THINK THEY ADDED OVERSIGHT OF
REGIONAL CENTERS IS PROBABLY A
GOOD IDEA THERE A LOT OF GOOD
IDEAS IN THIS IN THIS PROPOSAL
TO HELP REGIONAL CENTERS BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF THE STATE.
STATES FUNDS -- AND TO INCLUDE
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS.
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT IT
DOES INCREASE THE WORKLOAD OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS BUT IT
COMES WITH A PROPOSAL.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS FOR THAT
WORKLOAD SO THAT'S PROBABLY A
GOOD THING -- OUR THIRD POINT
WOULD JUST BE THAT -- WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
SOME IDEAS FOR HOW TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ON SOME OF THESE.
YOU KNOW ISSUES THAT CROP UP AS
PROBLEMS -- AND REALLY MAKE IT
SORT OF IN IT -- IT INTEREST TO
HAVE CONTINUOUS LEARNING PROCESS
SO THAT IT'S NOT ALL PUNITIVE
IT'S LIKE WORKING TOGETHER TO TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
AND THEN OUR LAST POINT WOULD BE
THIS PROPOSAL ALSO COMES WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF AND WE
WOULD NOTE THAT IN JANUARY --
THE DEPARTMENT DID REQUEST FIFTY
FOUR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TWENTY
FIVE OF WHICH WOULD BE DOING
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS AS WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THIS MIGHT BE NEW WORKLOAD BUT
I'M OUR OFFICE IS STILL NOT
CONVINCED THAT SOME OF THESE NEW
TASKS COULD NOT BE ABSORBED BY A
THOSE.
NEW POSITIONS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY REQUESTED.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS--
COUPLE QUESTIONS SIR COMMENTS SO
FIRST OF ALL -- REGARDING THE
THE PROPOSAL -- MENTION A
DASHBOARD -- CONTRACT REPORTING --
IS THERE.
ARE SO WAS THE LEGISLATURE
EXPRESS IT'S A STRONG DESIRE TO
SEE WE ADDRESS THE DISPARITY
ISSUE AND I THINK THIS CONCERNS
NOT SUFFICIENT PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE.
ARE WE GOING.
TO AND WE INCORPORATE --
STANDARDS -- FOR ADDRESS -- FOR
THAT TO ELIMINATE RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN THIS [inaudible]
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE.
YES SIR WHERE -- THE WE DO HAVE
WITHIN -- OUR DASHBOARD AND WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT POSTING OF
SOME OF THE MEASURES THAT WE
HAVE FOR DISPARITY WE DO HAVE
THAT IN THERE -- I'D HAVE TO
DOUBLE CHECK BUT I'M PRETTY SURE
WE HAVE -- WITHIN OUR DASHBOARD --
THE THE THE DISPARITIES PEACE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN ENHANCE THAT AND
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
WE'RE DOING THE COMPARISONS AND
THE MEASURES AND TRACKING OKAY
ON THAT AS WELL AND A A VAIO IT
DASHBOARDS AND MONITORING IS
GOOD I POINTED OUT FOR SOME
OTHER AGENCIES WE ALSO NEED
MINIMUM STANDARDS PERFORMANCE.
SO ARE WE GOING TO WORK ON THAT
AS WELL SO IT'S I MEAN. THREE
WERE MONITORING IN SOMEONE'S
DOING POORLY AND WE GO ALL
THEY'RE DOING POORLY.
AND THEY'RE DOING POORLY AGAIN
AND ARE DOING POORLY AGAIN SO I
THINK YOU KNOW WE NEED.
TO BUY CERTAINLY -- AGREE WITH
LA -- FIRST APPROACH SHOULD BE
WHAT CAN KIND OF ASSISTANCE WE
CAN GIVE YOU TO IMPROVE BUT AN
ORGANIZATION OF PERSISTENTLY
DOES NOT IMPROVE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CONSEQUENCES.
OKAY AND THEN THE OTHER PIECES
THAT.
YOU KNOW IT AT A PREVIOUS
HEARING -- WAS DISTURBED TO HEAR
SOME PEOPLE INDICATE THERE'S
SOME ISSUES AROUND PEOPLE THEN
FEEL FREE TO EXPRESSED PROBLEMS --
SO AGAIN FOR ACCOUNTABILITY I
DON'T KNOW WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
MECHANISMS BY WHICH IF SOMEONE
DOESN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE.
REPORTING WHAT THEY PERCEIVE THE
PROBLEMS AND AGAIN THAT NOW
REQUIRES INVESTIGATION WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE REALITY IS.
THAT THERE ARE WE HAVE THOSE
MECHANISMS -- THE THAT SAID
THEY'RE NOT JUST REPORTING TO
THE SAME GET OUT THERE NOT
COMPLAIN TO THE SAME CENTER
TODAY NOW DEPENDENT ON FOR
SERVICES ARE APPLYING FOR
SERVICES FROM SO -- WITHERED AS
MECHANISM FOR GOING THROUGH
THE STATE -- ARE IN A BUG'S MEN
TYPE SYSTEM WHERE BASICALLY THEY
KNOW THE PERSON YOU'RE TALKING
TO IS NOT THE SAME PERSON WHO'S
GONNA AND THEN ALSO HAVE CONTROL
OVER.
OUR IT HAS RELATIONSHIP DOWN THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEN MAKES
THAT THE BASICALLY THE PEOPLE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO REPORT THINGS --
WITHOUT FEAR -- OBVIOUSLY THEY
NEED TO BE INVESTIGATED WE DON'T
TO STILL AT THAT AND THE FINAL
THROUGH THE PROBLEM IS BUT I
THINK AS FAR AS ACCOUNTABILITY --
I THINK SOUNDS IT SEEMS TO ME
I'M HEARING A LOT AND I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SO IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT -- THAT THE PARTS
DEPARTMENT ALSO LOOKING INTO.
YESTERDAY AND CERTAINLY MANY OF
THE POINTS THAT THAT THAT YOU
HAD IDENTIFIED AS FAR AS AREAS
OF CONCERN AND AND WE AGREED
THAT.
THE THE DISCUSSION THAT WE WOULD
BE HAPPY WITH REGIONAL CENTERS
THIS COMES ALSO WITHIN THE
REORGANIZATION IS REALLY KIND OF
THAT.
THAT MERRY BRINGING TOGETHER
MERGING OF THE INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE WORKING WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS YOU KNOW HOW
CAN WE YOU KNOW CAN HELP IMPROVE.
SHARE BEST PRACTICES THINGS THAT
ARE GOING FORWARD BUT IN THOSE
INSTANCES WHEN THERE ARE THAT
THE THE PROBLEMS THAT CONCERNS
OR A DRESSING.
UP A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN IF IF
FAMILIES ARE FEELING INTIMIDATED
TO ASK FOR HELP WHERE DO THEY GO.
SO REALLY WITHIN CANADA THAT
STEMS KIND OF THE THOUGHT OF
DOING THAT INTAKE PACKET AS AN
EXAMPLE IS THAT EVERYBODY WOULD
HAVE INFORMATION AS TO WHAT THE
SERVICES ARE.
PHONE NUMBERS THAT THEY CAN CALL
THAT IS BOTH WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER BECAUSE MANY TIMES.
YOU KNOW THINGS CAN BE RESOLVED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT IN THOSE
INSTANCES IF NOT WHAT OF THOSE
OTHER PHONE NUMBERS WHERE THE
FAMILY OR THE CONSUMER CAN
ACCESS. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
THAT CONVERSATION THAT THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH SO MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THEIR INPUT AS WERE
DEVELOPING NOT.
SO FROM THE FAMILY'S PERSPECTIVE
WHAT IS KIND OF A HELPFUL.
PACKET THAT'S NOT JUST YOU KNOW
FULL OF NICE PICTURES BUT IT
REALLY IS INFORMATIVE TO HELP
THEM BE ABLE TO GET TO SOME OF
THOSE POINTS THAT WERE HEARING
AS WELL.
AND AND JUST ONE LAST THING ON
THE PERFORMANCE PIECE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S PART OF THE CHANGES OF
THE PERFORMANCE CONTRACT IS THAT
CURRENTLY WE'RE REPORTING AN
IMPROVEMENT FROM YEAR OVER YEAR.
SO IF YOU HAVE YOU KNOW A
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE --
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED ONE THE NEXT YEAR THAT
SHOWING PROGRESS SO TO SPEAK.
WE WOULD BE CHANGING THAT AND
SAYING THAT LET'S ESTABLISH A
GOAL WHAT IS THE GOAL FOR THE
YOU KNOW THAT NEXT YEAR SO IT'S
A MEANINGFUL GOLD IT'S AN
INFORMED GOAL AND THEN MEASURING
TO TO THOSE PIECES SO WE WOULD
BE.
THOSE ALL OF THOSE AREAS ARE THE
PIECES THAT OVER.
THE IMPLEMENTATION THE
PERFORMANCE CONTRACT
IMPLEMENTING SOME STANDARDIZE
PRACTICES IMPLEMENTING OUR OUR
REORGANIZATION AND AND DOING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DURING THE
CORRECTIVE ACTION BUT THEN ALSO
SHARING BEST PRACTICES.
IS GOING TO BE UP AT PRETTY
IMPORTANT TIME RIGHT NOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT.
THANK YOU AND YES ERTAINLY WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WORKING
VERY HARD FOR ALL THE RIGHT
REASONS IN A REGIONAL CENTERS --
BUT I ALSO PERCEIVES -- THAT WE
MAY HAVE -- AND UNDERLYING
CHALLENGE WITH TYPICALLY PEOPLE
FROM DIVERSE COMMUNITIES --
THEY'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
SYSTEM WE ALREADY KNOW THEIR
STIGMA ISSUES AROUND DOLLY
MENTAL HEALTH BUT DEVELOPMENTAL
ISSUES GET TIED UP INTO THAT --
THEN THERE'S LANGUAGE BARRIERS
CULTURAL BARRIERS -- PEOPLE'S
EXPECTATIONS AND SO FORTH AND
WELL AND AND WE WE CAN'T JUST
SIMPLY SAY WELL THEY HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT RIGHT WE NEED WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO SERVE
THOSE FAMILIES I THINK THE
DISPARITY ISSUE SHOWS SOME OF
OUR CHALLENGES DOING THAT THEY
DIED THEY DON'T.
FEEL WELCOME DATE THERE AT SO.
THIRD THAT CALLS FOR SOME
CULTURE CHANGE NOT SAYING THAT
CENTERS ARE WORKING VERY HARD.
AND AND DOING THEIR BEST -- BUT
I THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO LOOK
STRUCTURALLY AT THE NATURE OF
WHAT HOW THOSE INTERACTIONS
HAPPEN WITH PEOPLE FROM DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES DEFER YEAH AND AND
AND DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND
EXPERIENCES -- IN MANY WAYS
ACTUALLY WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT WE THESE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES I DON'T
SEE OUR UNIQUE BUT YOU KNOW WE
TRY TO BE A LEADER -- BUT THAT
ALSO MEANS PEOPLE COME FROM A
LOT OF DIFFERENT OTHER PLACES
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THAT KIND
OF EXPERIENCE OUR EXPECTATION
AND WE NEED.
TO HELP EDUCATE THEM AND BE ABLE
TO BE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
YEAH AND AND AGAIN SENATOR WE WE
SHARE THAT THE IMPORTANCE AND WE
CAN'T SLOW DOWN ON OUR EFFORTS.
ON THAT IMPORTANT TOPIC YOU KNOW
AND THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WE'VE BEEN DOING
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK AND
AS FAR AS ADDRESSING.
KIND OF INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES AND IT SAY A
MARATHON.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
YOU KNOW TAKE A LOOK AT AND
PRIORITIZE AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO DO THAT WE STARTED YOU KNOW
WE'VE DONE SOME SOME TRAINING
BRINGING AND GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY WITH SOME EXPERTISE
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCE AND
LINGUISTIC.
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO DO THAT
TRAINING WE DONE THE TRAINING
WITH ALL REGIONAL CENTERS MANY
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE
EXTENDED THAT TO BRING THAT.
TO THEIR SERVICE COORDINATORS TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE REALLY KEY AND
AND CRITICAL ISSUES ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THOSE CULTURAL
BARRIERS -- SO WE WE DON'T PLAN
ON LETTING UP THE GAS PEDAL ON
THAT -- IT'S IMPORTANT IT'S A A
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO TO WORK ITH OUR
COMMUNITY ON THOSE IMPORTANT
AREAS.
THANK YOU A PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF SENATOR STONE RICK
ROLLINS -- ASSOCIATION REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES -- AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
SPECIFICS ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WAS JUST RELEASED A
COUPLE HOURS AGO AND SO WE'RE
BUSY -- ANALYZING IT WE OE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOME QUESTIONS AND
WE WILL FOLLOW UP POST HASTE
WITH A LETTER TO YOU ON OUR
POSITIONS ON THAT ISSUE -- WE DO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THE RECOGNITION OF FUNDING
TO IMPLEMENT WHATEVER THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION DECIDES TO DO
WITH THESE PROPOSALS -- THAT
OFTEN IS NOT THE CASE WE GET A
LOT OF EXTRA WORK PUT ON
REGIONAL CENTERS TO PROVIDE WITH
A LITTLE OR NO FUNDING TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI -- MARTY MOTOS HE
CAN'T FAMILY MEMBER JUST WANT.
TO SHOW APPRECIATION FOR THE
INTENT OR OF THE PROPOSALS.
BY THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD WANT
TO WORK OR GET -- TO LEGISLATURE
TO REQUEST MORE DETAIL ON SOME
OF THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
INSPECTION ON THE AREA OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY -- WOULD --
BIG EXEMPTIONS OF WHICH ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT -- LASTLY AN
ISSUE OF DISPARITIES I JUST
WANNA STRESS.
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THE
CENTER THAT YOU HAVE MADE BUT
THAT ALL ALL STRESS AGAIN WE
NEED TO TAKE A WHOLE PERSON
APPROACH IN TERMS OF REDUCING
DISPARITIES.
MY FAMILY MY SISTER IN COUNTY
BARRIERS IN SEVERAL SYSTEMS MEDI
CAL.
YOU KNOW SUPPORT SERVICES FROM
THE COUNTY REGIONAL CENTER AND
PRIVATE INSURANCE AND IT DIDN'T
MATTER OF FAMILIES THAT SOMEONE
ELSE SOMEONE SAID NO WE MY DAD
MY MOM JUST SAW IT AS GOVERNMENT
SAY NO.
AND SO WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
AND THERE HAS BEEN PROGRESS MADE
BUT WE NEED TO DO BETTER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
A NANCY CHANCE A FAMILY MEMBER
CHOICES ERSONS AND SERVICES I I
JUST WANTED TO SAY I AM
ABSOLUTELY THRILLED SAYING --
THE CONSUMER SAFETY PIECE ABOUT
FINGERPRINTING -- I THINK THIS
IS JUST SO IMPORTANT AND WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS AND I'M
JUST REALLY GLAD TO SEE THAT
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE KNOW THE COMMENTS THAT
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND I
THINK IT SOUNDS LIKE EVERYONE
STILL BUSY READING THE LANGUAGE.
THEY JUST GOT.
OKAY -- THIS ONE ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR PORTERFIELD CIVILIZATION
TRAINING IS A SENSORY
INTEGRATION FACILITIES.
YES -- ISSUE FOR IS RELATED --
TO THE GOVERNOR'S -- BUDGET WE
HAVE PROPOSED THE EXTENSION OF
OUR STAR SERVICES AND THAT WOULD
BE TO HOMES IN THE COMMUNITY --
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND THEN
ALSO THE CASTER VERSES THIS
ACTUALLY WOULD -- GIVE US
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE A UNIT AT
FORTY BILL RIGHT NOW THE GENERAL
TREATMENT AREA TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE UP TO TEN INDIVIDUALS --
UNDER THE STAR MODEL AND TELL
THE HOMES IN THE COMMUNITY ARE
READY AND THEN WE WOULD
TRANSITION THE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THIS THE THE PORTER BILL SITE TO
THE COMMITTEE WE DID THIS --
SIMILAR AT START IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WHO JUST
TRANSITION AND THEN THE LAST
WEEK TO THE COMMUNITY AND THEN
WE'RE ALSO DOING THE SAME THAN
AT FAIRVIEW.
THANK YOU ALEJO.
SENATE PARTICULARLY -- ARE ONLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS ISSUE IS
THAT IT'S IT'S A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION BUT WE'RE NOT FULLY
CONVINCED OF THAT -- THAT THERE
WOULDN'T BE A REQUEST FOR
FUNDING NEXT YEAR AS WELL OF
THOSE HOMES DON'T COME ONLINE
YOU KNOW AS OF JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SO -- THIS IS JUST TO
POINT OUT THAT APPROVING FUNDING
THIS YEAR YOU MIGHT BE
COMMITTING YOURSELF -- TO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN IN FUTURE
YEARS [inaudible]
OKAY FINANCE.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY FOR EARLIER
THOUGH I MEAN.
THESE ARE.
PATIENTS TO RAISE SO.
IF WE DIDN'T DO THIS.
YES YES STILL BE HAPPY WE WE
CANNOT COMMIT EITHER WAY RIGHT
YEAH WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT
IT'S JUST I I'M NOT SURE THE ONE
TIME -- CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
PHONE OKAY SO IT'S VERY LIKELY
YEAH BUT IT IT -- IT SO EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE JUST CALLED A TIME
WHEN YOU'RE MAY ACTUALLY BE A
MULTI YEAR UNTIL YEAH YEAH I
THINK ANYBODY DISAGREES ABOUT
THE RIGHT.
OKAY IT'S IT'S THIS OUT IS IS
THIS AN ACCURATE SELECTION OF
THE ACTUAL COST OF DOING THIS
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
CONSUMERS OKAY SOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
POPULATION STUFFING A STAFFING
ADJUSTMENT.
YES ISSUE FIVE IS RELATED -- TO
SOME OF THE STAFFING THAT IS
PROJECTED -- FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT OUR END
OF INDIAN POPULATION WITH THE
CLOSURE OF FAIRVIEW IMPORTER
BILL -- WELL WE CERTAINLY TRY TO
PREDICT OUR BEST TRANSITION
PLANS AND AND MORE FOLKS ARE IN
THEIR TRANSITION -- BY THE END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR -- WE DON'T
ALWAYS GET IT EXACT AND SO WHEN
WE WE PROJECTED -- FOR THE END
OF THE YEAR THAT WE WOULD BE
ENTERING JULY FIRST -- AT
FAIRVIEW WITH FIVE UNITS THAT
WOULD BE OPEN.
THE NEXT TO THE IF WE STILL
PROJECT FIVE UNITS HOWEVER THE
MIX OF UNITS AS DIFFERENT SO WE
WERE LOOKING AT HAVING TO A
NURSING FACILITY UNITS OPEN ONE
AND TWO ICF UNITS AND THEN --
ONE I A CUTE -- THAT WOULD BE
OPEN.
HOWEVER BASED ON THE THE THE WAY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE MOVED TO THE
COMMUNITY WE'VE HAD MORE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN AND
ARE NURSING FACILITIES THAT HAVE
TRANSITION TO THE COMMUNITY --
BY JUNE THIRTIETH AND WE DID
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN IN OUR
ICE YEAH.
NOW OUR ICF -- FACILITY HAS --
IS UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE CMS
AGREEMENT WERE BY THE END OF
JUNE THIRTIETH THAT WE WOULD
HAVE FIVE INDIVIDUALS PART OF
THE CMS AGREEMENT.
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO CLAIM
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR THOSE FIVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAS CHANGED
FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- FROM
OUR PROJECTION IS THAT WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT OUR TO
POPULATION AT FAIRVIEW THAT THE
MIX OF OF INDIVIDUALS WOULD
CHANGE SO WE WOULD HAVE
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS.
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE CLAIMING
FEDERAL DOLLARS -- FOR BECAUSE
THEY HAD NOT TRANSITION WE STILL
DO ANTICIPATE EVERYBODY
TRANSITIONING -- WITHIN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS OF THE FISCAL
YEAR -- SO BY THE END OF
DECEMBER WE WOULD HAVE EVERYBODY
MOVED [inaudible]
HELLO.
THIS THIS THIS CHANGE IN THE IN
THE ESTIMATE DID -- REYES ONE
CONCERN FOR US WHICH IS THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THE MAN THE
MIX CHANGES THAT SEVERAL
RESIDENTS HAD TO MOVE BACK FROM
THEIR COMMUNITY PLACEMENTS AFTER
THEY'D ALREADY MOVED TO THE
COMMUNITY.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS HAD SOME
A SPECIAL LIKE ESPECIALLY
COMPLEX -- HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS -- HOWEVER IT'S JUST
IT'S JUST TO POINT OUT THIS.
THIS ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND AT A TIME WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO AUGMENT FUNDING ON THE
COMMUNITY SIDE IS IS SORT OF A
SHAME.
BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT --
INDIVIDUALS WHO MOVE IN THE
FUTURE BUT YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S SORT OF A A PLAN IN
PLACE FOR FOR THESE TOUGH
PLACEMENTS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FINANCE OKAY REMEMBERS
PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY.
SO YEAH I MEAN I THINK THE AND
I'D REALLY AS THAT'S THE
INTENTION WHEN WE MOVE PEOPLE A
COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT SUPPORT THEY CAN STAY
THERE AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE
NOW PAYING FOR THEM TO COME BACK
[inaudible]
IS IT.
REALIZE THAT -- YOU KNOW WHO'S
WHO'S KEEPING YOU LIKE WOOD IF
WE HAD WELL WE TOOK THAT MONEY
AND THEN SPENT IN THE COMMITTEE
COULD HAVE STAYED THERE
OBVIOUSLY IT SEEMS LIKE THAT WAS
NOT QUITE THE CASE BUT NOW IT
THE CELL.
BUT THIS WERE OF ALL IS ARE
MOVING DOWN THE LINE THAT SOME
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT BECAUSE THE GOAL IS
TO GET.
THIS TO KEEP MOVING THAT
DIRECTION.
ALL RIGHT -- ACTUALLY JUST
BEFORE WE MOVE ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER SIX MAY NOT MAKE A BRIEF
NIGHT IT'S MY INTENTION TO DO A
TEN MINUTE RECESS AFTER WE
CONCLUDE THIS ITEM SO FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING FOR
PART B. -- AFTER WE FINISH --
THE SECOND -- PART A THE ABOUT
TEN MINUTES IF YOU.
BREAK IS SO.
IN TERMS OF WHEN YOU HAVE TO
HEAD OVER HERE OKAY SO WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX EARLY BECAUSE EARLY START
COPAYMENTS.
YES THANK YOU -- AS CORRECTLY
STATED IN THE AGENDAS THAT --
THIS REQUEST IS AN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD -- ALLOW -- FOR
THOSE -- FAMILIES THAT HAVE
PRIVATE INSURANCE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTER FOR PAIN THE OUT
OF POCKET.
EXPENSES FOR CO PAYMENTS AND
DEDUCTIBLES AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GRANT AND
THE PROVISIONS OF ARC A FEDERAL
GRANT AND SO THIS WE GET AN
ALIGNMENT -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT OKAY HELLO
COMMENTS FINANCE.
PUBLIC COMMENTS ABOUT SOMEONE
COMING UP.
MCCARTY MOTO US HE CAN'T FAMILY
MEMBER REALLY STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED IN THIS AREA.
THE GOOD START.
EARLY START -- GE BUT ALSO ONE
ENCOURAGE THAT THE ISSUES OF FOR
THE FAMILY TO AN EARLY START AND
ALSO THE PROVIDERS BE INCLUDED
IN THE LARGER DISCUSSIONS -- BY
THE DMINISTRATION AND ALSO BY
THE LEGISLATURE FOCUSING IN ON
OF IMPROVING EARLY CHILDHOOD
CARE AND EDUCATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT A SINGLE INCOME OF THE
WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN FAMILY HELP ME TO
SEE OVERSIGHT.
YES THIS IS -- THAT THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE IS -- TO INCREASE --
THE FUNDING FOR REGIONAL CENTERS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A STAFF
PERSON THAT CAN PROVIDE THE NOT
ONLY THE OVERSIGHT BUT TO
ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT OF FAMILY
HOME AGENCIES IT'S AN AREA.
IN WHICH NOT ONLY IS IT -- IN
ALIGNMENT WITH H. CBS --
COMPLAINTS WITH THE FEDERAL RULE
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY AN OPTION
THAT REALLY DOES ALLOW FOR MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES SOMEONE THAT -- HAS
BEEN DESIRED FOR SOME AND SO
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND THAT.
HELLO A IT'S ALSO ENTERED OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT APARTMENT
HOPES TO EXPAND THE USE OF THESE --
THIS THESE TYPES OF RESIDENTIAL
PLACEMENTS AND SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY NEED MONITORING THIS
PROPOSAL LIKELY MAKE SENSE.
THANK YOU FINANCE RIGHT PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY SEEN NONE WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN.
A SPECIALIZED SO MONITORS.
SO ISSUE EIGHT ON THE THIS IS A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT THIS IS --
FROM THE PROJECTION THAT WE HAD
FOR THE SALARY FOR THE BEHAVIOR
SPECIALIST THAT WOULD BE PART OF
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT OF OUR EBS
H. HOME SO IT'S JUST A MINOR
ADJUSTMENT -- FOR THE
COMPENSATION FOR THAT THE STAFF
AND AND THAT IS REFLECTED AS FAR
AS A SLIGHT INCREASE FROM
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OKAY THANK YOU
VALUE.
OKAY FINANCE PUBLIC COMMENT YES.
DR AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
RICK ROLLINS AGAIN WITH -- ARCA
SO SHE SHE REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES SO IN JANUARY WE
TESTIFIED ABOUT THE FUNDING
LEVEL FOR THIS ITEM UP IN A
LITTLE INADEQUATE AND NOW WE
REALLY APPRECIATED MINISTRATION.
ADDRESS IT BY INCREASING IN THIS
THIS ITEM THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT -- ALL THIS ITEM
OPEN THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON THE
ISSUE NUMBER NINETY SLOWED AND
UTILIZATION ADJUSTMENT.
YES THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT --
THE UPDATE THAT I PROVIDE AN
ISSUE ONE AS FAR AS TAKING A
LOOK AT THE SLIGHT INCREASING
CASELOAD THE ADJUSTMENT AND THEN.
THE UPDATED NUMBERS BASED ON THE
UTILIZATION AND THE PARTICULAR
SERVICE CATEGORY SUPPORT
SERVICES MISCELLANEOUS
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
PUBLIC COMMENT NONE OKAY WALL
THIS ITEM OPEN AS WELL.
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER TEN UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE SUSPENSION.
YES -- ISSUE TEN IS -- OUR
PROPOSAL FOR SUSPENDING THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE -- IT
REFLECTS AS A SUSPENSION IN
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE HALF DAY BILLION -- BUT IT
DOES -- PROJECT THE SUSPENSION
OF THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE.
THANK YOU HELLO NO COMMENTS
ASIDE FROM OUR GENERAL COMMENT
ABOUT THE SUN SETS OKAY FINANCE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- SO WIDE THE REASON
SETTING THIS IS IT.
OKAY.
ARE YOUR BUDGET SO THIS IS IN
RELATION TO THE PARTICIPATION WE
HAD WITH -- THAT YOU'RE FOR
CASPAR REVENUES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY HISTORY SAID WHAT
I SAID ABOUT THE PREVIOUS ONES.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
NANCY CHANCE US TRANSMISSION
CENTER SERVICES SO HAPPY TO HAVE
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY -- NOT BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
NOW.
COMPLETELY OPPOSED TO IT HAVING
A SUNSET -- I A WANNA AGREE WITH
WHAT MARTY MOTHER SAID EARLIER
IT SHOULD BE JUST AS HARD TO
MAKE A CUT AS IT IS TO GET AN
INCREASE AND THIS IS JUST A CUT
SO WE OPPOSE.
THE SUNSET THANKS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN JORDAN INTO
WITH THE ARGUMENTS RIPPLES LIKE
COLLABORATIVE -- APPRECIATIVE OF
THE SUSPENSION OF UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE -- OAK ALSO
OPPOSE THE SUNSET OF IT WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THE PRICE
TAG ON IT -- IN OUR PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE HEARING YOU HEARD THAT
IN THE ASSUMPTION WAS SOMEWHERE
AROUND EIGHT DAYS WOULD BE TAKEN
FOR A HOLIDAY -- WE THINK THAT
MIGHT BE A LITTLE LOW JUST
SAYING THAT IN YOUR FINAL
SCORING OF EVERYTHING -- THIS
THE THE PRICE IT'S ON THIS THE
COST MIGHT ACTUALLY BE HIGHER
THAN ACTUALLY BE WE MIGHT THINK
THAT'LL BE A LOWER AS YOU COST
EVERYTHING OUT IN THE END --
BECAUSE PEOPLE WON'T BE WILL BE
TAKING MORE THAN EIGHT DAYS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M
DISAPPOINTED AT HALF THE BILLING
WAS NOT INCLUDING THIS HALF THE
BILLION IF WE GO IF SERVICES
GOOD HOURLY AS RECOMMENDED IN
THE RATE STUDY FOR CERTAIN TYPES
OF SERVICES.
DON'T KNOW IF THEY WILL BUT IF
THEY DO THEN HAVE TO BILLINGS A
MOOT POINT HAVE TWO BILLION
STREET SHOULD BE SUSPENDED AS
WELL UNTIL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RATES CITY AT THAT TIME IT COULD
BE LOOKED AT AGAIN BECAUSE BE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WORLD OF
BILLING -- BUT ALSO JUST HAVE TO
MENTION THINGS THAT WE DON'T
SEEN HERE MENTION THAT WE DON'T
SEE A FIX TO THE MINIMUM WAGE
QUIRK WHICH ON JANUARY ONE THIS
YEAR ENGINE ONE AGAIN NEXT YEAR
IS GOING TO HAVE MAJOR IMPACTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND SOCIAL RECKON CAMP NOT
INCLUDED UNFORTUNATELY THANK YOU
OKAY AND WE WE DID HEROES ITEMS
PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU WELCOME.
DOCTOR PANDA RICK ROLLINS --
ASSOCIATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR PRIOR
WORK IN THIS AREA I KNOW YOU'VE
TEAMED UP TO THE COMMERCE
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR LEASE THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS.
THE REPEAL OF THE SERVER FOR LOW
ON SCHEDULE ANARCHISM BEEN
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THAT OF
THAT ACTION ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT.
WHEN YOU -- FORESEES FURLOUGH
DAYS SOME PROVIDERS SAID THE
NEED FOR SERVICES DON'T GO AWAY
I HAVE A TWENTY EIGHT YEAR OLD
SON WAS VERY SEVERE AUTISM AND
WHEN HIS DAY PROGRAM GOES DOWN I
HAVE TO CALL MY REGIONAL CENTER
AND SAY HEY I NEED HELP IN OTHER
WAYS TO MAKE UP. FOR THE
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE
BECAUSE OF THE USE FORCE
FURLOUGH DAYS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CARL LUNDEN
ABOUT THE ALLIANCE I JUST WANT
TO COMPLETELY 1100%.
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER
LINDSEY THANK.
THANK YOU LOCAL MARTY MOTOR
FAMILY MEMBER CITY CAN SUPPORT
THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS MADE ON
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
ALSO REALLY QUICK COMMENT ON THE
FAMILY HOME AGENCIES A PROPOSAL
THAT THE MINISTRY XIN ADVANCE.
STRONG SUPPORT THAT I AM PART OF
THE EXTENDED FAMILY OF A YOUNG
MAN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND FRESNO.
WHEN HIS MOM DIED A YEAR AGO HE
HAD NO FAMILY LEFT OTHER THAN ME?
AND THE FAMILY HOME AGENCY IN
THE REGIONAL CENTER AND THE
PROVIDERS ARE REALLY MADE SURE
THAT HE BECAUSE OF THAT HE WOULD
HIS LIFE WAS IN PUTTING CRISIS
AND SO VERY.
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT MODEL AND
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING IS A
SMALL PIECE OF THE LARGER ISSUE
OF HOUSING.
FOR OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WELL I DECIDE DO WANNA
THANK -- THE GOVERNOR AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR PUTTING FORTH --
SUSPENSION OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE SO APPRECIATING
THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF
MARTIN'S SEVERAL THINGS -- BUT
CERTAINLY THIS IN PARTICULAR
SEEM TO BE PARTICULARLY -- WELL
AND FAIR AND THAT -- BED AND NOT
CONCORDANT WITH THE REALITY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY DELIVERS
SERVICES I APPRECIATE THAT --
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD -- SOLD A
WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN NEXT ISSUES
BEST BUDDIES.
THIS ISSUE -- ELEVEN REFLECTS
CORRECTLY IN THE AGENDA -- I
REQUEST FOR INCREASE OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THIS WOULD BE A
TOTAL -- CONTRACT OF TWO MILLION --
ALONG WITH THAT THOUGH WOULD BE
REPORTING BACK AS FAR AS
DELIVERABLES THAT WOULD BE
INCLUDE IN THE CONTRACT.
HELLO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THIS CHAIRMAN
A CARL LUNDEN ON THE OF THE
ALLIANCE'S ONE RESPECTFULLY --
SAY THAT WE OPPOSE THE INCLUSION
THIS THIS PROGRAM.
IS NO DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THIS
POPULATION.
AND WE SOON SEE NO REASON WHY
THIS WOULD HAVE A SPECIAL
AUGMENTATION.
IN COMPARISON TO THE REST OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE PROVIDING SIMILAR
SERVICES ON A DAILY BASIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
AS AS WELL.
SO IT'S BEEN STATED THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT IS THERE ANY THING
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM THAT.
IN TERMS OF ITS DELIVERY
COMPARED TO OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
WE FUND -- IT INTO SPACE BUT
CERTAINLY WITH THE BEST BUDDIES
YOU KNOW THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN
KNOWN AND AND TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW THEY DID -- MARK ON THE
EMPLOYMENT SPACE SO CONSISTENT
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAVE AS FAR AS
SUPPORTING COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED APPOINTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR THOSE -- EIGHT YOU DO SEE
SOME ALIGNMENT AS FAR AS THE
INTEND TO SUPPORT SOME OF THOSE
EFFORTS OKAY BUT SO BUT THE
NATURE OF THE SERVICE IS BEING
DELIVERED.
ARE SIMILAR ARE THERE ANYTHING
THAT THEY DO DIFFERENTLY OR I I
APOLOGIZE I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON
THE BEST BUDDIES PROGRAMS BUT I
I DO KNOW THAT.
KIND OF THE FRAMEWORK IN THE
SUCCESS AND AND BEING ABLE TO
SEE KIND OF THOSE OUTCOMES --
HAS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAS BEEN REPLICATED AND NOT ONLY
IN CALIFORNIA KIND OF
REPLICATING THAT BUT IN OTHER
STATES AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
REGIS ELLIE -- PLEASE POINT IN
FACT -- TO WE IT'S ALSO OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT BEST BUDDIES
IS A SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT VENDOR
OF A NUMBER OF REGIONAL CENTERS
IN ADDITION TO THE LINE ITEM
BUDGET FUNDING.
OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPENED
YOU'VE NEXT ISSUES ISSUE NMBER
TWELVE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ENHANCE BEHAVIOR SUPPORTS --
SUPPORTS HOME SUNSET EXTENSION.
YES THIS IS RELATED TO THE
ABILITY TO DEVELOP -- ENHANCE BE
ABLE SUPPORTS HOMES AND SO WE
HAVE A SUNSET TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE BECAUSE THEY'RE A PILOT
AT THIS POINT THIS WOULD EXTEND
THAT SUNSET -- WE CURRENTLY HAVE
JUST AT LESS THAN HALF OF THOSE
HOMES THAT ARE APPROVED FOR
DEVELOPMENT.
A BETTER AN OPERATION THIS WOULD
ALSO GIVE US THE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THE REST OF MANY OF THOSE
COME INTO OPERATION AND BE ABLE
TO ASSESS THE VIABILITY AND THE
OUTCOMES OF THOSE HOMES.
THANK YOU ALEJO.
FINANCE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO OKAY THANK YOU
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
THEN ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE CANYON
SPRINGS ADMISSIONS EXPANSION.
YES SIR CANYON SPRINGS ADMISSION
EXPANSION RIGHT NOW -- OUR
THIRTY TO BE ABLE TO DO
ADMISSIONS INTO CANYON SPRINGS
IS REALLY AS A STEP DOWN FROM
PORTER BILL SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM ORTRANSFER FROM AN
EXISTING STATE OPERATED
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
NOW WITH THE CLOSURE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS THERE'S A
VERY LIMITED WE ABILITY -- TO
FOR ADMISSION INTO CANYON
SPRINGS.
THERE WAS THE BILL ON CENTER
MCGUIRE IS BUILT THAT EXTENDED
CANYON SPRINGS TEMPORARILY FOR
TEN BEDS FOR IT UNDER THE STARS
SERVICES THIS IS NOT THE AREA
MUCH I'M TALKING ABOUT AS FAR AS
EXPANSION FOR CANYON SPRINGS.
THIS IS VERY SPECIFIC IN THOSE
REALLY RARE INSTANCES WERE
TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS WITH
VERY VERY COMPLEX NEEDS RIGHT
NOW.
THAT AS FAR AS TRYING TO HAVE A
TIME IN WHICH STABILIZATION AND
TREATMENT IS EXTENDED LONGER
THAN WHAT WE HAVE WITHIN OUR
EXISTING STATE OPERATED THAT
WILL BE GOING FORWARD AFTER THE
CLOSURE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS.
SO AGAIN I SEE THIS IS A VERY
LIMITED BUT IT DOES GIVE US A
EXTRA RESOURCE AND OUR TOOL BELT
IF YOU WILL -- WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE -- CERTAINLY MMHM CONTINUED
AND PROBABLY MORE IN DEPTH
CONVERSATIONS OF OUR SAFETY NET --
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT ARE SOME OF LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS SO WE DO SEE THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP STABILIZE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD WITHOUT
THAT OPTION WOULD BE STAYING IN --
I AM DES AT EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME OR EVEN EXTENDED PERIODS OF
TIME AND EMERGENCY ROOMS OR AT
ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS
WHERE THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE COLOR CURRY
NEEDS.
I THANK YOU HELLO.
A AND I APOLOGIZE WE JUST
HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH TIME TO TO
REVIEW THIS PROPOSAL IT DOES
REPRESENT A POLICY SHIFT AND
WILL CONTINUE -- TO TOOK TO LOOK
INTO IT AND AND GET BACK TO YOU.
OKAY FINANCE RIGHT PUBLIC
COMMENT AS MR JERKER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
WERE ACTUALLY VERY SURPRISED TO
SEE THIS LANGUAGE -- QUITE LATE
AS A WAS AND PARTICULARLY SINCE
IT WAS -- IS A REVERSAL OF A
VERY CLOSELY NEGOTIATED --
LANGUAGE FROM -- FROM LAST YEAR
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID THE WE
SEE -- SEVERAL PROBLEMS I THINK --
WITH THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
ONE IS THE THE EXTENT THAT IT
RESTRICTS NOW -- MINORS FROM
BEING ABLE TO BE HELD AND IN THE
CRISIS CENTERS -- WE'VE HAD A
CLIENT RECENTLY THAT ENDED UP
HAVING BE HELD -- WITHIN -- IN A
HOSPITAL -- BECAUSE THE LACK OF
AVAILABILITY AND ALMOST CONSTANT --
RESTRAINTS -- ADDITIONALLY -- AS
I MENTIONED IT IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE -- OR
RETREAT FROM FROM THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED -- LAST YEAR
TO USE -- CANYON SPRINGS REALLY
AS A LAST RESORT AND AND
ADDITIONALLY TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT DOES -- NOW INCREASE THE
CANYON SPRINGS POPULATION WE
THINK THERE SHOULD BE -- THE
CHESSMEN AS WELL -- FOR THE
OFFICE OF PATIENTS RIGHT OUR
CLIENTS RIGHTS TO BE ABLE -- TO
PROVIDE REPRESENTATION TO THEM
WE HAVE SHARED OUR PROPOSED --
AMENDMENTS WITH -- COMMITTEE
STAFF AND WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL WILL BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT --
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY -- IS SO
AND I REALIZE THAT THE LANGUAGE
WAS JUST RECEIVED SO THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE -- BUT THIS IS A THIS
INVOLVED I MEAN.
THE THE TEST THE WHOLE COMMENT
JUST MADE REFERENCE ALSO TO
CHILDREN CRISIS EXCEL WAS IS
BEYOND CANYON SPRINGS -- I MEAN
IS THERE SOME OUTWARD IMPACT
THIS IS HAVING BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
I MEAN SOUND.
YOU TALK ABOUT TOOL YOUR TOOLBOX
AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE WE NEED
PLACE BUT THEM BUT THEN IS THERE
SOME OUR PRESSURE I MEAN IS
THERE SOMETHING ABOUT HOW.
SO YEAH SO TO CLARIFY I'M I'M
NOT STE I AM HAPPY TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID AT DRC ABOUT THE
THE CHILDREN IT IS NOT.
AN ADMISSION FOR CHILDREN INTO
CANYON SPRINGS AND I ALSO WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT IT'S NOT
INCREASING THE CAPACITY.
THAT IT ACTUALLY WOULD RETAIN
OUR CURRENT BECAUSE CAPACITY
WERE NOT ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR
STAFFING ON THIS IS JUST
ACTUALLY JUST A STATUTORY CHANGE
TO ALLOW FOR ADMISSIONS.
AGAIN IN THOSE RARE INSTANCES
WHEN WE WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS IT.
IT'S NOT ASKING TO BE ABLE TO
EXTEND -- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN OUR STARS SERVICES
STAIN AND STAR SERVICES PASSED
THAT THIRTEEN MONTHS IT WOULD
GIVE HOWEVER IN ANY OF OUR STARS
WERE NOT TALKING IS AN ISOLATION
AT CANYON SPRINGS IT COULD BE.
NOR STARS SOUTH START OUR SOON
TO BE CENTRAL STARK IF FOR
CONTINUES STABILIZATION IT'S
NEEDED.
THAT THIS WOULD BE AN AREA IN
WHICH WE COULD ACCESS AS FAR AS
ADMISSION INTO CANYON SPRINGS
BUT AGAIN IT DOES NOT INCREASE
THE CAPACITY WE'RE NOT ASKING TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE -- CHILDREN
ADMITTED THERE THAT SAID WE DO
REALIZE THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THE NEEDS FOR
CHILDREN THAT WE HAVE WITH VERY
COMPLEX NEEDS WITH CO OCCURRING.
AND THERE'S THAT YOU'RE SEEING
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
THREE HOMES WE COMMITTEE CRISIS
HOMES BEING ABLE TO DEVELOP MORE.
SO WE WE DO HAVE YEAH THIS IS A
PIECE OF MANY THINGS BUT IS AN
ELEMENT THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO TO HAVE.
CURRENTLY TO SERVE A VERY SMALL
POPULATION THAT THAT NEEDS
SERVICES.
OKAY SO WELL SO LIKE WE PEOPLE
JUST KIND AT SO THAT THE LOCAL
AT THAT ALL RIGHT SO.
OKAY SO WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
AND WE'LL BE DIGGING INTO A LOT
MORE ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- SO I THINK THIS --
CONCLUDES -- THAT PART A AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATIONS FROM FARM TO
DEVELOP THE SERVICES -- SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A THE FAT TEN
MINUTE RECESS JUST SO I CAN
STAND UP AND MOVE AROUND -- AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO RECONVENE
TODAY -- FOR PART B. AS
MENTIONED AT THE HEALTH
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE COVER CALIFORNIA OFFICE
TO SEE WHAT HELP PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ITEMS.
THAT FOR THE MAY REVISED THANK
YOU
AND WELL WE FOR FIRST ITEM
IS THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE COVERED CALIFORNIA SO
FOLKS WANT TO COME UP
[inaudible]
FOR THIS ITEM.
WELCOME SO OF EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FIRST FOR THE RECORD.
CHECK IN WHEN THE PART OF
FINANCE.
COMING DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
AT REBEL COVER CALIFORNIA THE
RIVALS THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE OKAY THANK YOU VERY LONG
AGO AND AGAIN ON THAT ISSUE.
ONE SPENDING FOR THE BILLION
INITIAL HEALTH MARKET INSURANCE
MARKET UPDATE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHER AND
COMMITTEE STAFF -- I'M HERE TO
PRESENT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE AND STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM.
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES
THE GENERAL FUND NEUTRAL PROGRAM.
OVER THE FORECAST PERIOD WE
PROPOSE TO FIND A STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM UTILIZING INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY REVENUES.
COMPARED TO INITIAL ESTIMATE
SURE TO CONVERSE BUDGET WE NOW
ESTIMATE.
ESTIMATE HELD ZERO NEWS -- OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION OVER
THE THREE YEAR FORECAST PERIOD
THIS IS ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION LESS THAN PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED -- SPECIFICALLY THE
MEMBER VISION PROPOSES GENERAL
FUND ALLOCATIONS OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE POINT TWO MILLION IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY POINT FOUR MILLION AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO COMPARE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES TO PROVIDE
SUBSIDIES TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
INCOMES BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
60% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
PREVIOUSLY WAS -- TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO SIX ON A PERSONAL
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL -- THEY
WERE ALSO PROPOSING SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO OUR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE -- BASED
ON MODELING PROVIDED BY COVER
CALIFORNIA WE ASSUME THIS
PROPOSAL WILL RESULT IN EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING STATE
ASSISTANCE.
AND RESULT IN A HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND NEW ENROLLEES AND
NEARLY INDIVIDUAL NEWLY COVERED
UNDER INSURANCE.
ON AVERAGE WE ASSUME INDIVIDUALS
BELOW 4100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WILL.
RECEIVE MONTHLY SUBSIDIES OF
ABOUT TEN DOLLARS.
IN ADDITION TO THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES THEY ALREADY RECEIVE.
ON AVERAGE WE ASSUME INDIVIDUALS
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED SIX ARE
PERCENT OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
WILL RECEIVE MONTHLY SUBSIDIES
OF APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
MILLION.
OR ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH --
DENOUNCE MAY VERY SIGNIFICANTLY
BASED ON INDIVIDUALS HEALTHCARE
COSTS. TO TERMINA BY THE REGION
AGE HOUSEHOLD SIZE AND INCOME.
OF FOR COVERAGE EARS TWO ONE
THREE WERE PROPOSING TO MODIFY
THE PROGRAM DESIGNED.
TO ROUGHLY MAINTAIN THAT AVERAGE
MONTHLY PREMIUM AMOUNT FROM YOUR
ONE INTO YOUR TO WHEN YOU'RE.
THREE IF WE DO NOT MODIFY THE
PROGRAM DESIGN YOUR TO WHEN
YOU'RE THREE OF BASED OFF
MAILLET PROVIDE A COVER
CALIFORNIA WE ASSUME COSTS WILL
GROW BY UP 230% FOR THE OVER
4100% OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
POPULATION.
THIS IS PRIMARILY ATTRIBUTED
ATTRIBUTED -- TO THE INCREASE IN
PREMIUMS.
OUTPACED THE INCREASE IN
PERSONAL INCOME GROWTH THEREFORE
THE STATE SHARE OF COSTS FOR
THOSE PREMIUMS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ABOVE FOUR HUNDRED
INCREASE MORE RAPIDLY -- DUE TO
THOSE DIFFERENT GROWTH RATES --
REGARDING THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA -- ONE PROPOSING THIS
SUBSIDY PROGRAM WE INTENDED TO
CREATE A BUDGET NEUTRAL PROGRAM.
WHILE PROVIDING MEANINGFUL
MEANINGFUL SUBSIDIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVE NO
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE SO
INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN FOUR AND SIX
ARE PERCENT THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
BASED OFF THE MODELING PROVIDE A
COVER CALIFORNIA.
WE HAD TO PROVIDE AT LEAST
7100507575%.
OF THE AVAILABLE REVENUES TO
THIS POPULATION TO PROVIDE A
MEANINGFUL BENEFIT -- IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE PAYING THE PENALTY WE
ESTIMATE FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE INDIVIDUALS WILL PAY THE
PENALTY IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND FEWER
THAN IF THE FEDERAL PENALTY HAD
REMAINED IN PLACE AND TWENTY
TWENTY THAT NUMBER AGAIN.
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
PAY THE PENALTY.
WHICH IS A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FEWER THAN IF THE
FEDERAL PENALTY HAD REMAINED IN
PLACE -- BEYOND THAT WE STILL
PROPOSED TO SUNSET THE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM AFTER THREE YEARS AND
MAINTAIN THE PANEL THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY.
ON GOING WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
PENALTY ITSELF HAS AFFECTS ON
COVERAGE AND HELPS TO MAINTAIN
AFFORDABILITY IN THE MARKET
BROADLY.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- X. ANY
COMMENTS FROM COVER CALIFORNIA.
A MYTH OKAY HELLO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
PROVIDE JUST A FEW COMMENTS ON
THIS FIRST -- WE'RE STILL --
REVIEWING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
AN INDIVIDUAL MANDATE COUNTY
REVENUE ESTIMATES -- HOPING TO
RECEIVE -- SOME DETAILED.
BACK UP ON WHAT THE ASSUMPTIONS
WERE THAT WENT INTO THAT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY -- CONCERNS THEY
APPEAR GENERALLY REASONABLE AT
THIS TIME -- BUT WOULD KNOW THAT
THEY ARE SUBJECT TO UNCERTAINTY --
ALSO WOULD NOTE THAT -- AS WE
HAVE MENTIONED ON OTHER
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT INVOLVES SUNSETS.
AND THIS DOES RAISE SOME
CONCERNS -- IN PARTICULAR AND
SUN SETTING THESE SUBSIDIES
WHILE THE PENALTY REVENUES
CONTINUE COULD.
UNDERSTATE THE TRUE ONGOING
COSTS -- OF THE PROGRAM AM GIVEN
PRESSURES THAT THIS WOULD CREATE --
TO CONTINUE THEM.
AND LASTLY WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
AT THIS POINT TO PROVIDE ITS
INPUT ON THE ALLOCATION OF THE
THE COUNTY REVENUES SHOULD
CHOOSE TO LIMIT THEM -- TO THE
COUNTY REVENUES BETWEEN THE
ABOVE 4100% BELOW 4% OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL -- THRESHOLD SO
PLEASURE COULD FOR EXAMPLE
CHOOSE TO ALLOCATE RELATIVELY
GREATER SHARE TO THOSE BELOW
4100% OF OF PL.
AND SHOULD IT SHOULD HAVE A
PRIORITY.
THANK YOU -- SO JUST TO THE HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL ITSELF SO IN JANUARY --
THE IDEA WAS IS THAT YOU TAKE
THE PENALTY MONEY AND THEN IF IT
TURNS OUT YOU SPEND MORE YOU
CALL SOMEBODY FOR THE FUTURE
YEARS SAID -- IN THIS CASE WE'RE
NOW PROPOSING A MORE CONSISTENT
I MEAN I REALIZE THERE'S SOME
PROTECTION THE FUTURE BUT A
THERE'S GONNA BE MORE CERTAINTY
ABOUT FROM YOU AT LEAST WELL
FROM YEAR TO YEAR QUALITIES
UNTIL SUNSET.
OF THE LEVEL SUBSIDY CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT THE INTERNET THE
PROBLEM PROVIDE THAT TEN DOLLAR
AVERAGE MONTHLY SUBSIDY AND THAT
HUNDRED DOLLARS AVERAGE MONTHLY
SUBSIDY THROUGHOUT THE THREE
COVERAGE PERIODS OF THREE YEARS.
SO I I DO APPRECIATE ACT I THINK
IT'S JUST TO TO HAVE IT SWING
YOU KNOW AT THE NEEDS GREAT ONE
THE GOOD YEARS BUT IF THE TAP AT
SWING THAT BLACK PREDICTABLY I
THINK WILL.
BE PROBLEMATIC FOR TRYING TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO BUY INSURANCE
IF THEY DON'T KNOW.
HEALTH ONE YEAR IT'S NOT SO GOOD
AND AND THEN THEY DROP OUT IT'S
HARD TO ITEM -- YEAH NEXT YEAR
GOT BETTER SO PLEASE COME BACK
ON AND AND SO FORTH -- IS THERE
AGAIN OBVIOUSLY WE'RE MODELING
SORE GUESSING INTO THE FUTURE --
IF IF FOR FALLING A LITTLE SHORT.
LET'S SAY OUR TO SEE MORE PEOPLE
NEEDED SUBSIDIES GIVEN THAT THAT
LEVEL THEN -- THE PENALTY CAME
IN -- AGAIN I'D RELIGIOUS MORE
ABOUT TENSIONS ANYTHING ELSE IS --
THE POLICY WISE THE GOAL STILL
WOULD BE TO TRY TO MAINTAIN THE
SAME LEVEL WILL FIVE C. F. F.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT TO BE.
THROWN A LITTLE EXTRA MONEY TO
CLOSE THAT GAP OR WHATEVER
CORRECT I BELIEVE THE INTENT IS
TO MAINTAIN THAT AVERAGE TEN
AREN'T AVERAGE ONE HUNDRED MONTH.
DOLLAR MONTHLY SUBSIDY HOWEVER
THERE IS ALSO THE INTENT TO
MAINTAIN A BUDGET NEUTRAL
PROGRAM OVER THE THREE OR FOUR
EIGHT US PURITAN SO DEPENDING ON
THE VARIATIONS WITHIN THE
ESTIMATES OF THE REVENUE AMOUNT
AND THE EXPANDERS ABOUT THAT MAY.
REQUIRE ADJUSTMENTS IN YOUR TO
WHEN YOU'RE THREE AGAIN AS NOTED
WE ARE TRYING TO MINIMIZE THE
ADJUSTMENT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
BUT AGAIN WE HAVE.
THE THE INTENT IS TO MAINTAIN A
BUDGET NEUTRAL PROGRAM
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I I PRAY SHOULD
JUST MENTION THAT -- THAT.
I THINK -- I APPRECIATE THE THE
PROPOSAL'S BETTER DOLLARS BEFORE
OR ICE STILL THINK THAT WE
SHOULD IT'S NOT -- SUFFICIENT --
THE LEVEL SUBSIDY WE SHOULD
CONSIDER MORE BUT I APPRECIATE
SO I CLARIFY WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS.
AND THEN -- THEN OF AYE FROM I
UNDERSTAND BASED ON THIS
PROPOSAL -- WHEN YOU GO FROM
410025100% OF POVERTY AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT -- Là THE
MONEY'S GOING TO THE PEOPLE OF
FOUR HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED BUT
SAME TIME THAT'S BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE FEDERAL SUBSIDY I OF
THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS SO YOU
HAVE.
STATES MAKING UP THE ENTIRE GAP.
THEN -- BEFORE THE FIVE HUNDRED
BASICALLY AT 17%.
RIGHT SO BASICALLY CAM AT 70%
INCOME AND THAT.
AND THEN UP TO TWENTY TWO AND A
HALF.
AT 5100%.
THE PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW IS A FOUR
HUNDRED CAP AT NINE POINT 78% OF
INCOME LIKE A FOUR HUNDRED THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CAP AT 17%
OKAY NOT FIVE HUNDRED CAP AT
TWENTY TWO POINT 5%.
AND A SIX HUNDRED CAP AT 25% QUE
ALL RIGHT SO SO WHAT DOES
RECOGNIZE THAT -- WE'RE STILL
TALKING ABOUT SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF SOMEONE'S INCOME I
APPRECIATE THE SUBSIDY HELPS --
IT'S A LOT ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE.
IN YOUR FIFTIES JUROR -- AT NO
410050% OF POVERTY.
THE RATE SINCE THERE'S NO LIMIT
RIGHT NOW JUMPS WAY OUT I MEAN
THIS IS CERTAINLY BETTER MUCH
BETTER BUT THEN JUST RECOGNIZE
THAT WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
TWO AND A HALF PERCENT OF
SOMEONE'S INCOME SO IT'S NOT A
SMALL AMOUNT. FOR IN TERMS OF
FOR A DESPITE THE SUBSIDY OKAY
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY OKAY AND THEN -- ALL RIGHT
SO WELL ZERO PUBLIC COMMENT.
A NEW THERE SOME PEOPLE COME UP
ON THIS.
I'LL BE DISAPPOINTED IF I DIDN'T
SEE ANYONE COME UP ON THIS ONE
OKAY WELCOME.
WE WOULD AS WELL MISTER CHAIR
BETH CAPELL ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS -- LIKE YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS.
IN SOME RESPECTS IMPROVED OVER
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL BUT IN
OTHERS -- NOT HAS NOT BEEN THE
JANUARY WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
MONEY THEY HAVE MADE EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
RELATIVELY LEVEL AND THE HELP
THAT CONSUMERS GET IS RELATIVELY
LOW.
LEVEL AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THAT INCLUDES BOTH THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE IS SURE
LEGISLATION DOES AS WELL AS
HOWEVER THIS PROPOSAL IS FOR ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS
RATHER THAN ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AS THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL WAS THE JANUARY OR
PROPOSAL WAS SERIOUSLY UNDER
FUNDED.
THIS IS EVEN MORE SERIOUSLY
UNDER FUNDED THEY THE IDEA THAT
ANYONE SHOULD BE EXPECTED TO
SPEND 25% OF THEIR INCOME ON
PREMIUMS IS SIMPLY ASTONISHING.
IT WAS HARD ENOUGH FOR HEALTH
ACCESS TO SAY THAT WE SUPPORTED
A PROPOSAL.
AS THE JANUARY BUDGET WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT LIMITED PREMIUMS
210215% OF INCOME THE IDEA THAT
WERE KNOWS HOUSE TO SUPPORT
SOMETHING WITH TWENTY AT 25% IS --
ASTONISHING WERE ALSO VERY
TROUBLED THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES
NOT PROVIDE HELP BELOW 2100% OF
POVERTY WE HAVE PEOPLE LIVING ON
TWELVE HUNDRED OR IS FOURTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH ASKED TO
PAY TWENTY FIVE OR THIRTY
DOLLARS FOR PREMIUMS.
IF THEY WERE ON MEDI CAL THEY
WOULD PAY NOTHING WE SHOULD HAVE
BE ABLE TO HELP THE PEOPLE BELOW.
TWO HUNDRED AS WELL AS THE
PEOPLE ABOVE.
WE ALSO REMAIN TROUBLED THAT
THERE'S A SUNSET FOR THE
AFFORDABILITY HELP BUT NOT FOR
THE MANDATE.
WE ALSO ARE PERPLEXED AT THE
INSISTENCE ON RECONCILIATION FOR
THOSE WHO TAX RECONCILIATION FOR
THOSE ARE GETTING TEN DOLLARS A
MONTH OF HELP.
AND LIKE YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
AGREE THAT INCLUDING HEALTH CARE
SHARING MINISTRY IS IS NOT
APPROPRIATE AND WE HOPE WE CAN
GET THAT RESOLVED IN THE COMPANY
IN THE TRAILER BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE DO APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABILITY BUT DE DO BELIEVE
THE AFFORDABILITY IS.
ASSISTANCE IS INSUFFICIENT
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS THOSE MAKING LESS
THAN 2100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
UP ANY REINSTATEMENT OF THE
PENALTY SHOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS THESE LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
AS SOME OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE PAYING THE PENALTY BUT
RECEIVE NO STATE SUBSIDIES.
IN ADDITION THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE MORE PRICE SENSITIVE AND
MORE LIKELY TO ROLL AND ROLE AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA WITH
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE.
I WE SHARE THE CONCERNS RELATED
TO THE SUBSIDIES SUN SETTING IN
THREE YEARS BUT THE PENALTY
CONTINUING IN PERPETUITY.
AS WELL AS SHARE CONCERNS
REGARDING THAT HEALTH CARE
SHARING MINISTRIES.
IN ADDITION WE ALSO -- WOULD
WANT TO SEE THAT -- THERE BE --
THE THEY'RE NOT BE
RECONCILIATION FOR RENDERING
VISUALS MAKING ARE RECEIVING AND
TEN DOLLARS A MONTH THOSE -- BY
TWO HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED AND
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO PAY
THE PENALTY IN AREA BE PROVIDED
AN APPROPRIATE REFINED.
AND FINALLY IN TERMS OF THE
INSURANCE AFFORDABILITY PROGRAM
WHICH WE DO BELIEVE THE
DEFINITION SHOULD INCLUDE
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING SUBSIDIES
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO WRONG
DOOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AUTUMN
OGDEN SMITH WITH THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY CANCER ACTION
NETWORK AND WE WE WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE CONCERNS OF YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND HEALTHAXIS IN WESTERN
CENTER -- YOU KNOW FROM THE
CANCER PERSPECTIVE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE BRING DOWN
COSTS AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
PATIENTS NEED ACCESS TO
MEDICATIONS THEY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO FOR THEIR MEDICATIONS AND
THEIR TREATMENT AND WITH. 25% OF
THEIR INCOME GOING TO THE TO THE
COST OF HEALTHCARE IT'S IT MAKES
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO AFFORD
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT TO GET THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED.
SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS FURTHER AND THE LEGISLATURE
STORY LIBERAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
NICK LOUISE US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS A WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF A STATE BASED INDIVIDUAL
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY
REQUIREMENT -- IN USING THAT
PROGRAM TO FIND ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDIES FOR ADDITIONAL
POPULATIONS -- THIS WITH THIS
WILL GO A LONG WAY AND HELP --
PROVIDING CERTAINTY IN THE
MARKET WHICH IN TURN STABILIZES
PREMIUMS -- AND AND MAKES HEALTH
CARE MORE AFFORDABLE FROM OUR
POPULATIONS UNIT WERE WELCOME TO
BE A CONSTRUCTIVE PART OF ANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT -- HOW THE
SHEEP SABAH WERE WERE WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF OF GETTING
THIS ENACTED AT THE STATE LEVEL
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
AND WE ARE GENERALLY IN SUPPORT
OF PREMIUM ASSISTANCE BUT WE DO
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS THAT YOU
OUTLINED EARLIER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO -- SO FIRST OF ALL AGAIN
WHAT THANK THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP -- ON AND THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE I REALIZE
IT'S FIGHT BOUT THE MOST
POPULAR PIECE BUT IT.
IS THE COMPANION TO THE SUBSIDY
TO ME THEY COME TOGETHER RIGHT
AND THE PROBLEM IS IF WE DON'T
GET MORE PEOPLE TO THE PULL THAT
ACTUALLY TRIED TO PREMIUMS.
PREMIUMS DRIVE UP THAT MEANS
EVEN MORE MONEY WE HAVE TO FIND
FOR SUBSIDIES RIGHT SO I MEAN
THEY GO TOGETHER -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP ON THAT -- I A THE
WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE THE ESSENTIALLY THE
EXPIRATION DATE -- AND SO AND
UNTROUBLED THE EFFORT OUT
POSITION I'M.
TROUBLED BY THAT AS WELL -- IN
ME WILL BE COLLECTING --
BERKELEY COLLECTING A PENALTY --
BASED ON THE PEOPLE NOT
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE THAT SHOULD
BE DEVOTED TO HIS PROPOSED -- AT
LEAST -- YELL TO HELPING PEOPLE
GET INSURANCE -- AND THEN
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PERSUADE THOSE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY THE GREATEST
SUCCESS WOULD BE IS THAT WOULD
NO ONE ACTUALLY GETS PENALIZED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ALL GONE INTO
THE INSURANCE POOL.
SO -- THAT DOES THAT WOULD BE
THE IDEAL BUT BUT CERTAINLY IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WE'RE
COLLECTING PENALTIES FROM I
DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD JUST.
GO INTO THE GENERAL FUND AFTER
CERTAIN DATES FOR JUST GET NOW
WITH THAT.
WASHED OUT -- I THINK THE OTHER
PART AND WE LOOK AT THIS OF THE
RECORD YOU KNOW CERTAINLY FOR
THE 13322100% -- WELL CERTAINLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
PROVIDE SOME ASSISTANCE --
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT TO LOOK AT
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT AND THEN
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE EXAMPLE
THE TOP AND SO -- SO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A FORTY FIFTY
YEARS 17% OF YOUR INCOME UP 225%
THE CENTER AND THAT'S JUST FOR
PREMIUMS.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE.
COST SHARE THAT THIRTY SO YOU
PURCHASE THE INSURANCE.
THAT'S THE PREVIOUS SO I
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE DOING SOME
SORT OF THESE ADS -- BUT LET US
RECOGNIZE THAT A JURY SPENDING
25% ON THE PREMIUMS AND THEN YOU
HAVE CANCER OR SOME OTHER
CONDITION YOU'RE ALSO.
THINK ABOUT YOUR SILVER PLAN IS.
RIGHT.
YOU PAINT 20% YEAH YOU GET YOU
GET COST YEAR PART ON TOP OF
THAT RIGHT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
SUBSIDY FOR COST YEAR CORRECT IN
THIS RIGHT SO THIS IS PURELY
PREMIUMS.
CLEARLY PREMIUMS ARE IMPORTANT
BUT THIS.
I THINK BUT IF YOU ACTUALLY NEED
TO USE YOUR HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE
AGAIN PEOPLE COVERAGE AND THEN
ON TOP OF THAT YOU GOT YOUR COST
YOUR PARTS OFYOUR EIGHTY
TALKING ABOUT 25% FOR THE
PREMIUM.
NAY THROUGH THE CROSS YEAR ON
TOP OF THAT I I THINK WE HAVE A
CHALLENGE TELLING PEOPLE IT'S
AFFORDABLE.
SO I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP AND SAYING THAT BY
THINK WE DO NEED TO DO MORE.
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE MARRYING
THIS WITH THE THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE SELL -- SO AGAIN -- AS I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY THINK
MORE ABOUT THE RESOURCES THAT.
WE'RE PUTTING IN OTHERWISE I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE WE'RE
PUTTING PEOPLE INTO A VERY.
CHALLENGING POSITION.
RIGHT AND THAT IN THAT REGARD.
NO CHOICES 25% OF THE INCOME PAY
THE PENALTY -- AND THEN IF
THEY'RE NOT THE PULLED THEM OR
US OR DEFEATING THE PURPOSE OF
THE PENALTY IN THE FIRST PLACE
RIGHT.
SO I SELL AB -- SO CERTAINLY I
HOPE SO I APPRECIATE THE SOME OF
THE IMPROVEMENTS WE EE.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO DO MORE
ON THE SUBSIDY SIDE TO MAKE THE
MANDATE SIDE MORE SUCCESS ONE IF
WE SHOULD GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP
AND I SUPPORT HIM.
IN THAT AS WELL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I SHE COMMENTS ANY OTHER
COMMENTS [inaudible]
OBSERVERS AUTO.
JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONVERTIBLE FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR AND HIS AND
IS PLANNED -- BUT SPECIFICALLY
I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
REGARDING FEES SUBSIDIES FOR
THOSE UNDER.
THE UP OVER THE TWO WAS A 2100%
YEAH THE 2100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND I JUST OF THE
COULD BE IN IT IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S NOT AN ADEQUATE AMOUNT
OF SUBSIDIES THAT WOULD BE QUITE
TO THAT COMMUNITY THERE.
OKAY ANY.
THE COMMENTS.
IT IS THE ONLY COMMENT THAT I
ADDRESSES THE CONSULATE TO
PROPOSAL I THINK WE'VE THE
EXPLORE THE POSSIBILITY OF NOT
HAVING RECONCILIATION INCLUDED
IN THIS LANGUAGE.
HOWEVER WE STRUGGLE WITH HOW WE
COULD IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM
WITHOUT RECONCILIATION FOR THE
ABOVE FOUR HUNDRED POPULATE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FEEL
POPULATION ALL BIFURCATING THE
BELOW FOUR HUNDRED POPULATION
OUT OF THOSE RECONCILIATION --
ACTIVITIES ESPECIALLY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS 310050% F.
FEEL WHEN THEY REPORT THEIR
INCOME TO COVER CALIFORNIA AND
ENDS UP WITH 41005% OF THE BILL
INCOME IF YOU DON'T RECONCILE
THE INDIVIDUALS PAYMENT.
THEY MAY BE GETTING A
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER SUBSIDY THAN
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR OF COURSE
THIS HAS THE OPPOSITE EFFECT IF
YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL ABOVE
FOUR HUNDRED TO ACTUALLY COMES
IN.
BELOW FOUR HUNDRED WE RECONCILE
THAT PAYMENT LIKE THE RESULT AND
OF A PRODUCTION ARE OF A PAYMENT
TO THE STATE TO REPAIR THAT.
THAT'S THE SUBSIDY OUR THAT
PERSON WOULD STILL BE RECEIVING --
FEDERAL SUBSIDY WITHIN THEIR
REFUND AND SO KIND OF OFFSET
EACH OTHER SO I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF THE THE STICKING POINT
THAT WE STRUGGLE WITH IS HOW CAN
YOU.
BY FOR KATE THAT RECONCILIATION
PROCESS [inaudible]
OKAY WELL -- WE WE HAVE SOME
MORE WORK TO DO ON THIS ONE BUT
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP -- THE ON THE BROADER
POLICY BUT HOPEFULLY WE CAN WE
CAN.
SOME OF THESE VERY IMPORTANT
DETAILS AND ALSO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN AGREE ON A BOTTOM ON A
BROADER SUBSIDY APPRECIATE I DO
AGREE THAT WE USE THE PENALTY
SHOULD GO CONTRIBUTE TO THIS OF
THE BY THINK WHEN I DO MORE THAN
JUST THE PENALTY SO.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
BUDGETARY QUESTION SO WE CAN
DEAL WITH OKAY ANYTHING ELSE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS LA ONLY.
COVERED CALIFORNIA NO OKAY THANK
YOU FOR AGAIN WHAT THEY COVER
CALIFORNIA FOR THE ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON AND OFF AS A
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
ASK.
NEW TEAM AT THE TABLE SAW ASK
EVERYONE TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
FIRST AND THEN WE'LL GOING TO
MOVE ON THAT WILL MOVE TO IS --
ISSUE ONE WHICH IS INVESTMENT
WORKFORCE EDUCATION TRAINING
FIVE YEAR PLANS CELL DESK
[inaudible]
INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
THE CITY OUR WITH AUSTIN.
ELIO AND JOHNSON ALEJO FINANCE.
LIVING CHEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
CHECK A BLAND FINANCE OKAY THANK
YOU.
PLEASE PRESENT.
A GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS STAFF -- IN THE MAYOR
VISION OFFERED IS REQUESTING
MULTI YEAR APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY OF ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND.
ASSERTING FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY TO SUPPORT THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
ALSO KNOWN AS WET FIVE YEAR PLAN
I SHOULD ALSO REQUEST
PROVISIONAL AUTHORITY TO
TRANSFER EXPENDITURE THIRTY TO
STATE OPERATIONS. TO ADMINISTER
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WHAT FIVE YEAR PLAN.
THE WET FIVE YEAR PLAN AIMS TO
ADDRESS WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
WITHIN THE MENTAL HEALTH WITHIN
THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
THROUGH PIPELINE RECRUITMENT
ACTIVITIES.
SCHOLARSHIPS AND STIPENDS AND
LOAN REPAYMENTS TO SUPPORT THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY THE WEB PLAN
SUPPORTS THE SYSTEMS LEVEL
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM THROUGH
TRAINING OF PERSONNEL.
WITHIN THE SYSTEM TRAIN
RECRUITMENT YOUR PERSONNEL.
SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TRAINING --
RESIDENCIES AND PROVIDING
TRAINING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS TO PROVIDE PRIMARY
CARE PSYCHIATRY.
THOSE CONDUCTING RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION ON THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM WORKFORCE AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE WEB PLAN --
THE COMMITTEES **** DESCRIBE THE
TYPES OF MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
THAT WOULD RECEIVE SUPPORT UNDER
THE NEW FIVE YEAR WET PLAN AND
WHAT TYPE TO SUPPORT THESE
PROVIDERS WOULD RECEIVE.
BUT PLAN IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
THE ENTIRE CONTINUUM OF MENTAL
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS AND WORK
FORCE WITHIN THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTHSYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY THE PLAN SUPPORTS
PEER PERSONNEL PRE CLINICAL
SUPPORT STAFF -- BACHELORS IN
SOCIAL WORK MASTERS IN SOCIAL
WORK MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST MASTER'S AND PHD IN
PSYCHOLOGY PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
NURSE PRACTITIONERS MEDICAL
DOCTORS AS WELL PSYCHIATRISTS.
THE OBJECTIVES OF THE WEB PLANS
THE TO SUPPORT THIS WORK FORCE
ACROSS THE CONTINUUM OF THEIR
CAREER -- AT AND AS WELL AS
RATHER CREE DEVELOPMENT -- THESE
EFFORTS INCLUDE -- PLAN
ACTIVITIES TO RECRUIT --
STARTING IN COLLEGE AS WELL AS
HIGH SCHOOL INTO THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND PROMOTE
CREE AWARENESS -- TO COLLEGE AND
GRADUATE TRAINING THROUGH
SCHOLARSHIPS AND STIPENDS AND
ULTIMATELY RETENTION THROUGH
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS.
CONDITIONALLY THIS INVENTION
EARLIER WE IT IT INCLUDES
COMPONENTS TO SUPPORT YOUR
PERSONNEL THROUGH RECRUITMENT.
AND TRAINING ACTIVITIES THE
PSYCHIATRY EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF RESIDENCIES FOR PSYCHIATRISTS
WHO'D BE SUPPORTING RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS.
AND LASTLY TO SUPPORT PRIMARY
CARE PSYCHIATRY TRAINING AND FOR
EMERGENCY AND PRIMARY CARE
PRACTITIONERS -- THE STAFF ALSO
ASKED US TO ADDRESS HOW THE WET
FUNDING INTERACTS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE.
PROPOSE IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
AND OTHER PROGRAMS OR ACTIVITIES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM BOTH
PROPOSALS.
SO THE KEY DIFFERENTIATING
FACTOR HERE IS THAT THE WAY PLAN
IS THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM -- WHERE AS THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE MORE BROADLY SO THERE
ARE PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM THAT THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WOULD?
BE MORE TARGETED TOWARDS PEOPLE
WORKING OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR WHAT FUNDED
PROGRAMS.
AS THE KEYS FOR DIFFERENTIATING
FACTOR [inaudible]
HELLO.
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA L. -- MY
DAD ONE OTHER SORT OF IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION THAT WE THINK IS
THERE -- THAT -- THEY'RE MORE
SORT OF PIPELINE ACTIVITIES
UNDER THE WEB PROPOSAL AS
OPPOSED TO UNDER THE ADDITIONAL
FIFTY MILLION SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'D BE FOR EXAMPLE --
FUNDING FOR PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCIES AND SO FORTH THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED UNDER THE THE
HUNDRED DOLLAR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR WHAT PROPOSAL BUT NOT
UNDER THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS --
SO WE FOLLOWING THE RELEASE THE
MAY RELIGION -- REVISION --
RELEASED TO AN EMAIL ANALYSIS OF
OF THE GOVERNOR NEWS PURPOSE AS
GOVERNOR'S NEW PROPOSAL AND WE
INTEND TO RELEASE A A POLICY
POST IN THE COMING DAYS AS WELL --
THAT EXPANDS UPON THOSE COMMENTS
AND IN OUR SYSTEM -- WE DO FIND
THAT THERE IS MIXED EVIDENCE OF
A STATEWIDE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE -- SOME
INDICATIONS AND PROJECTIONS TO
SHOW SHORTAGE BUT OTHER DATA
SUCH AS SALARY INCREASES IN
RECENT YEARS AS WELL AS THE
NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
GRADUATES PARTICULARLY FROM --
NON PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND SO
FORTH HAS INCREASED PRETTY
MARKEDLY AND SO WE WE THINK WE
FIND THE EVIDENCE OVERALL MIXED
ON A STATE WIDE SHORTAGE.
WE DO FIND HOWEVER REGIONAL
DISPARITIES -- AMONG MENTAL
HEALTH PRESS -- PROVIDERS SO
ESPECIALLY IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
AND AS WELL AS THE INLAND EMPIRE
THOSE ARE -- DO APPEAR TO BE
EXPERIENCING MORE ACUTE
SHORTAGES I SHOULD KNOW THAT ON
A STATEWIDE BASIS WE DO FIND
MORE EVIDENCE OF A OF A
PSYCHIATRIC SHORTAGE -- WE ALSO
FIND THAT THERE IS UNCERTAINTY
AS TO THE EXTENT THAT EXISTING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL --
ONE PIECE OF DATA THAT WE LOOKED
AT WAS WHERE IN WHERE RECIPIENTS
OF WET AWARDS WORK AFTER THEIR
AFTER -- THEIR SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS COMPLETE AND FOUND
THAT THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY A
VERY STRONG RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE THAT WHERE THEY WORK
AND WITH THE REGION'S THE STATE
A QUICK SPINS THE MOST ACUTE
SHORTAGES. FOR WE DO PROVIDE
SOME OPTIONS AS WELL FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION FIRST
WOULD BE TO TAKE PAUSE AND
IDENTIFY THE STATE'S NEEDS IN
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES -- FOR FOR ADDRESSING
ANY STATEWIDE A REGIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE SHORTAGES.
ANOTHER WOULD BE -- TO SCALE
BACK FUNDING -- AND POTENTIALLY
HERE REQUIRE LOCAL CONTRIBUTION
HISTORICALLY -- MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO LOCALS -- FUNDED --
THE PREVIOUS WET PLANS --
WHEREAS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL IT
WOULD INVOLVE ONLY STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE UNDER THE MHSAA SO WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER EITHER ALLOWING OR
REQUIRING LOCAL CONTRIBUTIONS.
CURRENTLY UNDER THE IMAGE SAY
THEY'RE ALLOWED -- TO DEDICATE
UP 215% MAXIMUM -- TO MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND SO THEY DO
RECEIVE FUNDING ON AN ONGOING
BASIS TO DO SO -- AND THEN
ANOTHER OPTION WOULD JUST BE TO
ESTABLISH A MORE DETAILED
PARAMETERS ON HOW THE
ALLOCATIONS ARE MADE SO IT'S
TARGETED TO THE HIGHEST NEED
AREAS TOWARDS THE HIGHER -- MOST
HIGH NEED PROFESSIONS AND WE
ALSO GIVE SOME OTHER EXAMPLES SO
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
CLEAN CHANNEL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- I WILL CONFINE OUR
RESPONSE TO THE ALLO COMMENTS.
REGARDING THE OPTIONS -- TO THE
TO THE OPTIONS FOR DEALING A
FUNDING AND REQUIRING A LOCAL
CONTRIBUTION FROM -- AND DIVERT
OUR COLLEAGUE THAT ARE SPREAD --
FOR THE WORK FOR SHORTAGE AND
PROGRAM -- PROGRAMMATIC COMMENTS.
US AND SEE WHAT PLAN FUNDING
PROPOSAL ON FOOD STAMPS COSTS
AND DOING FUNDING WOULD MEAN A
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES -- FOR THE WEB PLAN
WOULD BE AN FUNDED AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY THIS MAY PREVENT
OFSHE BUT FROM.
OF WORKING WITH AN HSA REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS ANOTHER KEY STAKE
HOLDERS ON THE PLAN FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEXT FIVE
YEAR PLAN.
AND WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT A RE
DIRECTING COUNTY -- AND THAT'S
JUST A FEW DOLLARS A TO THE WEB
PROGRAM WOULD REQUIRE CHANGING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE.
AND AT THIS TIME WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
A TO CHANGE THE COUNTY
ALLEGATIONS -- WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT ON THE STATUE THAT DIRECTED
THE COUNTY DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST
TEN YEARS OF WHAT -- HAS SUNSET
AND COUNTIES NOT EXPECTING TO BE
ASKED TO MATCH ANY NEW FUNDING --
AND COUNTIES HAVE LIKELY NOT
BUDGETED FOR THIS CLASS AND
THOSE DOLLARS MIGHT BE ALREADY
EARMARKED FROM -- FOR OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
UP SO ACTION IS SO IN TERMS OF
OF WE'VE HAD WHAT.
FOR WELL THE TEN YEAR HEALTH TOP
TEN YEAR FIVE YEARS RIGHT SO
THIS WILL BE THE THIRD FIVE YEAR
PLAN STRAIGHT TO THE THIRD FIVE
YEAR OKAY SO THAT YEAH SO -- AND
I KNOW WE DID YOUR FAMILY OF
SOME OF SO I THINK YOU KNOW I
THINK -- VALUATIONS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT AND ACTUALLY LOOKING
NOT JUST BECAUSE THERE'S
MULTIPLE COMPONENTS IN HERE.
LIKE SUB CONSERVE SO FOR EXAMPLE --
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS RIGHT.
SORRY MY BACKGROUNDS AND WORK
FORCE I DID WORKFORCE RESEARCH
SO.
CHALLENGES LIKE YOU FEEL
SOMETHING AS YOU WILL SAY WELL
LET'S JUST SHOVE AS MANY PEOPLE
AS WE CAN RIGHT INTO THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE JUST HAVE A SHORTAGE
BUT THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
WHEN PEOPLE LEAVE FOR DO THEY GO
AND PUT A GO NOT SURPRISINGLY.
IS DEPENDENT ON THE LABOR MARKET
FOR THAT SO YOU CAN IF YOU DON'T
IF IT UNDERSERVED AREAS DON'T
HAVE POSITIONS.
AND IT'LL HAVE COMPETITIVE
POSITIONS COMPARED TO OTHER
AREAS THEN PEOPLE DON'T TEND TO
STAY EVEN IF YOU SELL.
ANY YET RIGHT SO I MEAN THINK
ABOUT IT IF YOU WANT TO LOOK FOR
A JOB AND YOU GO OKAY PAGE HERE
AND THIS KIND OF YOUR LIVER HERE.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY MULTIPLE
FACTORS GO IN PLACE SO -- AND SO
I THINK. FOR EXAMPLE -- ONE
LOOKS AT IN TERMS OF PLACEMENT --
WE SHOULD LOOK AT HOW DO LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS FAIR RIGHT SO
FOR EXAMPLE THE NATIONAL HEALTH
SERVICE CORPS.
USED TO PUT THE EMPHASIS ON
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR THE PAID PEOPLE
UP FRONT NAY REALIZE THAT
ACTUALLY TO GET PEOPLE TO STAY
YOU KNOW PEOPLE COME THEY DO
THEIR APPLICATION WAS ACTUALLY
TO GET LOAN REPAYMENT RIGHT.
AND AND ALSO THINKING ABOUT
BEYOND THE PIPELINE HOW THE
PROVIDE THE KIND OF SUPPORTS FOR
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
AND THE MOST UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SO SOLEMN HOPING THAT IS WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS THAT THERE'S A
SERVER.
THIS BROADER COUNTY LOOKING AT
THE KIND OF THAT THE AND ALSO
LOOKING AT THE DATA ABOUT WHAT
WILL WHICH PARTS OF THE
PROGRAMMER.
ARE MORE OR LESS SUCCESSFUL RAID
SO I THINK LA -- JUST MENTION
THE BILL FORTY PEOPLE INTO
PRACTICING WHAT WHAT'S THE
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THAT RT RT
PRACTICING IN THE UNDERSERVED
AREAS ARE NOT.
OF SOME OF THAT MAY REQUIRE SOME
TIME IT'S FINE TUNING OF THE THE
THE STRATEGY RIGHT AND THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS TO
PEOPLE PRACTICING IS THAT JOBS
IS IT ACTUALLY SOMETIMES CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SPOUSES.
I MEAN THAT'S A FACTOR IN
WORKFORCE MOST KNOWN PEOPLE GET
MAIL.
FORM RELATIONSHIPS MAYBE GET
MARRIED THEY USUALLY NEED TO
HAVE A CAREER FOR BOTH PEOPLE.
AND SO HOW DO YOU TREAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT -- IT'S SO
THAT COULD BE A DRIVING FACTOR --
WHAT KIND OF JOB SUPPORT SO WHAT
IS IT HOW GOOD IS THE PUBLIC YOU
KNOW AND FOR SEE HOW GOOD IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE?
FOR HIRING PEOPLE IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS RIGHT SO USE NOW YOU SPENT
THE TIME YOU TRAIN YOUR SOCIAL
WORKER YOU CHANGE PSYCHIATRISTS
WHATEVER.
IS IS THEIR COMPETITOR TO
COMPETITORS ASIANS FOR THEM TO
DO THE KIND OF WORK THAT YOU
WANT THEM TO DO AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS SO.
SO IT'S GREAT THAT WE'RE
TRAINING MORE PEOPLE -- THEN --
NOW SOMETIMES YOU'LL SAY WELL
LOOK THERE'S A SHORTAGE IN THIS
AREA -- AND THAT'S TRUE AND THEN
THE QUESTIONS HOW YOU CAN HOW DO
YOU RECRUIT AND KEEP PEOPLE
THERE RIGHT -- SO IS SO I'M
HOPING THAT.
NO BRIGITTE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE BUT THAT.
THERE'S AN ONGOING EVALUATION
WE'VE HAD TEN YEARS FOR SAID
SHOW US.
WE'RE DOING WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
DO ANOTHER.
SET HERE BY DOING BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY IN THE END RIGHT.
WE WANT TO BE SURE OF THE WE GET
THOSE WE GET COMMUNITIES.
SERVED RIGHT AND SO WE WILL I AM
I THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE YOU KNOW
HOW WE FINE TUNED OUR STRATEGY
WORKERS TOWARD RESOURCES BEST
DIRECTED TO GET THE KIND OF
RESULTS WE WANT TO GET AND SO.
THAT'S NOT JUST A VALUABLE
PROGRAM BUT ALSO THE SUB PARTS
OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
THINGS HERE RADIO LOANS OPTIONS
IF STATE AND AS YOU HAVE.
IT SET RAIL TRAINING PROGRAMS
ETCETERA SO -- SOME HOPING THAT
WE CAN WE SHOULD BE ABLE
CORPORATE THAT IS PART OF THE
THE PROPOSAL TO BE SURE WE HAVE
THE KIND INFORMATION AS WELL AS
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION WE HAD
BEFORE.
SO CURRENT.
YES SO WE ARE WORKING ON MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
EVALUATION SYSTEM BUILT INTO
THIS AS WELL AS I JUST SAID IT
WITH THE LAST FIVE YEAR PLAN --
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE INDICATES
THAT ACTUALLY 91% OF THE LOAN
REPAYMENT RECIPIENTS REMAIN IN
THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
I MEAN I I THINK THAT THAT
ACTUALLY DOES SPEAK TO THAT
THESE ARE AFFECTED PROGRAMS --
IN THE SHORT RUN I THINK.
WAS THAT A LOT OF PAIN EIGHT
EXACTLY AND TODAY THAT WE ARE
OPEN TO HAVING DISCUSSIONS AND
PART OF THE THE WAY THAT IS WHAT
PLAN IS FRAME IS THAT REALLY
IT'LL BE TAILORED TO THE
REGIONAL NEEDS -- AS OPPOSED TO
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE SO THERE'S THE FIVE
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS IN THE
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS WILL BE --
REALLY PUT IN -- THAT WE WOULD
THEY WILL TAILOR THE THE FUNDING
AND WHICH PROGRAMS GET
EMPHASIZED -- TO MEET THEIR
LOCAL NEEDS BASED OFF OF WHAT
THEIR PARTICULAR WORKFORCE
ISSUES ARE.
AND TO THE RECENT ELECTABILITY
BUILT INTO THIS THAT -- AND IS
OPEN.
TO CONTINUOUSLY RE EVALUATING
ANNUALLY SO WE OBVIOUSLY WANT ME
TO THINK OF OUR PUBLIC POLICY
GOALS ARE HOW THAT MEETS
DEPENDING ON THE READ REGION'S
AND AND WHICH WERE PUTTING THE
MONEY INTO SO WHICH PARTICULAR
STRATEGIES ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYLER IN THE WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE SUPPORT THIS
INVESTMENT IN STATEWIDE ON
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES IN THE
NEW -- BUT FIVE YEAR PLAN ON
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS --
AGREE THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL
MOMENT TO STRENGTHEN OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORK FORCE
COUNTIES ARE BOTH PROVIDERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE ABILITY TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN QUALIFIED
WORKERS IS ESSENTIAL TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
COUNTIES ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO BUILD HIGH QUALITY PROVIDER
NETWORKS TO MEET THE NEW WE
IMPLEMENTED NETWORK ADEQUACY
STANDARDS UNDER THE MEDICAID
MANAGED CARE FINAL RULE.
AND WE WELCOME TOOLS LIKE THIS
STATEWIDE -- WET PLAN THAT CAN
HELP US ACHIEVE THAT GOAL WE
WOULD AGREE WITH THE LA -- IN
THE CHAIRED TO TARGET -- WET
ACTIVITIES TO THE AREA OF
GREATEST NEED WE BELIEVE THAT
THE USE OF WET -- REGIONAL
COLLABORATED COOPERATIVES
PROVIDED BY PROPOSED BY OFSHE
BED CAN BE ONE EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY FOR DOING THIS WE ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO YOU -- RIGOROUS
EVALUATION OF THESE FUTURE WET
ACTIVITIES TO HELP ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF WHAT PROGRAMS AND
CONTINUOUSLY REFINE OUR WORK FOR
STRATEGIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M FAIR IMITATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE ARE
SO BROADLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL -- I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM CBS SHE A AND ALSO
SAY THAT -- WITH THE NETWORK
ADEQUACY GOALS WE ARE FINDING
THAT THERE ISN'T ENOUGH WORKS
FORCE -- WE HAVE COMPETING
INSTITUTIONS AND SYSTEMS WHO ARE
TRYING DAHLE HIGHER THE SAME
PEOPLE AND SO WHATEVER I CAN DO --
TO ASSIST IN THIS WE THINK IT'S
A WELL CRAFTED PLAN BUT AGREE
THAT THERE COULD BE MORE
TARGETING AND AS WELL AS
EVALUATION IN THE LONG RUN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
WELCOME.
SO MY AND HER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THIS
ALLOCATION FOR THE WET.
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- I JUST
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
INLAND EMPIRE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HAVE THE LOWEST PROVIDER
TO POPULATION RATIOS IN THE
STATE FOR ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
CATEGORY OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDER -- WE WOULD REALLY URGE
YOU TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
FUNDING THIS YEAR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN ON THE COMMENTS WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION OKAY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
FARM HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THANK WITH SEVERAL UPDATES HERE.
SOON BRINGING PEOPLE UP SO.
FIRST OF EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD AND
THEN -- WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE MEDIC
HOW LOCAL ASSISTANT ESTIMATES SO.
OR GO AND START WITH PRIMERICA
SERVICES -- MERRY COUNTY DEPUTY
FROM ABOUT HER SERVICE AVAIL AND
JOHNSON LEO.
PRIME WILL THE LA A SCIENCE.
WELCOME AND A GUEST FINANCE.
GLORIA FINANCE OKAY THANK YOU
WELCOME SALAS MEDICAL LOCAL
ASSISTANT ESTIMATE MAY REVISION
UPDATE FOR SO -- FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY THEM A REVISION INCLUDES
A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND SIX
BILLION -- FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES -- A LITTLE
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION OF THAT IS STATE
OPERATIONS.
THE MEDI CAL ESTIMATE IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWO BILLION TWENTY
THREE MILLION OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND -- IT'S A SLIGHT
INCREASE FROM JANUARY OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND.
WE ALSO HAVE -- REQUESTS FOR
EIGHTEEN PERMANENT NEW POSITIONS
IN THE CONVERSION OF THIRTEEN
EXISTING LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
TO PERMANENT.
AND THEN JUST TO MENTION
CASELOAD HAS CONTINUED TO HAVE A
SLIGHT DECREASE SO WE ARE NOW
JUST -- SLIGHTLY OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
LOWER THAN IT WAS IN JANUARY --
ALL THE MAJOR CHANGES WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT LATER
TODAY SO I WON'T LIST THOSE.
THE ONE ADDITIONAL ITEM ALTHOUGH
IT'S NOT PART OF THE BUDGET.
ITSELF AT THIS TIME GIVEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION TIME FRAME WE DID
ALSO RELEASE ARE.
FISCAL ESTIMATE FOR THE CARVE
OUT OF THE PHARMACY SERVICES
BACK TO FEE FOR SERVICE -- IT IS
ESTIMATED AT FULL IMPLEMENTATION
TO BE THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS -- I WILL NOTE THAT WE
DID NOT ASSUME ANY SAVINGS
RELATED TO THREE FORTY B..
IN THIS ESTIMATE JUST SO THAT
IT'S CLEAN AND CLEAR AND I KNOW
THERE HAD BEEN CONCERN
PREVIOUSLY.
THAT MOST THE SAVINGS WOULD BE
COMING FROM THREE FORTY B. SO
ESSENTIALLY AS A PART OF THIS
ESTIMATE -- WE JUST AT THIS
POINT ASSUMES.
THE PAYMENTS WOULD STAY THE SAME
OBVIOUSLY TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
THE FUNDING STILL FLOW THAT WAY
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND ADMINISTRATION WOULD HAVE TO
DEVELOP SOME TYPE OF PLAN TO
HAVE THE MONEY STAY WITH THEM --
IF OTHERWISE OTHERWISE THERE
WOULD BE SAVINGS FROM THREE
FORTY B. AND THEN THE NUMBER
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN -- THREE NINETY THREE YOU
HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE
INCREASE IN THE SAVINGS -- FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS REALLY
RELATED TO FOR ISSUES -- THERE
WE'VE DELAYED REPAYING -- SOME
TITLE -- TWENTY ONE FUNDS THAT
WE A CLAIMS BEFORE AS WERE STILL
WORKING WITH CMS.
ON THEN EXCHANGING THAT FOR
TITLE.
NINETEEN WE DID HAVE INCREASED
DRUG REBATES -- WE HAD FEWER
DEFERRALS FROM CMS AND THEN WE
DID HAVE SOME ADJUSTMENTS IN THE
TIMING OF RETROACTIVE MANAGED
CARE RATE ADJUSTMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY HELLO [inaudible]
IT'S MILLION.
RYAN WAS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IN THE LAST
SEVERAL DAYS WE HAVE BEEN --
CAREFULLY LOOKING THROUGH AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S MAY
REVISION MEDI CAL ESTIMATE.
AND DON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME -- HOWEVER
WE WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE ESTIMATED SPENDING IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS
NOW ABOUT THREE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS LOWER.
THAN AT THIS TIME LAST YEAR --
WHEN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT WAS APPROVED --
AND THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW --
VERY LARGE ANTICIPATED CHANGES
IN THE MEDICAL BUDGET HAVE
BECOME RELATIVELY COMMON -- IN
LARGE PART DUE TO THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE PROGRAM -- AND THIS HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
FORMULATE AND PURSUE LONGER TERM
FISCAL PLANS IN ALIGNMENT WITH
ITS PRIORITIES.
AND ALSO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF
THE PROGRAM -- WOULD LIKE TO
REITERATE SOME OF OUR COMMENTS
FROM EARLIER IN THE YEAR ON A
PROPOSAL THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PUT FORWARD AND CONTINUES TO
PROPOSE.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING --
AND POSITIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO BETTER TRACK -- CASH FLOWS
AND AND ESTIMATES IN THE MEDI
CAL PROGRAM.
AND ALSO TO CREATE A SPECIAL
FUND THAT WOULD SMOOTH THE
IMPACT OF DRUG REBATES.
ON ON THE MEDI CAL BUDGET THE
MAYOR VISION CONTINUES THAT AS
WELL -- AND PROPOSES TO PUT A
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THAT SPECIAL FUND --
WE CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED.
THOSE PROPOSALS AND KNOW THAT
THE COMMITTEE TOOK ACTION TO
APPROVE THE CREATION OF THE
SPECIAL FUND -- BUT WE FURTHER
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO SHARE
KEY INFORMATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD BE GAINED
FROM -- THESE NEW POSITIONS THAT
ARE GONNA BE TRACKING -- MEDI
CAL EXPENDITURES FOR EXAMPLE
PERHAPS ADDITIONAL MADE YOUR
UPDATES ON THE CASH FLOWS OF
CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO UNCERTAINTY.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP A LONGER
TERM PLAN WITH.
MORE STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT
WOULD -- IMPROVE THE ESTIMATES
OF THE MEDI CAL BUDGET IN AN
INCREASE THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO OVERSEE THE PROGRAM.
AND WOULD SUGGEST THAT PROCESS
BE CREATED THAT WOULD -- GATHER
INPUT FROM THE LA -- AND FROM
OTHER LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND TO
GENERATE IDEAS FOR HOW -- THAT
PLAN COULD BE ASSEMBLED -- WITH
WE THINK THIS WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE -- TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE PREDICTABILITY -- IN
THE FUTURE AS AS SOME OF THESE
COMPLEXITIES ARE ARE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
A QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER STONE THANK YOU SO -- THE
AMOUNT OF A DRUG REBATES. FOR
THE ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THAT RIGHT.
I'M SORRY I'M NOT CLEAR WHAT THE
QUESTION ARM ACIDIC REBATES SO
WHAT WHAT'S OUR TOTAL GENERAL
SAVINGS -- I DON'T KNOW THAT OFF
THE TOP MEDICINE TO CLUE IT'S
SOMETHING LOOKS TO BE A LOT
HIGHER THAN THAT.
YEAH. THREE TO FOUR THREE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
OKAY.
ASSIST THIS HUGE SO.
AS A PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON THE
CONSOLIDATION OF OUR X. BUYING
IS THAT.
HAVE YOU BEEN GIVEN ANY DETAILS
ABOUT HOW THAT CAN ENHANCE --
YOUR PROGRAM AND ENHANCE OF
MONEY COMING BACK INTO THE STATE
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OUR ADMINISTRATION
COLLEAGUES ON THE REPORTS THAT
WE HAVE TO DO -- TO THE GOVERNOR
AND SO THAT THOSE ARE STILL
GOING UNDER WAY IN FACT THE
DIRECTOR WAS HAVING A MEETING
TODAY.
HE'S NOT HERE -- SO IT'S
FORTHCOMING BUT WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THOSE OKAY.
WE'RE HOPING THAT THOSE --
EFFORTS ARE GOING TO BE FRUITFUL --
IN THE COMING YEAR AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS FOR
US NEXT YEAR AS WE ENTERED A
THIS BUDGETS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SO -- ACTUALLY BUT FOR DAILY --
SO BUT I APPRECIATE A YEAR THE
THE THE PRESENTATION AND WE
HEARD ALSO EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
HOW DO WE?
DO OVERSIGHT RATE.
THAT A COW.
IS WE SIT HERE AND WE HAVE ITEMS
AS SMALL AS WELL LIKE WITH THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS MILLIONS
EVEN TENS OF MILLIONS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS.
AND WE COME TO YOU MEDI CAL
RIGHT AND WE HAVE A SWING OF
WHAT TWO THREE BILLION RIGHT NOW
THAT'S DOES A PERCENTAGE THAT'S
ABOUT. TO ISSUE PERCENTRATE
GIVEN THE HOUSE THAT DAY IT IS --
AND THAT MAKES IT A LITTLE
CHALLENGING RIGHT BECAUSE I MEAN
WE CAN FIND A LOT OF STUFF FOR
TWO BILLION OF ITS THERE AND
THAT THE TWO BILLION -- WE SPENT
TWO BILLION MORE WE THOUGHT.
THAT A LOT LESS MONEY THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT OF
MAKE UP -- BUT I GUESS -- FOR
WHAT'S THE SWING IN TERMS OF THE
GENERAL FUND.
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THAT THE WHOLE BUDGET BECAUSE WE
HAVE A FEDERAL MATCH AND ENDS
AND EVERY LIGHTS Là MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT BUT IN
TERMS OF OUR BUDGET MANAGEMENT.
HOW MUCH OF A SWING TO HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT GENERAL FUND WISE?
SO THE THREE POINT THREE BILLION
NUMBER THAT I MENTIONED THAT IS
GENERAL FUND OKAY AND IT IS IT'S
ABOUT 14%.
OF OF THE MASS THAT IS A
PARTICULARLY LARGE.
ADJUSTMENT AND IMPRACTICAL TERMS
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT LAST
YEAR AT THIS TIME.
WE WERE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT AN
INCREASE A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
OVER THE PRIOR ESTIMATE AND THAT
THEN HAD TO FACTOR INTO THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION MAKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT.
WHAT FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE TO
ALLOCATE TO VARIOUS PRIORITIES
YEAH AND THEN IN JANUARY AND
THEN UPDATING HERE IN MAY IT'S
NOW SWUNG THE OTHER DIRECTION --
BY A VERY LARGE AMOUNT.
AND I'M SURE THE ISSUE BECOMES
EVEN MORE MAGNIFIED IN YEARS
WHERE WE HAVE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES WERE CASE LET'S GO UP
AND SO FORTH AS WELL IS THAT
TRUE.
THAT THAT PROBABLY WOULD BE A
TRUE BUT A LOT OF THE
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE'RE SEEING
HAVE MORE TO DO WITH -- THE
TIMING OF PAIN KAY.
RIGHT OKAY AND THE WAY WE DO THE
ACCOUNTING FOR THAT RIGHT IS IT
WE DO CASH RATE SO.
SO DEL DEPENDS ON WHAT TIME WE
HAVE TO PAY THE BILL IT'S AT
DOES A FALL BEFORE OR AFTER.
OKAY YES AND THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD IS THAT THAT WHAT
WE'VE DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
SAY LIMITING GENERAL FUND GROWTH
IN THE PROGRAM OVERALL BY ONE
RELYING A LOT OF FEDERAL FUNDS
AND ALSO RELYING ON A LOT OF
THAT NON GENERAL FUND STATE
REVENUES.
THE TOLL THE GENERAL FUND CAN BE
AT RISK FOR THE CHANGES IN THE
TOTAL COST OF THE PROGRAM IN
WHICH WE HAVE TO MAKE UP FOR A
ANY FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S NOT
COMING IN OR THE TIMING OF THESE.
OTHER NON FEDERAL FUNDS AND SO
TO SOME DEGREE THE RISK IS
LARGER THAN JUST THE GENERAL
FUND PROPORTION OF THE BUDGET
THAT YOU SEE.
AND SO I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT
ESPECIALLY THE DRUG REBATE
BECAUSE OF THAT I REMEMBER ONE
YEAR WAS A HOSTILE ONE A HALF
BILLION OR SOMETHING SWINGING
AND DOES A MISCALCULATION THERE
IS ANOTHER FEW BILLION LIKE YOU
KNOW.
LIKE WHICH THROUGH A FEW BILLION
HERE FOR THE THEIR RIGHT --
WHICH IS THE THE SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATIONS IS THE LA --
PLAN THE BABY PUT TOGETHER A
MORE FORMAL REPORT ABOUT THIS
THAT WE CAN USE AS A TEMPLATE
FOR PURSUING AND UPS THE WE WILL
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THIS.
TO TRY TO HOW HOW IN TERMS OF
HOW WE BETTER MANAGE OBVIOUSLY
DOES THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
OVERSEES MEDI CAL HOW CAN BETTER
MONITOR THIS.
AND AND MANAGE THESE.
THESE SWINGS IN RISKS.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CERTAINLY
COULD CONSIDER I THINK WE'RE
VERY INTERESTED IN -- WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO OURS
FIVE WAYS THAT -- WE COULD GET
THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED AND
ALSO WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE THE
STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO THE WAY
THAT WE MAKE OUR PAYMENTS THAT
COULD.
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CERTAINTY -- FROM YEAR TO YEAR --
WE POTENTIALLY COULD PUT THOSE
THINGS IN HER APARTMENT I THINK.
WANTED JUST WORK INFORMALLY AND
WITH WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THESE ISSUES.
A CLEAR TO ME AT THAT IS THAT WE
ALL HAVE A MUTUAL INTEREST AND
SO WE MAY HAVE DIFFERENT POLICY
GOALS OF A HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
A MUTUAL INTEREST AND FIGURE OUT
HOW WE BETTER MANAGE THE BUDGET
AND THE POTENTIAL RISKS AND
SWINGS THAT WE HAVE.
AND IN THE BUDGET.
YES AND THE THE THE AT THE ONLY
THING I THAT IS AT THIS REALLY
CAME TO HAVE THE HEAD A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHEN THERE IS A LARGE
SWING IN THE OTHER DIRECTION.
AND THE DEPARTMENT IS REALLY
ENGAGED IN PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE ITS OWN PROCESS SEES
SOME OF ITS OWN IT SYSTEMS AND
SO FORTH.
AND SO I THINK AT THIS STAGE
IT'S REALLY TIME -- TO START
BRINGING THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE AS SORT OF OVERSEE
IS OF THE BUDGET INTO THIS
PROCESS TO IT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A GREATER TRANSPARENCY
IN OVERSIGHT BROADLY.
WE DON'T JUST OVERSEE THE BUDGET
WE ACTUALLY WRITE THE BUDGET.
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE SO
I THAT SO I THINK -- YEAH SO WE
WE SHOULD.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH ALL THESE ISSUES HERE
RIGHT NOW BUT I APPRECIATE THOSE
PRESENTATIONS AND WE SHOULD BE.
REALLY LOOKING AT AT SOME
INITIAL STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
AND AND FED DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THOSE BUT IT'S I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO CONTINUE
NOT JUST CONVERSATION BUT THINK
ABOUT ACTIONS WE WANT TO TAKE --
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR -- SO A AND
THAT YOU'D MENTIONED AND AND I
HAVEN'T SEEN BY UNDERSTAND MY
STAFF AS THE FINANCIAL REPORT ON
THE BULK PURCHASING.
SO THE CARVE OUT SO -- SO WHEN.
HE SAID THERE'S NO SAVING
SEVENTY FORTY BE IN THE ACCIDENT
AND AND AND THE ESTIMATES SO
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO THREE FORTY
BE THEN.
RIGHT SO I MEAN THERE'S THERE'S
NO SPECIFIC PROPOSAL ON HOW TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE IT NATURALLY
AS A POLICY -- IF THE CAR ABOUT
HAPPENED AND NOTHING NOTHING
PROACTIVE WAS DONE BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
THERE WOULD THEN BE SAVINGS IN A
THREE FORTY BE BECAUSE THEY
WOULD BE BEING PAID AT COST.
WHICH THEY ARE NOT IN MANAGED
CARE SO WE WE'RE NOT CHANGING
THE FEE FOR SERVICE POLICY BUT
WE DIDN'T WANT SORT OF THE
CONVERSATION TO GET CONFUSED
ABOUT HOW MUCH OF THE SAVINGS
WAS FROM THAT VERSES ACTUAL SORT
OF INCREASES IN REBATES AND
OTHER.
OTHER TYPES OF SAVINGS AND SO --
AS WE SAID BEFORE WE'RE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IT WHAT
ARE THOSE DOLLARS IS ALSO NOT
POSSIBLE FOR US TO ESTIMATED
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THREE FORTY PRICES ARE.
ONLY THE COVERED ENTITIES DO SO.
IT FELT.
FUNNY TO JUST GAS WHAT IT WOULD
BE AND SAID YOU KNOW I KNOW
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR SEASON AT
COLLEAGUES THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING SOME WORK IN ESTIMATING ON
WHAT IT WOULD BE.
AND I THINK AGAIN WE WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT ARE SOME OPTIONS --
IF IN FACT THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION WANT TO CONTINUE
HAVE THAT MONEY FLOW TO THEM
OKAY AND THEN THE THREE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE MILLION YOU
MENTIONED SO WHERE IS THAT
COMING FROM.
SO IT'S ESSENTIALLY ADDITIONAL
REBATES AS WELL AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MAXIMUM
ALLOWABLE ALLOWABLE INGREDIENT
COST -- BOTH IN FEE FOR SERVICE
AND MANAGED CARE -- WE DO I
THINKS SCOTT PROBABLY DOES HAVE
THE WORKSHEET THAT LAYS OUT THE
INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS OF THE OF
THE FISCAL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
YES SIR SOUND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I TOOK IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- YOU KNOW BACK
DURING THE RECESSION WE WE
DELETED A LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT
SERVICES.
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS INCLUDING
AUDIOLOGY SPEECH THERAPY.
AND THE ONE THAT REALLY
RESONATES WITH ME IS -- PODIATRY --
PODIATRISTS OFTEN -- THROUGH
THEIR EXAMINATIONS OF THE
BOTTOMS OF THE FEET CAN.
OFTEN -- DIAGNOSE CIRCULATORY
PROBLEMS THAT EXIST WITHIN
DIABETIC POPULATION.
AND CAN ARE HELPFUL IN IN
SCREENING THESE.
THESE PATIENTS THAT ARE AT RISK
[inaudible]
OF AMPUTATIONS -- IT'S BEEN
SHOWN THAT -- FIVE OUT OF A
THOUSAND DIABETICS.
ARE.
GETTING LIMBS AMPUTATED AND WE
HAVE I HAVE THIS STUDY DONE BY.
THE KAISER -- HEALTH NEWS --
QUOTING A PROFESSOR AT THE KECK
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE THE U. S. C.
IT'S IT'S AN EPIDEMIC WITHIN AN
EPIDEMIC AND IT'S A PROBLEM
THAT'S TOTALLY IGNORED.
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE DOCTORS
PERFORMED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
DIABETIC AMPUTATIONS FROM
200-011-22000.
SEVENTEEN AND PEOPLE THAT WERE
AFRICAN AMERICAN OR LATINO ONE
MORE THAN TWICE AS LIKELY.
THAN NON HISPANIC WHITES TO
UNDERGO AMPUTATION RELATED TO
DIABETES [inaudible]
SO.
THE HOUSE WITH MY COLLEAGUES MY
STEAM FROM NOW DOCTOR PANEL TELL
YOU -- THE COST OF LOOKING AT
SOMEONE'S FEET TEN RESTORING
THIS BENEFIT.
IS PROBABLY MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE
WE WERE JUST LOOKING AT COSTS.
THE AND TO PUT A PATIENT THROUGH
AN AMPUTATION THAT CAN HAVE
CERTAIN RAMIFICATIONS ON THEIR
ABILITY TO TO WORK AND PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES WHICH
PROVIDES ANOTHER -- PROBLEM FOR
A SOCIAL SERVICE NETWORK -- WHY --
HAVE THESE SERVICES NOT BEEN --
RESUME TO IF YOU WILL -- BEING
THAT WE HAVE A TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS IN
THE FOR CUT.
DURING -- VERY CHALLENGING TIMES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN A UP A BUCK
INVESTED MIGHT SAVE FIVE OR TEN
DOLLARS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY --
PREVENT THEM THE MORBIDITY AND
POTENTIAL MORTALITY OF OF
DIABETICS THAT HAVE TO COPE WITH
UNCONTROLLED DIABETES.
GLORIA LET DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I THINK THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD AGREE THAT THERE ARE MANY --
SERVICES INVESTMENTS THAT COULD
FURTHER BE MADE IN THE BUDGET
BUT THERE'RE STILL A LIMITED
NUMBER OF AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
AND THEIR MANY INVESTMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE THIS IS I'M NOT
ONE OF THEM BUT WERE HAPPY.
TO WHERE WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
YOUR PRIORITIES.
OKAY -- WELL.
AND THESE WERE SERVICES THAT
WERE CUT DURING SOME VERY
CHALLENGING ECONOMIC TIMES WHEN
I WAS TAUGHT IN THE LEGISLATURE --
WE HAD MORE CASH FLOWING INTO
THE COUNTY TREASURY THAN WE'VE
EVER WITNESSED IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
AND WE HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
HISPANICS THAT ARE SEEING
AMPUTATIONS OTHERWISE COULD HAVE
BEEN SPARED HAVE THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE -- PARTY AFTER CAKES
EMANATIONS OF THEIR FEET -- DO
WE KNOW -- LA -- SIX OF THE
BUDGET -- IF WE WERE.
TO BEGIN TO FUND THIS AGAIN OR
WITH DEPARTMENT FINANCE IF YOU
HAVE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
YES AND THE ANNUAL ESTIMATE IS
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FIFTY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL FUNDS FOR MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OKAY.
SO FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS -- WE
OFTEN HEARD THE TERM BUDGET DUST
THAT'S REALLY BUDGET DUST.
BUT THAT FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
COULD MULTIPLY EXPONENTIALLY IF
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE AMPUTATIONS.
NOT TO MENTION THE THE THE
TRAUMA THAT ONE WOULD HAVE TO
THE DOOR KNOWING THAT THERE ARE
MORE THEIR LEGS.
OR FEET HAVE TO BE AMPUTATED --
I JUST BRING THIS UP FOR YOUR
RECONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE BUDGET THIS TO
ME AS A AN ISSUE WHERE --
INVESTMENT IN THE DOLLAR CAN
SPEAK COULD SAVE A HECK OF A LOT
MORE IN THE FUTURE SO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE THING ELSE
[inaudible]
YES FINANCE.
WELL OPEN MONDAY BECAUSE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SENATOR
SOME BACK TO YOUR QUESTION ON
DRUG REBATE IMPACT -- IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND SAVINGS OF
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION -- IN
GENERAL FUND.
OKAY -- IS YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT
THIS ITEM.
OKAY CAM THE ROCKS ON BEHALF OF
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS --
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
YOU ALL JUST HAD -- AROUND HOW
THE THREE FORTY BE SAVINGS ARE
IMPACTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL ON THE PHARMACY BENEFIT --
I APPRECIATE MISS CAN'T ALL
COMMENTS WE HAD NOT HEARD
PREVIOUS TO THIS AFTERNOON THAT
THE THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS SAVINGS NUMBER
DID NOT INCLUDE THREE FORTY B.
AND WE'RE VERY OPEN TO
CONTINUING TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HOW TO MOVE FORWARD -- TO
ADDRESS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CONCERNS ABOUT TRYING TO SAVE
MONEY ON PHARMACEUTICAL
PURCHASING BUT ALSO NOT
ADVERSELY IMPACTING SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS -- AND I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION PROBABLY CONCURS
WITH THE REMARKS I JUST MADE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME ARE THE GIRL
RIBS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND THINK OF FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION A MEDICAL COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
ANOTHER COMMON SO WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPENED AND LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE FAMILY HEALTH ESTIMATES MAY
REVISION UPDATE TOUR SO WE'VE
HAD A PRETTY EASY -- IN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND
EXPENDITURES IN CASELOAD -- BOTH
CCS NGH PP HAD A KEY SLOW
DECLINE REALLY DUE TO THE
CLOSURE OF AN ACTIVE CASES WE
DID HAVE A INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURES NGH PP -- AND THAT
WAS REALLY RELATED TO A BACKLOG
OF CASES WHERE THEY'VE NOW BEEN
APPROVED IN CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
PAID.
WE ALSO DO YOU SEE -- AN
INCREASE IN OUR EVERYWOMAN
COUNTS -- EXPENSES AND THAT'S
REALLY BECAUSE OF A SHIFT FROM A
CONVENTIONAL MAMMOGRAPHY TO
DIGITAL MAMMOGRAPHY WHICH IS
MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND AS WELL WE'VE HAD SOME.
CORRECTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING SO.
FAIRLY MINIMAL BUT THOSE THOSE
OF THE MAJOR ITEMS.
ELIO WE HAVE REVIEWED THIS
BUDGET AND DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
A FINANCE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE'RE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FAMILY OF A
SMITH.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT TO A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS.
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL I APPRECIATE THE
UPDATE I THINK AGENTS AGAIN I
AND WE HAD A PRESENTATION ON CCS
AND CERTAINLY G. H. P. P. IS A
PART OF IT.
WE WANT TO BE SURE -- OUR
PATIENTS WHO HAVE RARE
CONDITIONS -- THEY DON'T REALLY
FIT WELL IN THEM AND THE OTHERS
CURRENT MANAGED CARE PAIRED I'M
NOT SAYING THAT YOU CAN'T DO
MANAGED CARE BUT YOU NEED TO
HAVE REGIONAL SYSTEMS OF CARE
CELL.
TRYING TO FIT THEM INTO A
MANAGED CARE PLAN THAT IS NOT.
THAT DOESN'T DEVELOPMENT DID
THEY HAVE TO HAVE OF WIDER
NETWORK THAN WHAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE TO HAVE IN ORDER
TO TAKE CARE OF THESE PATIENTS
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT -- THESE
PROGRAMS -- AND WE CERTAINLY HAD
AN UPDATE ON THE OF THE HOTEL IS
DOWN MILES ON THE HOTEL MODEL IN
CCS SO WHERE -- WE WANNA KEEP.
CLOSE LED A CLOSE CLOSE EYE ON
THAT -- CG PEAS TWENTY TWO
PEOPLE NOW.
OKAY.
RIGHT SO OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN --
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
PROPERTY SIX INVESTMENTS.
SURE SO ALL OF THE TO DO THE THE
PRESENTATION AND ADDRESS THE
FINAL QUESTION AND THEN WILL
DEFER TO MY DEPARTMENT FINANCE
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER.
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS SO THE MAY
REVISION CONTINUESTHE PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAD IN JANUARY WHICH
REALLY IS CONTINUING -- THE
EXISTING DOLLARS -- THAT HAVE
BEEN FLOWING IN THIS YEAR --
INTO THE BUDGET YEAR WE ALSO DO
YOU HAVE FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED AS
A RESULT OF SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT WITH THAT THAT WE
HAVE THAT'S ONE TIME IN NATURE --
AND SO THOSE.
THOSE FUNDING -- TO SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL
MONEY INTO THE VALUE BASED
PAYMNT PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTEGRATION -- I WILL I JUST
ANSWER THE QUESTION YOU HAD
ABOUT THAT NOW -- WE ARE STILL
FINALIZING THE THE METRICS AND
HOW WE WANT TO USE THIS MONEY --
THIS IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT.
ISSUE FOR THE SECRETARY AND SO
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH HIM ON
HOW DOES HE BETTER THINK WE CAN --
FOCUSES MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE REALLY HAVING INTEGRATION
AT THE PROVIDER LEVEL SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET SORT OF A FULL
SCOPE OF CARE -- IN THE SAME
LOCATION -- IN ADDITION TO THE
SEVENTY MILLION THERE IS SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING SPREAD OVER THREE YEARS --
TO FUNDS PROVIDER TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
TRAUMA SCREENINGS -- I BELIEVE
THE LAST TIME I WAS HERE WE HAD
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A PROVIDERS
PROPERLY TRAINED -- AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE THEN CONTRACT THAT
SO THAT -- THE MONEY THEN ONLY
FLOWS FOR A PROVIDER WHO'S TAKEN
AN APPROPRIATE TRAINING SO WE'LL
BE WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL AND LOOKING
AT CONTRACTORS TO WORK WITH US
TO DEVELOP BUT A COMPREHENSIVE
TRAINING AS WELL AS OUR REACH --
AND MATERIALS FOR THE ENTIRE
OFFICE NOT JUST THE PROVIDER AND
AS WELL AS FAMILY SO THEY
UNDERSTAND -- WHY THESE
QUESTIONS ARE BEING ASKED -- IN
ADDITION TO THAT THERE IS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BEING ADDED
TO OUR LOAN REPAYMENT CALLED CAL
HEALTH CARE'S.
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR PHYSICIANS
AND TWENTY MILLION FOR DENTISTS
WE DID.
HAVE THE FIRST APPLICATION
PERIOD CLOTHES -- I THINK LAST
WEEK NOW -- WE HAD TWELVE HUNT
OVER TWELVE HUNDRED APPLICATIONS
FOR THE LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM --
THE TOTAL AMOUNT REQUESTED WAS
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
SO WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FOR EVERYTHING BUT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THOSE APPLICATIONS IN
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT THE
FUNDING FOR THAT -- BY THE END
OF JUNE SO THAT THAT MONEY CAN
START TO FLOW.
AND THEN FINALLY -- THE FOURTH
ITEM.
FUNDED DIDN'T FOURTH NEW ITEM
FUNDED IS THE RESTORATION OF THE
OPTICAL BENEFIT FOR ADULTS WORDS
THE PROVISION OF GLASSES IN.
AND ISN'T SO THAT NOT.
DEFERRED MY DEPARTMENT FINANCE
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OTHER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ADDRESS BECAUSE THANK
US DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACKNOWLEDGING US UNDERSTANDS
HUNDRED PAN YOUR BANK CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED EARLIER IN THE
HEARING REGARDING THE SUNSETS.
FOR VARIOUS PROGRAMS SO WE WULD
LIKE TO TAKE NOTICE COMMENTS AND
LET YOU KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING THOSE BACK FOR
CONSIDERATION.
AND THEN THE SECOND QUESTION I
BELIEVE IN THE AGENDA THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS.
IS THE AT FOR THE NEXT ROUND OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER PAYMENTS
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
PURSUING.
A ONE YEAR STATE PLAN AMENDMENTS
WITH THE FEDERAL CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES.
WE BELIEVE THAT AN ANNUAL --
YEAR BY YEAR I SUB MIDDLE OF
ANNUAL STATE PLAN AMENDMENTS
ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CIVIL FLEXIBILITY -- AS YOU
REVENUES FOR THE THIS PROGRAM
COMMENT ON ANNUAL BASIS WERE
ABLE TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE ON FUNDING LEVELS SO
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THE US AND ABOUT EIGHTY LA --
COMMENTS SEVEN PRESENTED AT THAT
WOULD.
EXCUSE EXCUSE ME -- BEEN JUMPING
IN WITH ELIO -- WE WE WROTE IN
OUR ANALYSIS THAT WHILE WE FIND
MAKING MOST OF THE PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX PAYMENT INCEASES --
LIMITED TERM HAS POLICY MERITS
TO ALLOW THEM TO BE -- EVALUATED
BEFORE THEY WOULD BE MADE
PERMANENT WE DO RAISE CONCERNS --
ABOUT SUN SETTING THEM FOR
FISCAL MANAGEMENT REASONS AS WE
FIND THAT ULTIMATELY IT IT
UNDERSTATES THE TRUE ONGOING
COSTS OF POLICY COMMITMENTS --
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WHAT
WERE THESE -- WAS IT WERE AN
ANALYSIS TO TAKE PLACE FOR
EXAMPLE FINDING THESE -- THESE
PAYMENTS TO BE EFFECTIVE -- THE
THE CURRENT PLAN WOULD STILL BE
TO TURN THEM OFF AT MIDWAY
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SO -- WE WE HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS WITH THE SUNSET AS WELL --
WE ALSO PROVIDE SOME COMMENTS ON
THE VALUE BASED PAYMENT PROPOSAL
AND OVERLAP WITH OTHER EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE QUALITY OF CARE IN
MANAGED CARE BUT WE TOUCHED ON
THOSE DURING A PREVIOUS HEARING
HAPPY BUT I'LL BE I'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THOSE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES -- CONSIDERATION OF THE
THE SUNSET -- YOU KNOW I THINK
ONE OF THE MOST.
IMPORTANT QUALITIES OF ELECTED
OFFICIAL IS WHEN.
THEY GIVE THEIR WORD AND THEY
SAY SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN KEEP
THEIR WORD -- THIS GOVERNOR IN
JANUARY MADE IT VERY CLEAR.
THAT PROP FIFTY SIX PROCEEDS
WERE GOING TO GO AS THEY WERE
INTENDED TO GO AND THAT WAS TO
SUPPLANT -- ARM OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM -- IT.
WE WITNESSED IN THE PAST WITH
THE PRIOR GOVERNOR THAT PROP
FIFTY SIX MONIES DIDN'T GO TO
WHERE THEY WERE INTENDED AND
ACTUALLY WENT INTO THE GENERAL
FUND.
FOR NON MEDICARE ALL NON HEALTH
CARE RELATED ISSUES.
SO.
JUST BY THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
THE SUNSET RAISES A LOT OF
SUSPICIONS -- AS TO WHY WE WOULD
EVEN CONSIDER.
THE NEWS FUND SOMEPLACE ELSE
WHETHER BE THE GENERAL FUND OR
ELSEWHERE.
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE GOVERNOR
MADE A COMMITMENT.
A PUBLIC COMMITMENT -- AND THAT
HE RECEIVED A LOT OF PRAISE.
FOR THAT A PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED FOR SO
MANY YEARS WAS FINANCING SOME
RELIEF.
SO WHILE I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS -- I'M I'M AS ONE AND I
THINK MY CAUCUS AS ANOTHER IS
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THIS VERY
CAREFULLY AS WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGET.
DOCUMENT AS A WHOLE.
AND I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT THAT THE
GOVERNOR MAINTAIN HIS WORD AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO WE CAN.
WITH -- THE TAXES OF PEOPLE
RELIED UPON TO ENSURE THAT THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM IS IS IS WELL
FUNDED AS WE POSSIBLY CAN MAKE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OTHER COMMENTS.
SO YEAH I I'LL I WOULD -- ALSO
JUST HAVE SAID REGARDING THE
SUNSET -- THE VOTERS SO ASIDE
FROM THE GENERAL MARKET MADE
ABOUT SUNSETS ON PREVIOUS ITEMS
I ALSO MENTIONED THAT.
FOR IT'S A GOOD FOR PROP FIFTY
SIX THE VOTERS VOTED FOR THIS.
TAX IS REVENUE STREAM RIGHT.
AND WITH THAT AND IN GETTING THE
VOTERS THE VOTERS VOTED FOR THIS
TO GO TO SPECIFICALLY --
IMPROVING ACCESS TO MEDICAL
INCLUDES -- INCLUDING IMPROVING --
PAYMENTS BECAUSE CLEARLY THAT
WAS A IT DOESN'T ISSUES I MEAN
THAT DOUBLE THE CENTER I WAS
PART OF THAT CAMPAIGN IS THE
CENTERPIECE OF THE CAMPAIGN.
AND SO I THINK THE IDEA THAT WE
WOULD PUT A SUNSET I MEAN THE
VOTERS ENOUGH VOTE FOR A SUNSET
ON THE THE PROPOSITION.
THE IT'S AN ONGOING PROPOSITION
AND I THINK YOU KNOW -- TO HONOR
WHAT THE VOTERS VOTED -- FOR THE
IDEA THAT WE WOULD THEN PUT A
SUNSET ON ON THOSE THINGS THANK
IS IS EXTREMELY DISTURBING -- WE
HAD THIS DISCUSSION WHEN IT
FIRST PASSED AND PROPOSALS ABOUT
HOW TO DIRECT THE MONEY -- I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS GOVERNOR
HAS MADE STATEMENTS THAT HE
WANTS HONOR WHAT THE VOTERS
VOTED FOR FOR PROP -- FIFTY SIX
AND IT'S IN THEM WE APPRECIATE
HIS.
HIS EXPRESSIONS OF THAT AND I I
THINK THAT AND SO PUTTING A
SUNSET BASICALLY IMPLYING THAT
AT THAT SUNSET DATE IS THE THE
MONEY WOULD THEN REFER TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
AGAIN UNDERMINES THE TRUST OF
THE VOTERS -- AND SO OF THOSE WE
GO TRY IT YOU'LL BUILD TRUST
WITH THE PUBLIC ABOUT DO WE KEEP
OUR PROMISES.
WHEN VOTERS VOTE FOR THINGS DO
WE CARRY OUT WHAT THEY DECIDE
WHAT THEIR INTENTIONS ARE I MEAN
WE CAN?
PUT UP MIL WE CAN TRY TO BE
LEGALISTIC BUT DURING THE
TENSIONS ARE PROVIDE CLEAR.
AND SO I THINK THIS REALLY SENDS
THE WRONG SIGNAL TO THE VOTERS
ABOUT WHETHER WE ARE TRUSTWORTHY --
AT THAT WE RESPECT WHAT THEY'VE
TOLD US -- AND THEN IN ADDITION
TO THAT OF COURSE IT ALSO HAS
POLICY IMPLICATIONS BECAUSE
AGAIN THAT.
THIS IS A BIT OF REPETITION THE
PREVIOUS.
ONES BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
YOU'RE TELLING OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T HAVE YOU DON'T HIRE
PEOPLE WITH THE INTENTION OF
LAYING THE MáS IN TWO YEARS.
RIGHT HI YOU DON'T TELL PEOPLE
THAT WELL WILL -- WE'RE GONNA
BRING YOU ON BOARD BUT THEN WE
WON'T HAVE ANY MONEY TO I MEAN
THAT THAT'S RIGHT OR WE'RE GOING
TO CUT YOUR SALARY IN TWO YEARS
I GUESS YOU COULD BECAUSE HE
REALLY UP FRONT ABOUT IT BUT
THEN YOU CAN THINK ABOUT HOW
HARD IS IT TO RECRUIT.
PEOPLE FOR THAT.
SO -- SO I THINK IT HAS A
CHILLING EFFECT ALSO IN THAT
REGARD BUT IT FUNDAMENTALLY.
THE IDEA THAT THE VOTERS SAID WE
ARE PASSING THIS PROPOSITION FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND THEN WE HEAR
AND THE STATE GOVERNMENT WE ARE
GOING TO PROPOSE TO SAY WELL.
TOO BAD WE'RE GOING TO GO AND
JUST TAKE THE MONEY AND THEN FOR
SOMETHING ELSE OR JUST THROWN TO
THE GENERAL POT.
I THINK RELIEF SENDS THE WRONG
MESSAGE AND IT AND AS WE HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE VOTERS TO TALK
ABOUT OTHER PRIORITIES AND WE
HAVE O PROVE OURSELVES
TRUSTWORTHY OF THAT AND AS A
EVERY TIME SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T.
IMPLY IN ANY WAY THAT WE ARE NOT
FIND INTENTIONS OF THE VOTERS.
THAT THAT THE PEOPLE WHO WENT
AND CAMPAIGN FOR THE PROPOSITION
SUCCESSFULLY.
AND AND AND SAID THAT THIS IS
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROPOSITION
WE NEED TO RESPECT THAT AND I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT --
THAT -- WE NOT SEND THAT WE NOT
TELL THE VOTERS OTHERWISE SO.
SO TO ME THAT AGAIN THE SUNSET
SUNSET THE SUN SETS IN GENERAL
THE PROBLEM THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC -- THE OTHER ISSUE I
ACTUALLY WANT TO ASK ABOUT SO I
DO APPRECIATE THE THE PROPOSALS --
IN TERMS OF THE AUGMENTATIONS --
THE I WOULD MAKE NOTE THE
OPTICAL WAS SOMETHING THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED BEFORE SO I
REALLY DO IT -- THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE WE'RE DOING THIS
PREVIOUSLY I WOULD.
COMMENT THAT -- ALSO -- EIGHT MY
MY GOOD FRIEND HAS TALKED ABOUT
THE DIET TREE IS WELL AND NOT TO
THE SAFE IT'S AN FIFTY SIX BUT
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE
END COST BENEFIT RATIO RIGHT --
THE BUT THERE'S FINANCIAL ARE
ALSO IN THE BUT THE OTHER FOR
AND AND THE OTHER PIECE I ALSO
WANT TO TOUCH ON IS THE I
BELIEVE THE LAST TIME WE TALKED --
WITH.
THE X. YES WAS STILL WORKING ON
THE FAMILY PLANNING PIECE.
AND WHERE AND I THINK WE EXPRESS
THAT AT LEAST WHAT WAS BEING
PROPOSED AND EVEN YOU AND THE
DIRECTOR AT SAID THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE REALLY WANT TO DO -- AND
THERE WAS -- SO WHAT WHERE ARE
WE WHERE WHERE'S ADMINISTRATION
ON THE FAMILY PLANNING -- FUNDS
THOUGH I FULLY OWNED THAT THAT
IS ALL MY FAULT THAT I HAVE NOT
FINISHED THE PROPOSALS THAT WAS
NO ONE ELSE IN WHO ELSE'S FAULT --
I AM HOPEFUL LEASE.
NEXT WEEK WE'LL HAVE SOMETHING
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
STUFF THAT -- CAME PARENTHOOD
HAS PROVIDED -- IN TERMS OF THE
INFORMATION -- AROUND SOME OF
THE SERVICES -- I THINK LOOKING
AT THINGS LIKE ARE YOU DE
INSERTION AND THINGS LIKE THAT
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS ARE
GOING TO WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
DATE IS A LITTLE COMPLICATED BUT
I'M I'M PRETTY CLOSE AT THIS
POINT.
OKAY SO AGAIN -- VISIT WITH THEM
WON'T REITERATE WHAT WE SAID THE
LAST HEARING ENTIRELY BUT
BASICALLY WE WANNA BE SURE THE
MONEY IS FOCUSED IN A WAY THAT
NEWS THE NEEDLE ON ACCESS TO
FAMILY PLANNING THAT'S WHAT I
JUST STANLEY SPREADING IT AROUND.
ABSOLUTELY WE TOTALLY AGREE OKAY
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
NO COMMENT ALL RIGHT PUBLIC
COMMENT FORCES PUBLIC COMMENT --
KELLY BE MY BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION --
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE
INVESTMENTS USING ONE TIME
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDING OF
TWO AND SIXTY THREE MILLION.
INCLUDING PHYSICIAN AND OUT AS
LOAN REPAYMENT VALUE BASED
PAYMENT FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTEGRATION AND PROVIDER TREATY.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE OTHER FUNDING --
SUCH AS THE MCO TAX OR OTHER
REVENUE STREAMS OTHER THAN ONE
TIME FUNDS WOULD BE BEST SUITED
TO FIND THE RESTORATION OF THE
OPTICAL BENEFIT.
AND THE OTHER BENEFITS CUT
DURING THE SESSION LIKE THE
PODIATRY BENEFIT.
PROP FIFTY SIX IS PASSED BY THE
VOTERS AS YOU GUYS ALL TALKED
ABOUT WAS INTENDED TO INCREASE
ACCESS VIA PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS
RATHER THAN THE BENEFITS --
COVERED OR INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF BENEFICIARIES COVERED BY
MEDICARE. FOR THE SAME REASON WE
OPPOSE THE USE OF PROPERTY SIX
TO FIND GROWTH IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM AFTER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED SUNSET OF PROP FIFTY
SIX INVESTMENTS -- ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INSTEAD WE REQUEST THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TAKE ACTION
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
APPROVE -- PROPERTY SIX AND BENT
AT INVESTMENTS I'M UNDER A THREE
YEAR STATE PLAN AMENDMENT.
AND CREATE MORE CERTAINTY FOR
PROVIDERS WHO WANT TO SERVE THE
PROGRAM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL IN THE COMING WEEKS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI DARIA MCGREW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION --
BUT QUICKLY THIS IS A BOTH A ONE
IN THREE COMMENT WE SUPPORT THE
LA -- SUGGESTION OF MORE
TRANSPARENCY PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE SUSCEPTIBLE. TO
UNCERTAINTY FUNDS LIKE THE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE MILLION
EXTRA IN PROP FIFTY SIX IT'S
LENS -- LENS LIGHT TO WHY WE
NEED MORE TRANSPARENCY ON THE
FUNDING -- IN IN PROP FIFTY SIX
BIGGER -- ISSUE WE REALLY HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING CONTINUITY NEED
FOR CONTINUITY IN -- PROVIDER
RESOURCE SAYS.
WE ARE SEEING.
REAL GAINS IN PROVIDERS AND
ROLLING IN PROP IN THE DENTAL
PROGRAM FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OVER A DECADE WE'RE SEEING THE
NUMBERS GO UP.
IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS NINE
HUNDRED NEW PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
ROLLED -- THIS IS A REAL
POSITIVE CHANGE IN THIS PROGRAM.
AS MENTIONED THE STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM HAD TWELVE
HUNDRED APPLICANTS WHO ARE
WILLING TO COMMIT FIVE YEARS TO
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
SO CDA DOES NOT SUPPORT SUN
SETTING -- THE PROGRAM AFTER TWO
YEARS WHEN THERE'S SUCH A
WILLINGNESS OF PROVIDERS TO
COMMIT TO A LONGER TERM AND NEED
THE SAME COMMITMENT FROM.
FROM THE STATE.
THANKS THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE DO APPRECIATE
THE FUNDING TO RESTORE EYE
GLASSES AND EYEWEAR -- DO YOU
HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THAT THE
CHAIR THE CHAIRS CONCERN
REGARDING THE TEMPORARY NATURE
OF THAT AND KNOW THAT -- IT IS A
CONCERN TO TO GIVE A BENEFIT AND
THEN TAKE IT AWAY TWO YEARS
LATER -- WE ALSO NOTE -- AS
CHAIR STATED THAT THE GOAL OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX WITH TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO MEDICARE I'LL --
WHETHER THAT BE THROUGH PROVIDER
RATES INCREASE SERVICES AND OR
ELIGIBILITY.
BOB AND FINALLY WE DO SUPPORT
THE NAY REVISION PROPOSAL TO
RELATED TO THE VALUE BASED.
PAYMENTS AS WELL AS PROVIDE AIR
TRAINING FOR TRAUMA SCREENING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON RENTAL COMING
HERE ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA WHEN A LINE MY
COMMENT TO BROWN THE INTENT OF
PROPERTY SIX WITH -- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR VALUE BASED PAYMENTS
ALSO FOR THE INVESTMENTS FOR THE
TRAUMA SCREENINGS.
AND FOR OPTICAL BENEFITS
ALTHOUGH WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
OPTICAL BENEFITS -- FOR THE
ADDITIONAL -- SERVICES IN
OPTICAL LAB SERVICES SHOULD
CERTAINLY -- THIS BE SOMETHING
THAT WE DO MOVE FORWARD INTO
PERPETUITY AND NOT JUST HAVE A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT FOR THAT
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
AFTERNOON ANDREAS SAN MIGUEL
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA -- I
JUST WANT TO REALLY THINK THE
CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR COMMENTS TODAY -- ABOUT
INSURING THAT THE ALLOCATION FOR
FAMILY PLANNING IS SPENT IN A
WAY THAT WILL -- GO TO A VARIETY
OF SERVICES AND ULTIMATELY
INCREASE ACCESS -- AND SO THAT
THIS IS A I AM VERY GLAD TO HAVE
IT LISTED AGAIN AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT -- HAS BEEN
DONE BY EVERYONE IN THE ROOM AND
ALSO JUST KIND OF ECHO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS POTENTIAL
IMPLICATIONS ON WORK FORCE. FOR
FOR ANY DISCUSSION OF A SUNSET
[inaudible]
SEVEN THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY
BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES -- AND HAVE A GENERAL
COMMENT RELATED TO PROP FIFTY
SIX AS IT RELATES TO THE MAY
REVISE WE REPRESENT THE HANDFUL
OF PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES AND THE STATE THAT
SERVE MEDICALLY FRAGILE PATIENTS.
THAT ARE -- TECHNOLOGY
DEPENDENCE THE WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
CONTINUATION OF PROP FIFTY SIX
FUNDS THAT THEY ARE NOT INCLUDED --
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION --
SAVES MEDI CAL 500-100-0500
DOLLARS A DAY I'M TO MOVE THESE
I AM VERY FRAGILE PATIENTS FROM
NICK USE -- AN ICY USE TO THE
PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE SO HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER --
FUNDING PROP FIFTY SIX FOR THEM
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SO I GUESS --
I DO HEAR THAT.
IT'S CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
RESTORATION THE BENEFITS WHETHER
THAT REALLY SHOULD FIGHT AND
PROPERTY SIX ABRIL ARE NOT --
THINKS IT CAN BE RAISED BUT I
GUESS THE QUESTION THE BIGGER
QUESTION IS -- REGARDS.
TO AND IT'S CERTAINLY BILL I SEE
THAT HAPPEN -- IN REGARDS TO THE
FINANCE TO TWENTY ONE YEAR.
VERSUS. THREE YEARS WHICH HAS
BEEN MENTIONED I MEAN I SO AGAIN
THIS IS ABOUT.
CERTAINTY AND AND AND AND BEING
SURE THAT HELP PEOPLE WERE.
IT TAKES TIME FEEL PEOPLE'S SIT
BACK AND WATCH AND WE SAW THIS
HAPPEN UNFORTUNATELY THE ACA
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT IT WAS A
TEMPORARY BOMB. THREE YEARS --
FOR TO FOR MEDICAID FOR
PEDIATRICS TO MEDICARE RATES --
PEOPLE POINT TO IT BEING
UNSUCCESSFUL AND BUT I THINK THE
REASON WAS UNSUCCESSFUL IS NOT
BECAUSE THE RATES WOULD HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENCE THE PROBLEM
WAS THAT PEOPLE KNEW WAS ONLY
FOR THREE YEARS.
THAT MANY TIMES -- FRANKLY EVEN
IN THIS STATE THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION DIDN'T HAPPEN TO
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF I MEAN
WE WENT BACK WITH.
PEOPLE DON'T PEOPLE INTEREST IN
SIGNING UP TO GET YELLED AT
UNDER PROMISE THAT THEY'LL GET
BACK BILL GET BACK FILLED I DO
WANT TO SEE IT RIGHT AWAY.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WHEN
WE SAY WELL TIME CERTAIN IT'S
EITHER GOING TO END OR THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE DOING ONE YEAR BY
YEAR.
THAT UNCERTAINTY.
IS WHAT DISCOURAGES PEOPLE FROM
FRANKLY FOR THEM TAKING A RISK
RIGHT TO TO TO SIGN UP RIGHT SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT PEOPLE.
THERE PLENTY PATIENTS TO TAKE
CARE OF THERE PLAY PATIENTS
HILDA DIED AND DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO TAKE MEDI CAL PATIENTS
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL PRACTICE BUT WE WANT
THEM TO IN LA.
PEOPLE WANT TO IT -- AND DAY ONE
OF IN FACT WE SEE THE LEVEL OF
INTEREST IN THE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM.
PEOPLE WANT TO GO TO UNDERSERVED
AREAS THEY WANT TAKE YOUR
MEDICARE PATIENTS.
RIGHT THEY WANT TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THAT THAT'S
PART OF NOT BECAUSE WE GET RICH
DOING IT.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WANT TO STAY
WITH THE REALLY TO PEOPLE I MEAN
I'VE INTERACT WITH MEDICAL
STUDENTS PRESENCE ALL TIME AND
AND THAT'S IN -- DENNIS'S OF
WHAT THEY THEY WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF PEOPLE OR UNDERSERVED A DAY
DON'T WANT TO SAY WELL WE DON'T
TAKE IN THESE PATIENTS REALLY
FIGURE THOSE PATIENTS.
SO THE DESIRE IS THERE -- BUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT WHEN THERE'S
ALWAYS THIS UNCERTAINTY WELL HOW
MUCH MAY GET PAID WELL IT SAID
IT WAS I HAVE TO KEEP PRACTICE
GOING [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO WITH SO CAN WE TALK ABOUT
GIVING PEOPLE MORE CERTAINTY.
I MEAN ASIDE FROM THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT THE THAT THE EXPIRATION
DATE THE YES SUNSET BUT I MEAN
TERMS OF THE PLAN AMENDMENT I
MEAN A A REALIZE THAT YES WE
YEAR TO YEAR BUT IS THIS IS WHAT
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE OPPOSITION.
TO DOING A LONGER PLAN AMENDMENT.
I JUST THINK IT'S DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I THINK AS WE WE NOTED
EARLIER IT DOES -- ONE YEAR
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT DOES GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF FLEXIBILITY -- AN INMATE
ADMINISTRATION GENERAL ARE
FLEXIBILITY FLEXIBILITY TO DO
WHAT TO ELIMINATE THE PAYMENTS
NO NOT THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE LIKE CIVILIAN A CD NO
NO CERTAINLY AND I'M NOT THAT
KIND OF FLEXIBILITY IT IS A
DECLINING REVENUE SOURCE --
BEING A TOBACCO TAX ALL TOBACCO
TAXES SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS FLEXIBILITY
TO REEVALUATE FUNDING LEVELS ON
A YEAR BY YEAR BASIS.
AN ANNUAL STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
DOES A FACILITY THAT PROCESS.
SO I GUESS.
VAN THAT MAKES EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT -- THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SENDS A CLEAR
SIGNAL AGAIN THE THE SUNSET THE
FORTIES THE OPPOSITE WAY THAT
THERE'S A COMMITMENT TO THIS
DOING THIS AN ON GOING BASIS.
RIGHT I MEAN CLEARLY YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE DO BUDGET EVERY
YEAR WE HAVE TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
AND SO FORTH BUT THAT THE
INTENTION AND COMMITMENT IS THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE SUSTAINED
EFFORT BECAUSE THAT'S HOW WE GET
PEOPLE. TO GO AND BECOME MORE
MEDI CAL PAIENTS IN PLACE LIKE
FRESNO SACRAMENTO RIVERSIDE OR
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
SO SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THAT.
THAT THAT HAS.
TO BE EXPRESSED YOU HEAR AND SEE
THE SUNSET CERTAINLY SENDS THE
WRONG SIGNAL AND IT AND AND AND
IT'S IF YOU'RE DOING YEAR BY
YEAR YOU SAY BECAUSE YOU NEED
FLEXIBILITY THAT'S TO BE VERY
CLEAR WHAT KIND OF FLEXIBLE YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT THE FLEX PLEASE
NOT ABOUT.
WELL WE'RE PLAYING THE PULL THE
RUG FROM UNDER YOU WE WANT TO WE
ARE WE ARE COMMITTED TO DOING
THIS AND THE ONLY AT THIS IS A
REVENUE STREAM YES IT'S A
DECLINING ONE BUT IT'S THE ON
THIS ONE IS.
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN THAT'S
NOT GENERAL FUND REVENUE RIGHT
ONE AT THAT THERE'S A COMMITMENT
NOT TO TAKE PROPERTY SIX IN USE
AT THE BACK FILL THE GENERAL
FUND.
I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOU
NEED SAY.
I REALIZE IT'S TRAVIS SOMEBODY
HIGHER UP THE BUT I MEAN BUT I
MEAN THAT THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
THAT KIND OF COMMUNICATION IF
YOU GUYS SAY WELL YOU KNOW WHAT
TRUST US.
I MEAN IF WE CAN'T TELLING
PEOPLE TRUST US.
SOME PEOPLE GO HOME LET'S SEE.
YES -- MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WHAT ABOUT MONDAY GETS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE'LL TAKE THEM BACK -- I DID
WANT TO SAY THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS EXPRESSED HIS COMMITMENT TO
YOU KNOW BROADER -- HEALTH CARE --
DELIVERY SYSTEM CHANGES AND SO
ON THIS WILL BE A PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS -- IN THE FUTURE SO
JUST WANTED TO A POINT THAT
POINT OUT AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
WELL.
AGAIN I IT WE NEED TO BE SURE
ACTIONS ARE CONSISTENT WITH SO
AGAIN THE SUNSET I KNOW HARPING
ON THE SUNSET A BIT BUT YOU JUST
SENT THE WRONG SIGNAL -- WITH
THAT.
SELF.
BUT I THINK BEYOND EVEN JUST
ELIMINATING THE SUNSET I THINK A
STRONGER EXPRESSION -- THE
WIZARD AS HELPFUL AND ACTUALLY
THE THE DEEP BETTER ACTUALLY TO
DO A THREE YEAR.
PLAN AMENDMENT WOULD SET PLEASE
SEND A SIGNAL THAT DEAL WE'RE
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS SO BUT BUT
CERTAINLY.
IF YOU'RE NOT GONNA DO THAT
THERE'S GOT TO BE OTHER WAYS YOU
SEND THAT SIGNAL SWELLED TO
REALLY SELL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ANYTHING ELSE THAN
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR FULL SCOPE MEDICARE
COVERAGE FOR KNOCKED MANY YOUNG
ADULTS MAY REVISION UPDATE.
TORSO -- THE MAY REVISION AND
DOES SHIFT IMPLEMENTATION DATE
TO ONE THAT'S MORE REALISTIC
WHICH IS JANUARY -- INTO ACCOUNT
FOR THE CHANGES THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN AND AND CAL HERE'S IN
SIZE AS WELL AS HAVING A CLEAR
TRANSITION PLAN AND NOTICING AND
ALL OF THOSE TYPES OF THINGS SO.
THE MOST OF THE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN THE FISCAL IS RELATED
TO THE SIX MONTH SHIFT IN
IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
WE DID ALSO UPDATE THE THE
ELIGIBILITY AND ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS BASED ON MORE RECENT
DATA AS WELL AS CORRECTING AN
ISSUE THAT HAD BEEN IDENTIFIED
BY THE LA -- IN THE JANUARY
ESTIMATE.
IF THEY CAN THAT EIGHTY FIVE
WITH THE FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
MORNING MR CARE AND NUMBER GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
JENNY LIND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO THE NEIGHBOR VISION A SCENES
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS OF FORTY
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM.
AND MAKE SEVERAL CHANGES TO THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL FOR AB
EIGHTY FIVE FIRST NOTING
CONCERNS FROM COUNTIES ON THE
DECREASE OF FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH ACTIVITIES.
THE MAYOR VISION NO LONGER
REFLECTS TO CHANGE THE
REDIRECTION AMOUNT OF THE FOR
COUNTIES REALIGNMENT REVENUES
275%.
SECOND THE MAYBE REVISION
REFLECTS YOLO COUNTY AT THE
COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES PROGRAM
COUNTY.
AND LASTLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO WITHHOLD REALIGNMENT
REVENUES FROM THE COUNTY MEDICAL
SERVICES PROGRAM BOARD.
UNTIL THE BOARD'S TOTAL RESERVES
REACHED A REASONABLE LEVEL EQUAL
TO TWO YEARS OF TOTAL
EXPENDITURES.
AT THAT POINT THE WARTS
REDIRECTION WILL BE REFLECTED AT
75%.
AND WE HAVE HEARD CONCERNS ON
THE REDIRECTION LEVEL AT 75% FOR
THE SEEM AS KEYBOARD FROM FROM
THE LA -- INSTEAD HOLDERS AND
WE'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE WILL
BE TAKING THESE CONCERNS BACK
FOR CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
OKAY AVAIL.
ON THE NUMBER OF VICE ESTIMATES
FOR THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE AL --
WE THINK A JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TIMELINE IS VERY REASONABLE IN
LIGHT OF THE STATE'S EXPERIENCE
WITH THE PREVIOUS EXPANSION TO
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN -- WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND --
REVISED CASELOAD ESTIMATES BUT
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS AT THIS
TIME.
ON THE AB EIGHTY FIVE ISSUE --
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THERE
MAY STILL BE SOME SAVINGS IN THE
FOR A NON CMS P. COUNTIES THAT
WERE MENTIONED.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ESSENTIALLY REFLECTS A POLICY
CHOICE TO ALLOW THOSE SAVINGS TO
STAY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
LOCAL PRIORITIES INCLUDING
PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIVITIES.
THAT'S A REASONABLE PRIORITY --
BUT ONE OF THE LEGISLATURE OF
COURSE CAN CAN WEIGH AGAINST
OTHER LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES FOR
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES -- WE
ALSO THINK IT IS REASONABLE I'M
AS WE NOTED BEFORE FOR THE STATE
TO RE DIRECT.
REALIGNMENT REVENUES FROM THE C.
M. S. P. PROGRAM GIVEN THAT THEY
HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT RESERVE --
OVER TEN YEARS OF OPERATING
EXPENSES -- BUT AS WAS NOTED --
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT IT APPEARS THE IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE MISTER
SINCE PROPOSAL WOULD
ADDITIONALLY -- ELIMINATE GROWTH
FUNDING TO THE SAME AS P.
PROGRAM.
INDEFINITELY -- AND AT 75% --
WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN SEEM AS
P. PROGRAM NOT RECEIVING.
REVENUES EVEN AFTER ITS RESERVES
GO DOWN TO A LOWER LEVEL.
NOW OF COURSE GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF RESERVES OF THE
PROGRAM HAS THIS WOULD ALL TAKE
PLACE.
YEARS IN THE FUTURE -- BUT WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A NEED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEFINE.
THE PARAMETERS OF ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE SAME IS BE
PROGRAM.
AT THIS POINT -- INSTEAD THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DIRECT.
THAT THE REVENUES BE REDIRECTED
AND FURTHER DIRECT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION -- COME BACK WITH --
ADDITIONAL -- INFORMATION LATER
ON OR ENGAGE IN A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE THE ON GOING -- ROLE
OF THE SAME AS P. PROGRAM GIVEN
THAT THEIR CASE LET'S HAVE
FALLEN SO SIGNIFICANTLY WITH
WITH THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- ANY
OTHER COMES FROM FINANCE OR
EIGHT OKAY QUESTIONS COMPANIES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES SIR TARA.
SIR JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ARE FOR THIS PROPOSAL --
ONE OF MY COUNTIES KINGS COUNTY
FALLS UNDER THE CMS P..
SO.
I JUST WANT TO GET A LITTLE BIT
OF OF AN UNDERSTANDING AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE CASELOADS
HAVE FALLEN WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
FOR THAT COUNTY IN IT YOU KNOW
OTHER.
COUNTIES -- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT -- THAT THE WOULD FALL
UNDER THIS.
AND SO WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT
AT THE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
SPECIFICALLY TO KINGS COUNTY AND
OF COURSE A HUNDRED OF IF YOU
HAVE NUMBERS ON THE ON THE
CASELOADS.
WE WE UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE
AG COUNTY LEVEL INFORMATION I
DON'T KNOW IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS THAT HANDY -- IN IN
GENERAL THE FUNDING FOR THE SAME
AS P. PROGRAM IS IS AGGREGATED
UP FOR ALL THE COUNTIES THAT
PARTICIPATE -- OVERALL CASELOADS
IN C. M. S. P. COUNTIES -- FELL
I'M ABOUT 99% RELATIVE TO BEFORE
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT SO
THERE'S A VERY VERY SMALL
RESIDUAL POPULATION RELATIVE TO
THEY SERVE BEFORE -- AND THAT
HAS CONTRIBUTED SIGNIFICANTLY TO
THE THE LARGE RESERVES HAVE HAVE
BEEN -- AMASSED.
SO WHAT ABOUT THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT [inaudible]
ARE NOT -- WITH THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT PERMISSION YOU DON'T HAVE
IT YOU KNOW AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW
BUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO
THAT TO THAT.
POPULATION THAT IS NOT BEING
ADDRESSED HERE SO SO UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE CMS P.
PROGRAM WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
THE CASE LAW THAT REMAINS
INCLUDING IN KINGS COUNTY GIVEN
THAT THEY HAVE OVER TEN YEARS
WORTH OF RESERVES -- A LATER
QUESTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL NEED TO ADDRESS AT SOME
POINT IS WHAT IS THE ONGOING
ROLE OF THE PROGRAM PARTICULARLY
IF THERE ARE OTHER FUTURE
EXPANSIONS OF COVERAGE -- SAY IN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM THAT
FURTHER REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WHO NEED THE SERVICES
AND WHAT THAT APPROPRIATE LEVEL
FUNDING FOR CMS P. WOULD BE BUT
HAT AGAIN THAT IS A LONGER TERM
QUESTION.
GIVEN THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
RESERVES AVAILABLE TO THE
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE THE SERVICES
TODAY WHAT ABOUT POSITIONS.
THE STATE DOES NOT -- HAVE
BUDGET POSITIONS FOR FOR THE
SAME SB THAT'S A LOCAL A LOCAL
MATTER [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND?
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MR TURN
MEMBERS CAROLING ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES-PROGRAM GOVERNING BOARD HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MERRY VISION
AND ASKING FOR ALTERNATE.
A PROPOSAL THAT WAS PUT BEFORE
THE DEPRTMENT OF FINANCE AND
MARCH WHICH WAS TO OFFER.
A REDIRECTION OF TWENTY OF THE
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
THE BOARD RECEIVES AND THEY ARE
DOING A LOT OF PROGRAMMING.
IN FACT THIS MSP COUNTIES
NOTABLY THEY WERE WORKING
EXTENSIVELY LAST YEAR TO DEVELOP
A UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS HEALTH
BENEFIT ALL THE WAY UP TO AGE
SIXTY FIVE THAT PROGRAM IS LIVE
NOW.
AND THERE IS A CLINIC SYSTEM
WITH ABOUT A LITTLE LESS THAN
FIFTY CLINICS IN THE C. MUST BE
COUNTY IS THAT WALL -- PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING PRIMARY
CARE DISEASE CHRONIC DISEASE
MANAGEMENT.
ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
RUNNING NOW THEY PROVIDED A
PROPOSAL TO ADMINISTRATION TO
EXPAND A SUBSTANTIALLY THE
PROGRAMMING THAT THEY'RE
OFFERING INCLUDING COVERING
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY FIVE WE WERE HOPING
TO SEE THAT THAT PROPOSAL WAS
INCLUDED IN THE MERRY VISION WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE RESERVE.
A SIZEABLE AND OF CONCERN TO THE
ADMINISTRATION PLEASE READ
PLEASE NOTE THAT HALF OF THAT
RESERVE AS A ONE TIME REPAYMENT
FOR THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
A IMPLEMENTATION THE SAME AS P.
DID FOR A BIT THE THIRTY FIVE C.
MUST BE COUNTY SO THAT IS IT'S
NOT LIKE ALL THAT MONEY WAS
ACCRUING EACH YEAR WAS.
PART OF IT IS A VERY LARGE ONE
TIME PAYMENT OF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE
OFFERING TO HAVE REDIRECTED AWAY
THAT THEY COULD SUPPORT.
WE COVERED THE EXPANSION TO THE
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING UP TO AGE
TWENTY SIX INSIDE THE SAME MUST
BE COUNTY SO WE THINK THAT'S A
FAIR ALTERNATE PROPOSAL AND WE
WOULD URGE YOU. TO PROVIDE SAID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON RONALD COLMAN
HERE WE HAVE A HELP TAXES
CALIFORNIA I WOULD SAY THAT WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S --
EXPANSION PROPOSAL FOR YOUNG
ADULTS -- CERTAINLY WE DO HAVE A
NEW ONCE POSITION ON HOW IT IS
FUNDED -- WE DO APPRECIATE THE
CHANGES IN THE MAY REVISE FOR
THE FOR COUNTY SPECIFICALLY
SACRAMENTO SANTA BARBARA --
STANISLAUS IN PLASTER -- TO BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND PARTICULARLY
FOR SACRAMENTO KEEPING THE MONEY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE THEY
DO HAVE ELIGIBILITY -- AVAILABLE
FOR UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WE
ARE HOWEVER CONCERNED -- ABOUT
THE COMPLETE ZEROING OUT -- AND
THE SPEND DOWN OF THE RESERVE OF
C. M. S. P. -- WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THE RESERVE IS A
FOCUS WE DO THINK THAT THERE
STILL SHOULD BE SOME MONEY THAT
IS REDIRECTED TO SAM S. P. --
BECAUSE THEY CERTAINLY ARE --
INVESTING IN -- THAT GAP IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS CERTAINLY THE
PATHWAY TO HEALTH PROGRAM DOES
PROVIDE SLOTS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE SEEN
PROPOSALS FOR C. M. S. P. WHERE
THEY HOPE TO EXPAND TO THEIR
PATHWAY TO HELP PROGRAM. TO GET
MORE UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS
THROUGH THE YEAR AND WE DO THINK
THAT SOME MONEY BEING REDIRECTED
TO THEM COULD BE HELPFUL IN -- A
COMPROMISED -- APPROACH WITH
THAT SAID -- WITH YOUNG ADULTS
WE DO THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD INCLUDE SENIORS AS WELL
IT'S ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS 2% OF THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION NINETY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR MEDI
CAL SOME AYE HSS COSTS -- BUT WE
DO THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
PRIORITIZE THAT FOR THIS
PARTICULAR YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI THERE I AM A GROUP CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE TO MORE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA -- HOWEVER JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT THE LAST ISSUE.
WE WANT THAT COVERAGE TO BE.
MEANINGFUL AND WE NEED TO HAVE
QUALITY PROVIDERS -- AND WE
DON'T.
WANT THE STATE MAKING PROMISES
TO BENEFICIARIES WITHOUT ALSO
HAVING A NETWORK OF QUALITY
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THE CARE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FAIR
WITH THE TING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
TO THE A. B. EIGHTY FIVE
PROPOSAL -- WE WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION IN
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR HERE IN THE
FOR COUNTIES THOSE IN BETWEEN
OURS AND HAVING THE GOVERNOR
SENT HIS PROPOSAL TO TAKE
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH DOLLARS
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL. FOR THE
CMS P. COUNTIES -- AGAIN WANT TO
THANK OUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE
LA -- AND OTHERS WHO'VE BEEN
HELPING EXAMINE THE SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE AND WHAT THAT MIGHT
LOOK IN THE OUT YEARS AND WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS TO
LOOK AT WHAT.
OTHER SOLUTIONS THAT COULD
HAPPEN LATER ON DOWN THEROAD --
AND THEN THE CHANGING HEALTH
CARE LANDSCAPE ALL OF THESE
SCENARIOS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IS
SEEN AS BE OFFERING HEALTH CARE
POTENTIALLY MORE EXPANSIONS IN
MEDI CAL FOR UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS --
HOW WE CAN PLAN THAT OUT SO THAT
SEEM SB CONTINUES TO PROVIDE THE
CRITICAL RURAL HEALTH SAFETY NET
BUT ALSO THAT FOLKS HAVE
COVERAGE THANK YOU?
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MICHELLE GIVEN THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDIC HOUSE
AND DOCUMENT YOUNG ADULTS AND
WE'RE ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE TO
SEE.
THE COMPROMISE THAT WAS MADE FOR
THE FOR COUNTIES THAT THE
ADDITIONAL REDIRECTION WILL NO
LONGER HAPPEN THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES IN FOR AS
MENTIONED BEFORE FOR SACRAMENTO
TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES TO UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT WOULD BE MY BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF EXPANDING MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY BUT NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF LOCAL COUNTY SAN
ENTITIES?
AND THEN ALSO -- MAKING SURE
THAT IS PAIRED WITH INVESTMENTS
IN WORKFORCE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NOT PROVIDERS AND TO
SERVE THOSE NEW BENEFICIARIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR THAT PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND MEDICARE HEALTH TO YOUNG
ADULTS I SEE NO ISSUES WITH THE
DELAY AS THAT ALIGNS WITH OTHER --
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS -- AND
ALSO I CONSIDERING THE THE LOWER
ESTIMATES REVISED ESTIMATES WITH
THE DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION WE
ASK THAT THERE BE CONSIDERATION
GIVEN TO EXPANDING BEYOND YOUNG
ADULTS PARTICULARLY THE THE
COMMUNITY HAS NOTED.
THAT INDIVIDUAL SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER I HAS PRIORITIZE THAT
POPULATION SO WOULD ALSO ASK OUR
CONSIDERATION BE GIVEN TO THAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MARK MENDOZA WITH SCA YOU
CALIFORNIA -- WELL WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S.
EXPANSION FOR YOUNG ADULTS
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS IS SCA
YOU HISTORICALLY -- HAS BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF PROVIDING FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL BENEFITS TO ALL
AND DOCUMENTED -- FOLKS AND ALSO
JUST TO STRESS ON WHATEVER THE
SORT OF FINAL AGREED UPON
EXPANSION IS THAT IT ALSO
INCLUDE AYE HSS SERVICES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON DEEPLY
TECHNICIAN WITH A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER -- IN
SUPPORT OF THE ALLOCATION OF THE
CONGRESS PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
HEALTHCARE FULL COMMITTEE CAL TO
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS UP TO
AGE TWENTY FIVE BUT WOULD URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER.
EXPANDING TO SENIORS SIXTY FIVE
AND OVER BUT MEDI CAL AND I HSS
COSTS THIS YEAR.
AS WAS MENTIONED A COMMUNITY IS
UPLIFTING BEAT THEIR VOICES
BECAUSE THIS IS THE POPULATION
THAT IS IN GREATEST NEED -- AND
MOST IMMEDIATE NEEDS AS WAS
NOTED IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS I'M
AND WOULD ALSO ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER SOME KIND OF
PLAN TO GET.
TO I COVER ALL UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS THE NEXT FEW YEARS THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS THE
CALIFORNIA ASOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OF EXPANDING MY CAL
TO UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
NO I BOTTOM REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ON BEHALF
OF OUR FARM WORKER.
IMMIGRANT RURAL COMMUNITIES WE
STAND WITH WESTERN CENTER CA PC
AND HEALTH ACCESS AND EXPANDING.
COVERAGE TO YOUNG ADULTS AND
BEYOND SO WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE QUESTION
AROUND DATA THAT VERY KEY AND
JUST TO SHARE WITH CENTER HER
TITLE.
IS APPROXIMATELY NINETY SEVEN
HUNDRED FARMWORKERS IN KINGS
COUNTY OF THOSE BASED ON UC
BERKELEY THE STUDY SHOWS THAT
ABOUT. THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED ARE
COVERED UNDER MEDICARE SO
THERE'S A GAP IN TERMS OF ACCESS
TO CARE AND COVERAGE THAT WE
STILL NEED TO FILL WHICH IS
PROPOSAL WILL THE HOPEFULLY.
WILL DO IN ADDITION BEYOND THAT
TO INCLUDE OUR OLDER ADULTS AND
SENIORS AND SO DATA IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN NO THESE
NUMBERS AND HE'S SEEN AS BE
COUNTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI THIS IS I'M CARRIE BROWNSTEIN
I'M THE ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
FOR SAM S. P..
I JUST WANTED -- TO TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT AN UNCERTAIN
REVENUE FLOW FOR C. M. S. P..
THAT PUTS YOU MUST BE IN A
LITTLE BIT OF A POSITION OF
ACTING MORE AS AN ENDOWMENT --
WHICH MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT IF IF WE HAVE A
SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE IN OUR
ONGOING REVENUE IN THE FUTURES
ZERO IT'S HARD -- TO EXPAND AND
THEN YOU KNOW CUT THINGS OFF
AFTER THAT AND WE REALLY WANT TO
WORK WITH THE STATE ON THIS AS
WELL BECAUSE WE WE HAVE THIS NEW
PATH TO HELP PROGRAM WE KNOW THE
GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND.
HEALTH CARE TO THE UNDOCUMENTED
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE DOING THAT
AGES.
TWENTY ONE TO SIXTY FOUR IN OUR
THIRTY FIVE COUNTIES WE LESS AS
KAREN LÏNG MENTIONED WE HAVE.
OVER OR BY ABOUT FORTY SIX TO
FIFTY CLINICS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
FOCUSING GO AND THEY GET ROLE
ACTUALLY AT THE CLINIC.
SO AS FAR AS GETTING CARE THEY
GET CARE THAT DAY THAT DAY AND
WE WANT TO EXPAND THAT TO AGES
SIXTY FIVE PLUS.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO EXPAND THE
PRIMARY CARE BENEFIT FOR CMS P.
MEMBERS SOME OF OUR SEEM AS P.
MEMBERS MAY NOT BECOME A SIEMENS
REMEMBER YES WE DROPPED VERY LOW.
AFTER ACA IMPLEMENTATION THERE
ARE LIGIBLES OUT THERE BUT IF
THEIR SHARE OF COST IS REALLY
HIGH THEY MIGHT NOT GO GET THOSE
PRIMARY CARE SERVICES.
SO WE'RE LOOKING ALSO AT DOING
AN EXPANDED PRIMARY CARE.
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE MEMBERS COUNTY MUST FOR
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S --
EXPANDING COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED -- INDIVIDUALS.
THANK YOU.
SO -- SO FIRST OF ALL I KNOW THE
SHE TO GOVERNMENT'S LEADERSHIP
AND AND PROPOSING COVERED THE
ANATOMY OF ADULTS I THINK WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING SEE WHAT I CAN DO A
LITTLE MORE -- I REALLY
APPRECIATE -- THE ADMINISTRATION
LISTING IN REGARDS TO THE COUNTY
REALIGNMENT FOR THE FOR COUNTIES
THAT REPRESENT ONE OF THEM SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL.
REGARDING CMS P. AND THE SO -- I
YET I GET THE IDEA THAT OKAY.
AND FROM THE C. M. S. V. FOLKS
THAT WHILE THEY GOT FIRST OF ALL
WE GOT ONE KIND OF LARGEST CHUNK
OF MONEY BACK FOR THE ACA BUT
THEY'RE SITTING ON TEN YEARS.
RIGHT THAT'S WHY [inaudible]
OKAY -- THE OPERATING RESERVE OF
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THEIR
EXPENDITURES A. COULD BE MORE
THAN TEN YEARS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO.
SO I GET THE IDEA YOU'RE SAYING
OKAY WELL.
AT AND MOST OF THE MONEY COMES
FROM WHERE [inaudible]
FROM.
FROM -- THE REALIGNMENT RAVENOUS
RIGHT NOW OKAY SO SO THAT SO
THAT THAT IS SO AND SO ONE OF
THINGS I HEAR THEM SAYING THAT
DATED SO IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SPENDING OUT SOME POINT WE'VE.
THE MONEY NEEDS THAT.
THE ARTS WE KEEP IT SAID I HEARD
SPEND DOWN THE TWO YEARS ROUGHLY.
AND DESERVE PLAN THEN FOR THEM.
TO TO THEN GET REVENUE AGAIN FOR
THAT OR I MEAN I GUESS THAT
THAT'S A QUESTION THAT'S COME UP
SO BECAUSE OTHERWISE EFFECTIVELY
YOU'RE NOT SAYING SPEND UNTIL
TWO YEARS I MEAN IT JUST GOES
DOWN TO ZERO CORRECT.
SO -- AND I REALIZE THAT'S NOT
THIS YEAR -- PRIVACY SEVERAL
YEARS OUT GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE
THE THE THE AMOUNTS BUT IS.
CAN CAN.
AT ONE ALABAMA TO GUESS WHAT IT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SO --
THE TERRIBLE IS FORTHCOMING ON
THIS -- AND SO THE PROPOSAL
RIGHT NOW IS AFTER WE DETERMINED
THAT THERE'S A YOU KNOW A
REASONABLE RESERVE -- WE WILL
RIVER OR THE REDIRECTION AMOUNT
WILL CHANGE 275% AND SO THAT'S
THE POINT THAT THE ALLEY --
RAISED EARLIER THAT -- PERHAPS
SAID 75% -- THEN THE THE REVENUE --
MAY STILL.
MAY STILL BE ZERO AND SO THAT'S
WITH MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
EARLIER THOSE ARE THE COMMENTS
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE BACK IN
TERMS OF THE 75% VERSUS MAYBE
PERHAPS ANOTHER LEVEL -- BUT THE
PROPOSAL AS IT IS TODAY IS -- TO
AFTER REASONABLE RESERVE.
IS REACHED THEN WE WOULD --
INCREASE EVERY DIRECTION 275% OF
THE VOTE SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIT
SO THE OTHER THING THAT I WANT
JUST MENTION IS THAT -- IN A FEW
CAN APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP AND TRYING TO GET
MORE UNDOCUMENTED COVERED AND I
THINK THERE'S SOME HOPE THAT WE
CAN DO EVEN MORE OVER THE YEARS
MAYBE WE'RE SO LUCKY WILL EVEN.
GET EVERYBODY BEFORE THE THAT
RUNS OUT AND AND RECOGNIZE THAT
NOT EVERYONE ON C. MYSTERIES
NECESSARILY AND DOCUMENT EITHER
SO THE PROGRAMS NOT JUST SERVING
A DOCUMENT CORRECT.
THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING IS --
UNDOCUMENTED AND FOLKS THAT JUST
DON'T HAVE OTHER COVERAGE RIGHT
OKAY SO I MEAN WE'VE DONE
COVERAGE EXPANSIONS OF OTHER
TYPES TO SELL.
SO BUT THE ONE PART I ALSO
WANTED SO EVEN IF WE OFFER
COVERAGE TO ALL UNDOCUMENTED.
THE THING I THINK WE NEED TO
KEEP MY AT LEAST CURRENTLY WE
HAVE.
THERE'S A PUBLIC CHARGE ISSUE.
AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE HAVING
SOME CHALLENGES WITH SOME
FAMILIES WILLING TO SIGN UP FOR
SERVICES THAT THEY ARE ELIGIBLE.
FOR AND WHILE CERTAINLY ONE CAN
ARGUE THAT MIGHT ALSO APPLIED TO
SOME OF THE CMS IT.
I DO WONDER WHETHER SINCE SOME
OFTHOSE ARE REALLY MORE
DIRECTLY FRANKLY THAT IT DID DID
IT IS THAT THAT IS A SERVER BACK
UP TO EVEN IF WE SET SAY WE SAY
WE'RE GONNA COVER EVERYBODY IN
HERE YOU CAN GET MEDI CAL WILL
YOUR DOCUMENT OR NOT.
DURING THE PEOPLE AFRAID SIGNED
UP JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PUBLIC
CHARGE NOW MAYBE THAT WILL
CHANGE I DON'T KNOW MAYBE
THEY'LL CHANGE IN A FEW YEARS
DEPENDS -- BUT A A DO WHAT IT
DEALS THINK ABOUT.
THIS IN ADDITION TO THE FACT
THAT WE STILL HAVE A GAP.
EVEN IF WE CLOSE THE GAP R.
COSTA SUBSTANTIALLY.
AT LEAST IN THIS CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT AND AGAIN YOU KNOW
WHO KNOWS HOW MANY YEARS OUT --
DO WE NEED TO HAVE OF A A AND
AND I DESERVE SOME DUPLICATION
SERVE A LITTLE BIT OF A BACK UP
BECAUSE DURING THE PEOPLE FRAYED
SIGN UP ANYWAY JUST BECAUSE THEN
WE SEE PEOPLE NOW.
NOT WAY SIDE FOR WICKER SEEN
PEOPLE NOT MY INSIDE FOR A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND THAT THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
FIND.
GOING TO THE SEMIS FEWER DATES
GO TO A CLINIC AND SHOW UP --
AND NOT HAVING TO SIGN YOUR NAME
ON A WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS MAYBE
MORE THEY'RE OPEN MORE OPEN THAT
THAT AND WE MAKES ONE THINK
ABOUT THAT AS A POLICY THING TO
CONSIDER.
RIGHT AND IT IS WORKERS ARE
MOVING FORWARD AS WELL.
AND TELL MAYBE THINGS WILL
CHANGE IN FUTURE YEARS AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
AS MUCH BUT RIGHT NOW IT SEEMS
LIKE SOMETHING PEOPLE TO WORRY
ABOUT.
SO JUST WHAT THROW THAT IN THIS
PART OF THE DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
BUT AGAIN APPRECIATE -- THE ON
GOING CONVERSATION OF THE
CHANGES MADE SO FAR BUT I THINK
FOR SERIOUSLY I MAY HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING -- BUT I THINK
IT'S A LITTLE CHALLENGING.
THEM AND I UNDERSTAND YOU GOT
MOST OF THE MONEY IN ONE YOU
KNOW THE ACA BUT IT.
SELL.
ALTHOUGH THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION SURE OKAY ANY OTHER.
ISLANDS OKAY SO WE WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN -- LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE YEAR RUN
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS MINDS.
SURE SO I A I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE HEARD A STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL ON THIS SO I'LL JUST BE
REALLY BRIEF WE ARE REQUESTING
THREE POINT SIX MILLION AN IMAGE
SAY FUNDS -- OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS TO CONTRACT WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO TO CREATE A STATEWIDE --
PEER RUN MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
LINE SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN DOING -- FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS IN IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO COMMENTS
FINANCE NEW PERSON AT THE TABLE
YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
UNKNOWN CONFRONT IN FINANCE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WELCOME.
BETWEEN AT THE LA GOES TOO MUCH
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
TYLER ANY WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION -- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF PHAM
PURE BASED PAPER HOUSE ON
SERVICES IN GENERAL AND AGREE
THAT PROVIDING CARE SERVICES
THROUGH A CRISIS LINE CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT WAY TO REACH MORE
CALIFORNIANS.
WERE EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES OR CALM CONDITIONS WE DO
HAVE QUESTIONS HOWEVER ON HOW
THIS WILL BE IMPLEMENTED -- WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT SOME ASPECTS
OF THE CRISIS LINE MAY BE
DUPLICATIVE -- AS WE HAVE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND CRISIS FIND
OPERATED.
BUT BY COUNTIES AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL WHICH DOES INCLUDE PEERS
AND PROVIDERS WITH FIVE TO
EXPERIENCE -- ADDITIONALLY THERE
SHOULD BE A QUALITY COMPONENT TO
THIS AS A PART OF ON THE
COUNTY'S OPERATION OF THESE
LINES ALONG SIDE WITH -- APP
BASED PEER RUN PLATFORMS
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
RESEARCHERS IN ENSURING ONGOING
QUALITY MONITORING AND ASSESSING
OUTCOMES FOR THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION POP FORMS -- FINALLY
WE WOULD WANT TO ENSURE ON
COORDINATION WITH EXISTING
SYSTEMS OF CARE -- PEOPLE THAT
WILL CALL THE CRISIS LINE WILL
NEED REFERRALS TO ON GOING CARE --
AND SERVICES WITHIN THE PUBLICLY
FUNDED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT SYSTEM SO WHILE WE ARE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS IN
CONCEPT.
I'M IT THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
AT THE STATE THINK CRITICALLY
ABOUT HOW TO COORDINATE THE
STRATEGY WITH EXISTING RESOURCES
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
PERSON.
OKAY SO -- THANK YOU.
AS CERTAINLY WHY MEASURE WE
INTEGRATE WITH EXISTING SERVICES
AS WELL OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN CREATORS
COMMENTS OKAY ISSUE NUMBER SIX
NOT A WHOLE PERSON CARE COUNTIES.
FOR SERVICE PART OF THE JANUARY
BUDGET -- THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING TO GO TO SUPPORT THE
TWENTY FIVE WHOLE PERSON CARE.
KILEY IT'S TO HELP CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT A HOUSING SPECIFICALLY
HOUSING SERVICES AND THOSE WHO
HAVE SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS --
AS WE CONTINUE TO EVALUATE AND
AS I'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE IN IN
THIS COMMITTEE THE FUTURE OF THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM AND WHAT HAPPENS
POST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PROPOSED --
TWENTY TWENTY WE REALLY YEAR.
THOUGHT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN
INVESTMENT IN THIS IS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE COUNTIES
THAT ARE NOT PARTICIPATING IN
WHOLE PERSON CARE. TO REALLY
HELP THEM -- SHRIMP GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WHEN WERE IN A PLACE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
HOPEFULLY SPREAD -- MORE STATE
WIDE THE THE GOOD PARTS OF HOLD
POWER POLL PERSON CARE THAT THEY
WON'T BE SORT OF BEHIND BECAUSE
THEY WERE NOT A PART OF THE THE
INITIAL.
PILOT PROGRAMS AND I SAY THERE
ARE MANY REASONS WHY COUNTIES
MIGHT NOT HAVE -- PARTICIPATED
IN WHOLE PERSON CARE ONE OF THEM
BEING JUST THE LACK OF NON
FEDERAL FUNDING -- AND SO THIS
IS ESSENTIALLY GRANT FUNDING TO
HELP THEM -- SORT OF GET IT GET
READY [inaudible]
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE OKAY HELLO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE MEMBERS.
JUST THE TWO CLARIFIED THE
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING AND APPRECIATE
WE'RE GOING FROM PILOT TO MAKE
IT MORE SO APPRECIATE -- NOT
JUST IN THE PILOT STAGE -- THAT
THEY HAVE TO PUT IN ANY SORT OF
LOCAL FUNDS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT YEAH OKAY SO WHAT IS ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD SO ARE WE STILL
GOING TO HAVE A SITUATION WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE SOME
ENTITIES ARE PUTTING LOCAL FUNDS
AND OTHER ONES DON'T ARE WE
GONNA THEN.
ELIMINATE THAT FOR ALL THE
COUNTY.
THAT'S A CONVERSATION WILL HAVE
TO HAVE.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- THE
FUTURE HOLDERS IN CARE AND HOW
WE BUILD THAT IN BUT OBVIOUSLY
THERE IS GOING TO BE A NEED FOR
A NON FEDERAL SHARE AND SO I
THINK THAT CONVERSATION WILL
HAVE TO HAPPEN -- AT THAT TIME
FOR SOME INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THOSE WHO COULD NOT PUT IN
FUNDING -- OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS SO THAT THAT WE COULD
GET TO A PLACE OF HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION AND WE ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY BE ABLE TO HAVE A
STATE WIDE PROGRAM.
OKAY WELL I APPRECIATE TRêN
MOVED TO STATEWIDE PROGRAM I
THINK.
TO MOW YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT I
THINK SOME OF THE CHALLENGES ARE
GOING TO BE.
IS THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO CAME IN EARLY ARE
CAME IN AS THE PILOTS -- THE ONE
I'M GOING AWAY THINKING LIKE A
WE GOT PUNISHED BECAUSE HE SAT
FOR A PILOT BECAUSE THE ONES WHO
FOLLOWED US NOW GOT EVERYTHING%
PAID FOR WELL THEY DID GET A
HUNDRED MILLION FROM IN JANUARY
THAT WAS DOCTOR DID NOT REQUIRE
MATCH I'LL JUST OKAY.
SO THEY'RE EVERYONE'S GETTING
MONEY WITHOUT HAVING TO PUT IN A
MATCH.
ALL RIGHT WELL I I JUST LOVE YOU
SURE YEAH I IS THAT THIS IS MORE
MECHANICAL SAYING BUT ALSO LIKE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING.
TO I JUST SAID SO THE SURE THAT --
WE DON'T CREATE A SITUATION
WHERE.
BELIEVE ME YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT THE
WILL HEAR ABOUT IT TOO SO.
I DECIDED UNDERSTAND.
I APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO TAKE THIS STATEWIDE SO ALL
RIGHT EXCELLENT RIGHT UP OF A
COMMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FARMING DATING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ONE EDITORIAL
COMMENT HEARING THIS CAN'T WILL
SAY THAT EVERYBODY GETS MONEY
WITH AND THEN DOESN'T HAVE TO
PUT IN A MATCH MAKES OUR DAY.
BUT REALLY ON THE WHOLE PERSON
CARE PROJECTS THE COUNTY.
PERSON CARE IT'S COUNTIES THAT
DO PUT UP THE MATCH FOR THE
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS -- FOR
THE TWENTY MILLION PROPOSED TO
HELP NEW COUNTIES ON BOARD WERE
SO EXCITED ABOUT THAT SO
THANKFUL TO THE DH CS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PROPOSING
THAT.
AND REALLY IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE -- OFFER A WHOLE
PERSON CARE SERVICES IT'S MORE --
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT TA THE DATA
GATHERING WHICH IS A HUGE JOB
AND WAS A VERY OR FOR SOME OF
THE COUNTIES TO JOIN IN AND I'M
TEACHING CAM IS KIND OF HOW TO
COORDINATE SERVICES.
SO THIS MONEY WE THINK IT'S JUST
AN EXCELLENT INVESTMENT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD EVEN THOUGH WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS
FOR SECURE NECESSARILY IS.
WE THINK IT'S A GREAT INVESTMENT
BECAUSE WE HAD GREAT OUT COMES A
WHOLE PERSON CARE I DO WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS LIKE WHICH WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR AS WELL FOR
EXISTING PILOTS -- DTS DEVELOPED
AN ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY IN
APRIL -- THAT HAS SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE --
WE WANT TO WORK WITH THEM TO
WORK THOSE ISSUES OUT ONE IS THE
TARGET POPULATION THE GOVERNOR
INDICATES THAT THIS MONEY WOULD
BE AVAILABLE FOR THOSE LIVING
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WHICH IS --
A BIG INCLUDES MANY HOPE PERSON
CARE AND RELEASE BUT EACH COUNTY
SET THEIR TARGET POPULATION AND
HOPE PERSON CARE SERVICE PEOPLE
WITH JUST CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS AS WELL.
SO WE WANT -- TO HAVE THE MONEY
MATCH THE TARGET POPULATION IN
THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT AND
IT'S THE IT'S DIFFERENT BY
COUNTY -- SECONDLY AND LASTLY --
ON THE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY.
THERE -- IT'S THE GOVERNOR
INDICATES HE WANTS IT FOR
HOUSING SERVICES INCLUDING SHORT
TERM OR LONG STERN TERM STAYS
VOUCHERS SHELTER THINGS LIKE
THAT WE NEED THE MONEY REALLY
FOR TENANTS SERVICES SO THAT THE
MONEY LIKE.
FIRST AND LAST DEPOSIT THE
UTILITY BILL PAYMENTS LANDLORD
LAYS ON PROGRAMS THIS IS AN
ARGUMENT WE MAKE ON THE
HOMELESSNESS SIDE AS WELL.
WE'D LIKE TO MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
THE USE OF THAT FUNDING WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR
FOR PROPOSING BOTH OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THEM.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU TIM MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
AMERICAN CULTURE MERSEY FISSIONS
IN WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION FOR THE
COUNTIES OR NOT CURRENTLY PART
OF THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT.
FOR MERSEY FISSIONS WERE SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
OVERALL BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE TARGET POPULATION THESE ARE
THE FOLKS THAT WE SEE IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT ON A
REGULAR BASIS. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE RUN INTOIS
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
POPULATION WHO SEEN THE MERCY
DEPARTMENT AND THEN GET THEM
INTO THESE PROGRAMS.
AT UC DAVIS WE'VE SEEN
PARTICULAR SUCCESS WITH THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO PROGRAM WHERE THEY
HAVE A RESOURCE THEY HAVE A PEER
COUNSELOR THEY CAN SIT DOWN WITH
THESE FOLKS IN TRANSITION THEM
INTO THESE WHOLE PERSON CARE
PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERY HOSPITAL
HAS THESE RESOURCES AND AS LUCK
MY HABIT BY WERE SPONSORING A
BUDGET REQUEST THIS YEAR. TO
MAKE THOSE TYPES OF HER
COUNCILORS AVAILABLE WE THINK
THIS BE REALLY BENEFICIAL TO THE
PROGRAM -- AND BE COMPLEMENTARY
TO THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
WE'RE IN THE WITH THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR HOW TRACTORS
ASSOCIATION BE RULING BY TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF PHAM WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS -- BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
C. SACK AND THAT WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT -- TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR NEW
WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOTS AND
THAT -- WE HAVE -- WHEN WE
TAUGHT OUR MEMBERS ABOUT THIS WE
HAD SOME COUNTY SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN?
AND THEN WITH A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL WE WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT TO ENSURE
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT IT MATCHES
THE TARGET POPULATIONS OF EACH
EXISTING WHOLE PERSON CARE THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND.
BEYOND WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT
COUNTIES WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THE GOALS OF THE THE THIS ALIGN
WITH THE HEALTH HOMES PROGRAM.
A WHICH DRAWS DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDED SO I WOULD REQUEST THAT
SOME CONSIDERATION BE GIVEN TO
EXPANDING PROGRAMS THAT DO JOT
DOWN FEDERAL FUND TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT LEAVING.
MONEY ON THE TABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AKA MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA --
PLEASE TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
INVEST TWENTY MILLION TO EXPAND
TO NON WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOTS
JUST TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM C. SECOND
ROUND ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
WITH THE TARGET POPULATION AND
THE FLEXIBLE USES A FUNDING
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
KELLY BROOKS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
THE ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION -- WE SENT A LETTER
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
MILLION WE'VE SUPPORTED THE
HUNDRED MILLION AND WE SHARE
THAT -- ISSUES RAISED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT ALI SUPPORTING
REVERSING FOR GOOD FOR GROUPS
IT'S REALLY LONG NAMES.
OKAY IN THE COMMENTS AND I'M
RESPONDING -- WITH RESPECT TO
THE COMING FROM THE SECOND OUR
OTHER COUNTY PARTNERS ON THE
TENDENCY SUPPORT SERVICES -- THE
REASON THAT WE ARE NOT
PERMITTING THAT IS THAT THAT
ACTUALLY A CLEAN MOBILE SERVICE
UNDER THE WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOT PROGRAM -- AND SO WHAT WE
WERE REALLY TRYING TO DIRECT
THIS MONEY TO THINGS THAT
COULDN'T DRAW DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS --
BUT WE'VE WE KNEW I THINK WE
HAVE SEEN -- IN NEW NOT AS FAST
OF AN UP TICK IN TERMS OF
CLEANING THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THEIR SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
FUNDING LEFT SO WE WOULD
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE THOSE CARE
NEEDS TO BE DOING TENDENCY
SUPPORT SERVICES BUT DRAWING
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THAT AND
NOT USING HUNDRED MILLION.
OKAY IN A SIMPLE YOUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BE EDUCATING
PEOPLE HOW TO DO THAT OF COURSE
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
THIS WITHOUT THE ISSUE SEVEN I
THINK WE HAVE CALLED VARIOUS
REPURPOSE [inaudible]
OF THEM.
YEAH I MEAN THAT THAT I THINK
THE AGENDAS THAT'S WHAT THEY ALL
ARE STILL DOES VERY QUICKLY THE
FIRST IS RELATED TO OUR MEDICAL
FY TURN OVER AND TAKE OVER.
THE SECOND WE DID DISCUSS THAT A
PRIOR HEARING IT'S RELATED TO
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DATA
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION AND FINALLY
THE THIRD ONE IS EXTENDING THE
TIME FRAME FOR WHICH WE CAN
EXPENSE THE MONEY FOR THE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW SPEND ALL THE MONEY
THAT.
WE HAVE AND IT HAVE IT BE A
LONGER TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU LA YOU ONCE
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL RIGHT --
HOLDERS ITEM OPEN.
ALL RIGHTS MOVE ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT MEDI CAL EDGELL
ELIGIBILITY SYSTEMS STAFFING.
SO THIS IS A POSITION REQUEST
FOR THIRTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS
BEING CONVERTED FROM LIMITED
TERM AND THEN A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
EQUIVALENT TO SEVEN POSITIONS.
THIS IS REALLY TIED TO THE
INTEGRATION OF OF OUR POLICY YOU
BETWEEN MEDS AND CAL HERE'S AS
WELL AS ANY OTHER MEDS.
INTERFACE CHANGES THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO
[inaudible]
BELIAU.
COMMENTS FINANCE.
THE MEMBER COMMENTS.
PUBLIC COMMENT NO ONE WOULD
ARGUE THAT BY THE TECHS SHOULD
BE A ONE VERSUS THE TWO OKAY.
HEY WE HAVE IT ALL WRITTEN OUT
HERE SO OKAY SO WE'LL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE SEE A CALIFORNIA MMI S.
OVERSIGHT TO OWNERSHIP AND
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS FOR SO
THIS IS ALSO A RESOURCE REQUEST --
TO REALLY FURTHER ARE A TO TURN
OVER AND TAKE OVER FOR A FISCAL
INTERMEDIARY AND OUR
MODERNIZATION OBJECTIVES.
THE MAJORITY OF THE REQUEST IS
RELATED TO TURN OVER TAKE OVER
FROM THE EXISTING FISCAL
INTERMEDIARY -- TO TO FISCAL
INTERMEDIARIES THAT IS TAKING
PLACE THIS OCTOBER -- AND THEN
WE ARE ALSO REQUESTING POSITIONS
TO FURTHER OUR OVERSIGHT OF OUR
OUR OVERSIGHT OWNERSHIP STRATEGY --
THOSE NINE POSITIONS FOR THAT
AND POSITIONS FOR OUR ONGOING
MODERNIZATION EFFORS
[inaudible]
KALEO ONCE.
BRIAN MET SCALE A WE JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT THERE WS
TWENTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS AN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR
TURN OVER AND TAKEOVER
ACTIVITIES -- BUT THE R. F. P.
FOR THIS PARTICULAR -- FISCAL
INTERMEDIARY CONTRACT WAS UP TO
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN COSTS
AND THE ULTIMATE CONTRACTS THAT
WERE AWARDED AS A MENTION IN THE
PROPOSAL WERE FORTY SEVEN POINT
NINE MILLION -- AND SO WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE HAVE.
FAIR AMOUNT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THE INCREASE IN TURN OVER AND
TAKEOVER ACTIVITIES COSTS --
BETTER OCCURRING UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL AND SO IT JUST ASKS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
MINISTRATION TO EXPLAIN THE
DIFFERENCE IN COST.
OKAY FINANCE NONE OF YOU I HAVE
AN ANSWER OR IS IT THE DIRECTOR
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION --
OUTGOING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO -- AS ILIO MEN'S AND THE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL DEAD -- SAY
COSTS UP TO TWO HUNDRED SORRY
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS -- AND THE
B. C. B. FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN UP ONLY INCLUDE THE
COST -- FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ANOTHER BEING BUILT IN.
BUT THE ACTUAL LOSS OF BEEN
FINALIZED.
OKAY AND ACTUALLY I DON'T THINK --
K. ISSUE DO SO FOR THE RECORD.
SURGICAL AN APARTMENT FINANCES
AND YOUR PART.
ALCHEMY TOMORROW FINANCE THANK
YOU.
DJ BUT SOMETHING SAY.
THE ARTIST TO CLARIFY THE THE
COSTS ARE BUILT IN LAST YEAR AS
MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE WERE
FOR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS ASSUME THAT
THE TURN OVER TAKE OR WOULD TAKE
MULTIPLE YEARS SO THE INCLUSION
OF THE NINETEEN TWENTY COSTS.
CAPTURE THE FULL COST OR NOTED
IN THE RFP. FOR THE FINAL
CONTRACTS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXECUTED [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY FOR THE COMING FROM LA L.
REGARDED ANSWER.
CERTAINLY ANSWERS ARE CONCERNS
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE THE
INITIAL BCP DID SAY THAT IT WAS
THE ESTIMATED COST OF THE
ACTIVITIES AND TOTAL AND SO WE
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN HAVE MORE CLARITY ON THAT
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS.
OKAY SEEING NONE OF COMMITTEE
HOW IT ALL RIGHT SO WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN GAME.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT ISSUE IS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER MERGING
EPIDEMICS SASSER SPONSON
LICENSING WORKLOAD.
YES A FEW THINGS GOING ON IN
THIS REQUEST WE ARE REQUESTING --
SEVEN POSITIONS REALLY RELATED
TO ADDRESSING THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH ALL OF THOSE
ITEMS -- RESPONDING TO NATURAL
DISASTERS EMERGENCIES THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC WE'RE ALSO SEEING A
RESURGENCE OF METH ABUSE
HAPPENING IN THE STATE -- AND SO
WE ARE REQUESTING POSITIONS FOR
THAT AS WELL AS WE ARE SEEING AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF FACILITIES
THAT ARE SEEKING TO BE.
CERTIFIED AND SO WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION -- REQUEST IN HERE
AND THEN FINALLY WE ALL OVER
ALSO REQUESTING A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND.
TO MY GREAT OUR CURRENT DISASTER
DATA COLLECTION SYSTEM TO A WEB
BASED SYSTEM THROUGH AND I A
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
OKAY HELLO COMMENTS FINANCE.
SINCE PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT FOR HOLD THIS ITEM
OPENED I'M SURE READY FOR THESE
THINGS.
OKAY -- NUMBER ELEVEN EXTENSION
HOME HEALTH PROGRAM FUNDING MAY
REVISION UPDATE.
SOURCEW WE HAD PREVIOUSLY
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL TO EXTEND
THE THE DATES FOR THE WHOLE HOME
A PROGRAM FUNDING AND GIVEN SOME
ADDITIONAL OF LEADER STARTING
DATES FROM SOME ADDITIONAL
COUNTY AS WE ARE REQUESTING TO
EXTENDED EVEN FURTHER.
HELLO COMMENTS FINANCE COMMENTS
PUBLIC COMMENT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH ALIGNS WITH THE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HEALTH
ON PROGRAM.
OKAY SO -- CERTAINLY WANT TO
HELP WITH THE IMPLICATION ALL
THIS ITEM OPEN.
AND IN ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
MANAGED CARE SANCTIONS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR SO WE ARE
PROPOSING A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- IT WITH THE MAY
REVISION THAT REALLY
STANDARDIZING IS ACROSS OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS -- ARE MANAGED
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS ARE
AUTHORITIES TO ISSUE SANCTIONS
WHEN HEALTH PLANS ARE COUNTY
MIDDLE HEALTH PLANS OR THE
SEVENTIES ORGANIZED DELIVERY
SYSTEMS ARE NOT PERFORMING AT UP
TO THE REQUIREMENTS.
WE DO HAVE EXISTING LAW THAT
AUTHORIZES US TO DO SANCTIONS IT
IS NOT CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND WE'RE ALSO
SEEKING SEEKING TO BROADEN IT
AND ALLOW US TO DO ADDITIONAL
SANCTIONS GIVEN -- SOME OF THE
TOWNS AS WE'VE BEEN SEEING AND
OBVIOUSLY THE CHILDREN STUFF
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT PREVIOUSLY
AND SO WE'RE REALLY JUST SEEKING
A BROADENING OF THAT AUTHORITY
SO THAT WE CAN USE THAT WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE IN ORDER TO
HELP.
DRIVE THE CHANGES THAT WE WANT
TO SEE IN OUR PLANS [inaudible]
LA OF WE DO BELIEVE THAT --
INCREASING OVERSIGHT OF IN
MANAGED MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
REFLECTS -- PRUDENT PROMISING
APPROACH TO IMPROVING -- QUALITY
OF OUTCOMES WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
TRAILER BILL YET -- OUR NEW
SPENDING IS IT WILL BE RELEASED
IN THE COMING DAYS AFTER WHICH
WE WILL REVIEW IT AND PROVIDE
ANY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
OKAY SO I GUESS WAS THE WAY FOR
THE TRAILER BILL AND WE
DEFINITELY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY THE FIRST STEP IS WE
TRY TO WORK WITH THE PLAN RIGHT.
THE BUT THE PROBLEM IS IF
THERE'S PERSISTENT PERFORMANCE
ISSUES -- THEIR NEEDS NO PEOPLE
NEED TO KNOW THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES THEY DON'T JUST
DRAG IT ALL OUT OKAY.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY -- WE ALSO ARE
WAITING -- FOR THE TVL ABOUT DO
SUPPORT.
INCREASED OVERSIGHT OF MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS CONSIDERING --
OVER.
THE TEN MILLION -- MEDI CAL
MEMBERS ARE IT ENROLLED IN A
MANAGED CARE PLAN -- WE WOULD
ALSO RECOMMEND THE FOCUS BE
BEYOND CHILDREN INCLUDED ALTS AS
WELL AS DELEGATED ENTITIES --
CONSIDERING SOME OF THE THE
RECENT -- FIVE ARTICLES IN OF
FINDING -- ALLEGATIONS REGARDING --
IS CONTACT THEIR THAT THAT THE
CHAIR IS WELL AWARE OF AND SO --
INCREASED OVERSIGHT OVER MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND THEIR DELEGATED
ENTITIES THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
WELCOME TO MADDEN REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER HE MIRACLES
EMERGING VISIONS WERE ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF DIGITAL OVERSIGHT
OF THE MANAGED CARE PLANS AND IN
PARTICULAR AS WESTERN CENTER.
ON MENTION IT'S THE DELEGATED
ENTITIES THAT ARE FOLKS RUN INTO
TROUBLE WITH AND IT'S MORE
HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THEM.
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE NOT
ACCEPTING THE RESPONSIBILITY
BECAUSE THEY DELEGATED ALL THAT
DOWN TO THE OTHER PAIR SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT'S A PART OF
THIS WE THINK WOULD BE A GOOD
THING.
ON THERE WERE ALSO SUPPORT OF
LEGISLATION MOVING FOR NOT
DIRECTION AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO NO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE --
IN REGARDS TO DELEGATED ENTITIES
IS THAT PART OF THIS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IT'S NOT SPECIFIC
TO THIS -- THIS WOULD COVER SORT
OF THE ABILITY TO DEAL WITH THAT
I THINK WE ARE WE HAVE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HAD SOME
CONCERNING ISSUES SEVENTH POPPED
UP IN THE RECENT YEARS.
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED AND SO
WE HAVE BEEN INCREASING OUR
OVERSIGHT OF DELEGATED AND
SEASON GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT SO THIS WOULD SUPPORT THAT
BUT IT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY TIED
TO THAT.
OKAY SO I THE ESTATE A. THINK
WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS IS THAT.
JUST WON'T BE SURE THERE'S
CLARITY SELF IT'S THEY OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT DELEGATED
ENTITIES BUT DO I MAKE SURE THAT
AS YOU ARE ACTUALLY.
DOING THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO INCREASE CONSISTENCY AND
CLARITY.
ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN DO -- TO BE
SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS
PROCESS THAT THERE'S CLEARLY
ALSO THEN.
AGAIN WE ARE NEVER WON WE HOPE
WE NEVER HAVE A CIRCUMSTANCE WE
EVER NEED TO DO THIS -- BUT THAT
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY. TO TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AS WELL AT
LEAST THE HOURS THESE THE PLAN
HAS TO HAVE.
RESPONSIBILITY OVER DELEGATED
ENERGY BUT THE PRIDE DEL THEY
AGAIN WE TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF OVERSIGHT OVER TO
DELEGATE ANY DISCOUNTS CAN
SIMPLY SAY NOT OUR PROBLEM.
OKAY.
HI THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPENED.
FINALLY WE HAVE -- DON'T USE OF
MARIJUANA ACT TO USE EDUCATION
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT
WORKLOAD. TO THE OBVIOUSLY PROP
SIXTY FOUR WAS PASSED BY THE
VOTERS AND IT REALLY DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO A FEW THINGS IN
TERMS OF THE MONEY THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE SO WHAT WE DO HAVE TO
ESTABLISH I. A.'S WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
SO IN THE MAY REVISION IT DOES
REFLECT A HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN SPENDING FROM
THE PROP SIXTY FOUR ACCOUNT --
WE WILL BE PROVIDING TWELVE
MILLION OF THAT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
SURVEILLANCE IN EDUCATION -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WOULD BE
GETTING A LITTLE OVER EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND SLOTS
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES FOR
AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER CARE
PROGRAMS -- THE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTLY WILL RECEIVE TWENTY ONE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WILL SUPPORT LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT
EMPHASIZE PREVENTION AND
EDUCATION THAT WOULD BE THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT PER THE PROPOSITION WE WILL
NEED TO DEVELOP THE PARAMETERS
FOR WITH A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THAT WE ARE PLANNING.
AND THEN FINALLY -- THE LAST
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO FUND.
YOUTH COMMUNITY ACCESS GRANTS
THAT SUPPORT NATURAL AND
CULTURAL RESOURCES.
HELLO ONCE FINANCE.
RIGHT OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT. TWO
CHAIRMAN HOLLY MAY SHARA BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE WOULD ADVOCATE A
MORE EQUITABLE SPLIT BETWEEN
EDUCATION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS THERE
ARE.
OF NEEDS FOR OUR CHILDREN WHO
ARE OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND WE WOULD WANT A DISTRIBUTION
THAT WAS A LITTLE MORE EQUITABLE
THAN EIGHTY APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
TWENTY SPLIT THAT'S OUT THERE
NOW -- SECONDLY -- WE WOULD
SUPPORT A ROBUST ASSESSMENT --
BEFORE ANY FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED
AND I THAT AGAIN THE AT THAT THE
ASSESSMENT SHOULD BE DONE WITH
SOME STAKEHOLDER INPUT -- THE
BUT THE ASSESSMENT WOULD
IDENTIFY AREAS OF GREATEST NEED
AND GAPS IN THE CURRENT SERVICES
AND IT WOULD GO A LONG WAY IN
INFORMING.
OF FUTURE OF A DECISION SO -- WE
WE HARDLY SUPPORT AN ASSESSMENT
BEFORE ANY FUNDING IS ALLOCATED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HAVE A RAINY WITH -- COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I'M KIND OF BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROGRAMS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR BOTH ADMINISTERING IN
PROVIDING A COMPLETE CONTINUUM
OF SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
CARE FOR PROM YOU FROM
PREVENTION AND EDUCATION TO
EARLY INTERVENTION AND
ULTIMATELY TREATMENT FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE -- SEVERE MORE SEVERE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR OFFERS A
AN UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE TO AND FAST AND
BUILDING -- A ROBUST INCOMPLETE
CONTINUUM OF PHAM STD CARE FOR
YOU.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE TWO CONCERNS
WITH THE I'M CURRENT PROPOSALS
FOR ALLOCATING THE FUNDING AND
NON -- NINETEEN TWENTY FIRST BY
DIRECTING THE BALK AT THIS
FUNDING TO EDUCATION --
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES THROUGH
BOTH THE CHILD CARE AND DH CS
TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR COMPETITIVE PROGRAM --
THE CURRENT PROPOSALS DO VERY
LITTLE TO HELP YOUTH WHO ALREADY
HAVE AN EXISTING NON SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER AND WHO NEED
SERVICES THAT FALL MORE IN THE
TREATMENT SIDE THAN ON
PREVENTION -- SECONDLY WE WOULD
RECOMMEND -- ECHO IN WHAT WE
WOULD HEARD FROM CAT B. THAT --
PRIOR TO LAUNCHING A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS THAT DH CS SHOULD
TO UNDERTAKE A COMPREHENSIVE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT -- TO IDENTIFY
THE GAPS IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
AND CAREFULLY TARGET THE ON
GOING PROP SIXTY FOUR FUNDS TO
SUSTAINABLE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
CAN LARA'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
THAN WE WOULD ADVOCATING I'M ON
INCREASING THEIR SERVICES
AVAILABLE FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SPECIFICALLY.
UNDER PROP SIXTY FOUR IN THIS
HEAT TREATMENT ACCOUNT IT CALLED
FOR GRANTS FOR THE EDUCATION OUR
REGION TREATMENT.
OF HOMELESS YOUTH IN OUT OF
SCHOOL YOUTH EXPERIENCING AND
WHAT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
WE KNOW THAT THE STATE HAS UNDER
INVESTED IN YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FOR YEARS FORTY
YEARS WE ONLY SPEND TWO MILLION
AN ON GOING BASIS.
AND WHEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PREFERS TO HAVE SPECIAL FUN FOR
ON GOING RATHER THAN GENERAL
FUND SEEMS LIKE THIS COULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE USE TO REALLY.
HELP OUR POPULATIONS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
SERVE THEM SO THAT THEY CAN.
REALLY COULD AT CHEAP SELF
SUFFICIENCY LATER ON THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- SO IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE SPOKEN A LOT ABOUT
EVALUATION AND MAYBE SAYING
FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT -- THE FUNDS
A DTS THERE'S GONNA GIVE SO IS
THAT WE CAN YOU MAYBE SPEAK JUST
A LITTLE BIT AS TO WHAT THE
THESIS IS PLAIN TO DO IN TERMS
OF BEFORE DISPERSING THOSE FUNDS.
SO WHAT.
I CAN A LITTLE BIT I'LL ADMIT
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING I AM
ACTUALLY.
ON BUT DIXIE WE WILL BE HAVING A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO HELP
INFORM WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
THE MONEY ON SO CERTAINLY THOSE
TYPES OF COMMENTSWE WOULD WANT
TO HEAR -- IN THAT PROCESS AND
I'M SURE THE TEAM WILL WILL
HAPPILY TAKE THOSE COMMENTS --
WHEN THAT PROCESS BEGINS?
IS IS THIS.
I GUESS -- DTS COURSE RUN THE
VERY LARGE PROGRAMS HAD A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT THE EIGHT CS
NORMALLY DOES OR IS THIS KIND OF
IT IS SO IT'S NOT I MEAN IS THAT
SO THE PART OF THE REASON I'M
NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH THESE
THINGS IS BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
A MEDICAID PROGRAM AND OBVIOUSLY
MY MY ROLE IS OVER JUST A
MEDICAID COMPONENT WHICH JUST I
MEAN IT'S MOST OF THE PROGRAM
BUT BUT UNDER OUR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS A
PROGRAMS WE THAT WE BROUGHT IN
FROM BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE THERE IS
PREVENTION AND EDUCATION.
WORK THAT THEY DO THAT AS DODD
BROAD AND NOT RELATED TO
MEDICAID PROGRAMS RIGHT.
SO LIKE ALL OUR OPIOID ABUSE
GRANTS THAT WE'RE DOING -- YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN.
DOING FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO
YEAH WE HAVE STAFF WHO THIS IS
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY DO
EVERY DAY OKAY WELL IS STILL
TERMS OF CORE COMPETENCY OF YES
IS NO MY CORE COMPETENCY BUT IT
IS SOMEBODY ELSE'S.
THE DEPARTMENT OKAY.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY --
SO WE'LL GO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
THEN.
ALL RIGHT WELL THIS DOES
CONCLUDE THE THE THEN -- THIS
HEARING OF THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
AND WITH THAT -- WE ARE -- SO
BEFORE WE ARE ADJOURNED -- WE
ARE CONVENING AGAIN TOMORROW --
WE ARE SO THERE WILL BE FLOOR
SESSION FOLLOWED BY
APPROPRIATIONS AND WHEN THEY'RE
DONE.
WE WILL THEN WE GET TO GET THIS
ROOM SO WE WILL BE THAT'S WHEN
WE'LL BE CONVENE A CELL -- THAT
OBVIOUSLY TIME UNCERTAIN BUT
HOPEFULLY BY MID DAY SO WITH
THAT -- THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU